[Musique]
he he he
he
[Musique]
et mesdames et messieurs on est on est
parti à l'heure l'heure du déjeuner Fab
ouais nouvel horaire aujourd'hui pour
cette c'est quoi 9e ronde 9e ronde mais
attention c'est horaire aujourd'hui mais
demain c'est de nouveau 14h30 et et Fab
important la dernière ronde dimanche 14
donc là on a des horaires différents de
jour en de jour en jour et ça c'est
quand même primordial et donc
aujourd'hui la partie cindarov avec les
Blancs JAV kir contre Maxime Vacher La
Grave Maxime qui est peut-être Fab notre
notre dernière cartouche he dans dans ce
tournoi il va falloir gagner les trois
dernières c'est impossible c'est
impossible sauf peut-être pour Maxime
peut-être le seul joueur au monde ou
l'un des seuls à être capable de
réaliser cet exploit il est déjà sur du
3 sur 3 s'il fait 6 sur 6 ce sera un des
plus grands exploits échikiens du siècle
ouais ouais bon ça serait incroyable
donc bah écoute c'est toujours très dur
on n'y est pas du tout mais on peut
encore on peut encore espérer et c'est
déjà beau et donc il joue contre
sindarov jeune joueur ousbek qui a été
son bourreau à la Coupe du Monde Maxime
qui était passé à côté de de la partie
retour il avait dominé le match dans le
jeu mais il avait perdu he dominé n'est
pas gagné et aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
la la revanche sindarov qui est dans le
même cas de figure que Maxime obligé de
faire 3 sur TR mais il peut il peut il
peut jouer à l'idiot Fab sindarov et
faire un peu à l'image d'un Baki du
chantage bah moi c'est disons ce que je
ferai à sa place
euh et voir laisser la responsabilité à
Maxime en gros dans le sens où tu joues
un truc où tout le monde sait que si tu
joues la ligne normale la meilleure ça
va vers égal mais d' draw et sinon tu
peux prendre des risques ouvrir un peu
le jeu et prendre voilà euh j'essaierai
de faire un chantage comme ça à sa place
sachant que maximavi ttera le coup et
pour avoir une partie qui joue mais
plutôt avantageuse plutôt que prendre
moi-même les risque mais après pas so
dans ce dans cette philosophie là
peut-être que lui il croit aussi en ses
chances qu'il se dit bon benah j'ai
éliminé une fois Maxime peut-être que je
peux jouer une partie en prendant
moi-même les risques ou on va voir mais
mais voilà ce jeu de dupe parfois ça
peut être intéressant dans le choix
d'ouverture on l'a vu par exemple hier
avec sévian qui a joué un truc un peu
moins bon que que quec3 mais qui a amené
son adversaire son qui où était moins
moins à l'aise firouja dans le dans le
moroxzi et il jouit l'adversaire et la
situation de match c'est aussi pas bête
c'est c'est une intelligence de jeu on
va dire autre que juste t compét et
chien P et dur et B qui et B qui lui va
jouer contre pr que donc il faut qu'il
fasse aussi 3 sur TR après bah il va
continuer sur sur sa stratégie un peu du
chantage Baky en jouant tranquille et en
laissant les adversaires prendre les
risques et les contant de de manière
brillante simplement aujourd'hui là où
il a un peu moins de bol c'est qui joue
contre pr que qui lui a 5 points et demi
et le meilleur départage du tournoi
jusqu'à maintenant donc prê que avec les
Noirs là il est pas dans l'urgence
peut-être que prê que et le seul joueur
avoir une chance à se qualifier de se
qualifier en plus avec 7 points et demi
ouais donc il pourrait avoir besoin que
que de faire deux sur TR et quand tu as
besoin de faire deux sur TR tu as pas à
prendre de risque avec les Noirs c'est
complètement
stupide donc il va
probablement faire l'inverse prêre que
lui il va dire à B qui écoute c'est toi
qui est obligé de gagner ouais puis du
coup du coup personne joue pour gag moi
ça me convient la nul donc écoute à toi
de forcer moi je suis là en contre et B
quii qui pourra plus réutiliser cette
idée un peu du du chantage h euh ben
écoute on
verra ça peut être une petite nuulle si
B qui un peu fatigue de de ces deux
longs marathons des deux derniers jours
prê de Cup à oppos nul à voir mais ça
peut aussi jouer et durer longtemps dur
dire je sais pas trop à quoi m'attendre
ça va dépendre sûement de l'ouverture
aussion en tout cas notre grand Pharma
du jour sera évidemment sur la partie de
Maxime à ne pas oublier pour nous il y a
une troisième partie hyper importante
Fab et c'est la partie d'ikaru
nakakamura vu les classement ho et vu la
forme de d'Ali Reza on a plutôt envie
d'être d'être pour ikarou ici il a
besoin de faire deux etnemis sur trois
je te dirais que c'est très dur mais
c'est un petit peu comme mvl sil en a
bien un qui peut y arriver bah c'est
aussiarou he 2 et demi sur 3 c'est dans
ses cordes surtout qu'aujourd'hui il
joue contre un joueur alors très fort de
chez parinov mais vu le le le classement
actuel d'ikarou dans dans le tournoi on
peut difficilement rêver meilleur
appariment même si il est très en forme
il a battu par lira il a fait nul Lvon
nulangi nul Abd nul vugof nul contre
Rodrig le mieuxchon joueur québécois
puis battu Arian tari et Douda coup sur
coup donc il est en forme chez parinov
mais quand
même à trois rondes de la fin avec 5 et
demi sur 8 tu t'attends à taper plus
fort que je sais
pas tu sais quoi euh non ben ouais bon
apparemment pas mal pour ikarou après
joueur dangereux évidemment de che
parinof mais oui plutôt plutôt un bon
apparimment après peut-être qu'on pour
acheter un il aussi aux deux premières
tables parce que si les mecs continue de
gagner et qu'en fait finalement gagner 8
et demi c'est une autre histoire euh al
après on a Fabiano qui nous fait plaisir
ici en quelque sorte puisque lui il joue
pas pour la Calif c'est un genre de
bloqueur si bat des Hatch quelque part
il l'élimine plus ou moins s fait nul
ben pourquoi pas Fabiano hier qui a
gagné une partie au forceps contre bcky
qui enchaîne les marathons c'était déjà
un marathon la veille contre voasek mais
là encore on parle de joueur
exceptionnel Fabien et siil en a bien
qui peut enchaîner les marathons et ne
pas faiblir bah c'est c'est Fabiano
carwana oui oui non c'est c'est
admirable ce qu'il réalise après donc ce
championnat des États-Unis où il a
laissé des plumes enfin il l'a gagné
donc il a bien joué dire en terme
d'énergie et puis tu enchaîne avec ce
tournoi là et il joue encore les
premiers rôles donc bravo à lui et on a
bah vidit contre i Penko ouais là si S
un vainqueur c'est un joueur qui prend
une énorme option pour laquelle il fait
partie importante et si pienko qui hier
l'a emporté dans une très belle partie
contre Vincent CER lui aussi il a joué
du lourd jusqu'à maintenant même si son
départage va être un petit peu abîmé par
ses premières rondes où il a joué contre
VAP Sanal mon 2103 c'est normal mais
après il était juste à la limite il a
joué très bas contre jumabayev il a joué
Marc Andria aussi donc il s'est retrouvé
souvent à la limite dans le tableau
Suisse à jouer des joueurs très mal
classés et ça pourrait lui coûter
finalement avec ce départage que moi je
trouve pas forcément très juste
personnellement parce que suivent si tu
joues des jeunes sous-classés ou ben ça
je trouve que c'est un impact beaucoup
trop important et hier j'avais fait une
au dîner j'avais fait
une une démonstration par l'absurde que
le départage était
absurde on pourra la faire un petit peu
plus tard dans dans dans la journée si
vous le souhaitez mais donc aussi une
grosse partie allez on va regarder
l'ouverture bien évidemment chez notre
leader et cindarov qui ne déçoit pas il
envoie E4 C5 cavalier F3 D6 il rejoue
pas le fou B5 échec il joue cavalier C3
attention quand même sindarov de pas se
tromper là de pas aller euh dans une
nashedorf à triple tranchant et non fou
B5 échec il ne se trompe pas sindarov il
joue trèsputre non mais tu peux aussi
faire la nashdorf puis empoisonn enfin
on en connaî des ventes qui sont
ouais mais là il se trompe pas il veut
forcer Maxime à à prendre des risques
ouais ouais ouais non ou lui-même a une
idée enfin fou B5 c'est pas toujours
pour rien
faire mais euhors est-ce on peut faire
cavalier BD7 ici tu fais tout oui tu
peux faire ce que tu veux est-ce qu'on
peut faire cavalier fd7
j'en doute euh cavalier C6 on peut aussi
j'imagine un peu bizarre je pense qu' je
pense qu'il a E5 j'auris pas fait mais
c'est F c'est F je pense c'est fou des7
le
C il y a pas énormément de parties dans
la base mais je pense qu'il y a
énormément de transposition c'est un peu
différent mais tu peux pas jouer tu peux
pas jouer le maroxi non eu ça c'est
autre chose alors quelle va être ton
idée B tu des qu ouais ouais je je veux
bien mais admettons pas sûr qu' faire
prend des déjà oui non mais gen
admettons ça ça on est d'accord que ça
juste l'air égale ça va très bien pour
les noirs ou non à mon avis sur F7 il
veut jouer à 4 ou un coup
on en a vu des trucs comme ça un truc
comme ça je sais pas trop le tant les
aboutissants dans le fond mais
mais c'est juste pour faire FPR fou des
qu ça pas l'air brillant quoi ouais mais
ça élimine tout le monde des candidats
quoi ah oui oui non mais il a une idée
c'est il joue pas juste pour
t'égaliser je te dis pas qu'il va jouer
risqué
mais on peut aller voir Maxime réfléchit
il connaît Maxime forcément mais il y a
il y a des enjeux dans cette ouverture
donc il a raison de prendre son temps
ikarou chez parinof et ouais bien
évidemment la pettrof ça met les Barbel
et ikarou qui réfléchit là il y a
plusieurs options il y a cavalier prend5
évidemment il y a D4 et C3 s qu
cavaliers
ouis ça va être D4 sûrement mais pr 5
bien sûr mais on va voir on va voir et
et B qui on va regarder ses trois
premières parties et
ah pr que qui joue ouais alors c'est pas
la même ligne que by vu que il a joué k
F6 by cétait k C6 C7 mais mais ça reste
dans les dans les siciliennes E6 voilà
donc l'idée enfin pour les Noirs c'est
que sur k B5 soit tu fais D6 tu joues
une chneaker so tu peux faire fou B4
bien sûr donc soit va jouer ça soit k B5
fou B4 ouais là c'est le bordel ce truc
là c'est un truc assez solide pour tu fa
à 3 K prend C3 k prend D5 un P isolé
mais le P souvent il avance jusqu'à
D4 soit B qui bah frapp pas k B5 et tu
as l'ancienne grand ligne k prend C6 B
prend C E5 maintenant k D5 qui E4
c'est ça là qui est ouais y a pas mal de
théorie là-dessus mais ça si tu veux
vraiment jouer le gain avec les Blancs
tu peux et puis tu as tous les petits
coups à fond A3 fou 2 G3 ou quoi bon il
chois k B5 le grand coup le premier que
j'avais mentionné mais tu as tous les
autres qui sont jouables en fait
évidemment euh voilà donc aè je sais pas
ce que prê que en tête je sais pas je le
sens bien jouer fou B4 mais bon des6 bah
voilà chez snickov mais tu as évité la
variante cavalier des5 exactement la
fameuse variante que vousz pu voir en
long en large et en travers dans le
match
caroana Carlsen 2018 ou trouver sur la
chaîne principale beaucoup de parties
analysé avec Vlad c'était hyper
intéressant parce qu'on découvrait à
l'époque cette variante elle était moins
théorique c'est cette variante qui a
commencer à introduire la grosse théorie
qu'on a connu par la suite c'est très
intéressant parce que vous pouvez
retrouver un peu la genèse de la
variante et en gros elle existe depuis
ENF éit déjà joué avant c'est pas cétait
pas une nouveauté mais c'était pas trop
joué à très haut niveau alors que
maintenant c'est devenu main quoi grâce
à Alpha
Z0 alors Nakamura ah ok petite varante
qui prend et C4 OK
pourquoi
pas tu peux faire D4 ensuite ou K3 et
reprendre un pion quand
même va voir faire F 3
ouais bon écoute c'est très théorique ça
une de mes parties contre un 2100
espagnol on l'IT fa non ou on l' fa très
belle partie ah peutre pas fa peut-êre
fa
stage je pense pas qu'on l' fait sur la
chaîne pas fait les enjeux de cette
structure on a fait les enjeux
on l'avait faite ouais très belle partie
B 2080 regarde ouais on l'avait faite
exactement je te rappelle bien F F des7
pour Maxime dame alors en fait je crois
que dans le tournoi il y
a ilarine qui a dû jouer plus ou moins
de la même
manière contre Taran il y a plusieurs
rondes et qu'elle a qu'elle avait été le
r il avait gagné mais c'était assez égal
la
position c'était égal et je pense on mal
joué après il a fait un truc
bienarine est-ce que Maxim il peut jouer
au 5
ici parce que ça peut être maximesque
comme coup rappelle il avait battu tari
avec cette structure il y a pas
longtemps il avait fait une autre bonne
game mais ici avec les chens de F cas
blanche ça va pas j'aime pas trop en
fait j'aime mieux si tu échanges les
foot cas je les échang en le6
h là tu peux pas ça pas l'air terrible
non mais que c'est maximesque parce
qu'il a déjà gagné des parties comme ça
où après tu sais il te fout le fou en fi
Ketto il te décale le cavalier il joue
tout pour l'attaque ouais bien sûr mais
bon et je dans un must twin genre c'est
un truc qui paraît oui là là les fous
sont pas échangé au bon endroit mais
c'est un truc qui paraît inspide où tu
fermes tout mais en fait tu as une vraie
idée pour pour tout envoyer rappelle
gagné une belle partie contre contre
Arian tar je sais pas si tu te rappelles
il est complètement
défoncé et tu sais contre un tel tu peux
vraiment jouer n'importe quoi ah ouais
il l'avait mais il l'avait pilonné
quoi est-ce qu'on va jouer à 6 je pense
pas qu'on va pourquoi venir provoquer
cet échange finalement on peut rester un
peu en foot faillance ouais tu peux
peut-être faire je sais pas6
g fa regarder si 5 c'est une menace en
fait une menace stratégique quoi g si va
te faire quoi mais donc il te fasse 5ou
ou pas je pr G7 tu admettons que je
veille déséquilibrer la position
que tu prennes enfin tu es un peu venir
pour quand même
je peux attendre un coup de plus
peut-être mais bon disons que tu le fais
parce que tu as envie d'analyser enfin
tu fais de l'analyse facile tu roes je
en tu fait fa pas grand chose quoi pous
C 4 on le
ramène c'est pas non mais je te dis pas
que c'est grandiose pour les blancs ouis
6 qui B6 qui a des5 ouais TR enfin moi
je fais un spécial j'ai ma petite paire
de fou ou je sais pas ce que j'en fais
mais on verra bien un jour tu me fais ça
je te fais ça enfin genre je te fais des
trucs enfin je suis là quoiou mais bon
çaf je sais pas s'il est content avec
les blan ou pas mais pourquoi pas non
mais B mais je sais pas quelle est son
IDE enfin comme
j'ai comm j'ai jamais analysé la ligne
je peux pas trop te dire pourquoi tu tu
fais k C3 d'abord avant fou B5 et dame 2
mais je sa on va jouer mais donc moi je
m'interroge si tu as envie de jouer avec
le 5 parce que ça peut être un truc pour
une meilleure structure quand même c'est
pour ça que je proposais eu 5 avec les
Noirs d'ailleurs pas innocent c'était
pour essayer de jouer un truc comme ça
en me disant que tu allais prendre que
je te reprendre la dame je peux aller
essayer de te trouver cette partie et
j'essaie de t'envoyer un K sur D4 enfin
je suis là quoi je te joue avec grand je
sais plus quand c'était cétait tout tu
me fais petit regarde tu me fais petit
je fais G5 par 6 ah tu veuxg 5
ouais ouais non mais je vois que tu me
nuis mais e je fa
regarde
mais regarde ah tu doubles
fé je féli quoi je suis là quoi je
t'envoie des trucs sur ta gueule et puis
je vois
après regarde je vais te mater c'est
où je même pas je sens je peut-être tour
G8 je sa plus en
fait
sera beau de faire G5 maintenant
quoi est là un peu comme le truc qu'on a
vu de
mur c'est quoi le truc de M il avait
joué àar ici prend je peux dire la
partie tuux attends je le
truc mtass quoi absolument rien à on a
vu une photo pas on est très
heureux je peux te dire la partie de de
Sarine c'était dame 2
A6 D7 il prend petit 6 ouais mais D3 B5
la partie de merde A4 B4 k
D1 F7 B3 rock F quelle horreur D5
ou D2
B8 F4 4 C
C63 C D4 d
F2 tour C8 tour1
C7 c'est fond de oh non tour de1
finalement changement d'avis tour FD non
l'autre tour F
D8 roi
H1 dame C6 pas compris qu' était l'idé
blanche en fait tu moi j'avais vu cette
partie bon je sais pas trop pourquoi il
l' joué là il a fait un truc bien
prend et là il a bien joué je trouve il
a fait fou prend d4ouis que j'ais dire
bouffe D5 obligé de prendre d'une pièce
donc de la tour d'ailleurs F en C4 et
après il a fait un très beau plan il fou
F6 il a amené le roy dame ouais il s'est
barré lu pousser les pions et cetera
après là c'était bien joué cette phase
mais je tu vois l'ouverture j'is rien
trouvé d'impressionnant donc j'ai
toujours pas compris la l'idée derrière
enfin s de pencher dessus mais le peu
que j'ai vu je connais que ça je peux
pas dire que ce soit ça m'a
impressionnit mais c'est solide hein
évidemment tu m'as
écuré on vient de déjeuner j'ai envie de
vomir quand cette partie quelle horreur
ouais c'est dur c'est dur on voulait un
truc un peu
plus un peu plus péchu ouais là ça a
l'air d'être la purjasse mais bon ou il
fait ce qu'on a dit ce matin au petit
dage
ouais mais bah en sophistiqué mais le
truc de prendre de forcer l'autre à
prendre des ris sinon tu es vers un truc
où ça peut faire de la petite nulle quoi
mais mais bon c'est pas vraiment ce que
moi j'aurais imaginé là il fait un truc
qui joue sans trop de risque quo enfin
mais c'est ça il remet la balle quoi
c'est ça il remet la balle mais il te
force à peut-être envoyer un GCO quoi
mais peut-être que tu peux aussi
remettre et qu' un
[Musique]
moment je suis éliminé tu es éliminé
éliminer regarde parce que tu sais pas
si l'autre finement il joue pour rien
quoi peut-être qu' joue pour rien on
sait pas alors Naka il joue pour quelque
chose ou pas bon Naka il va faire r F1
je passe vite fait pour voir s'il y a eu
de beaucoup c'est théorique on va on va
on va passer Baky ah mais ça c'est
encore hyper théorique non ah bah oui de
toute façon la ch ouais ça peut clique
jusqu'au 25e non la chnikof ça peut
tomber dans une répétition en il peut
tout se passer hein euh Fabi ou là
italienne ouais mais alors italienne oui
mais italienne intéressante une nouveau
C Foug 5 t
ouais ouais
ou sympa pas genre c'est théorique ou
quoi mais genre la position elle est
sympa à jouer ouais ouis ouais il y a
des arguments de part et d'autres ça
c'est c'est des positions qu'on espérait
pour Maxim il pouvait pas avoir une
italienne mais c'est le type de position
qu'on espérait voir ça se bat de part et
d'autres là tu vas pouir peut-être jouer
avec du Grand rock envoyer les pions
l'autre va t'envoyer au centre enfin il
y a un vrai combat direct donc ça beau
beau joueur donc ok vidit c'est quoi et
Sant Gou rati ah mais c'est une
Espagnole ouais
ouais pas très péchu là pour le momentti
ouais peut-être qu'il est heureux de
faire n enfin non mais ça existe hein je
veux dire un moment tu pouris essayer de
jouer K4 avec après il a 6 points c'est
potentiellement trois nuls ouais non il
a pas joué assez de Fort pourquoi PASF
après il peut aussi se dire joue la
dernière avec les Blancs et puis je fais
un peu le chante ENF jeis non mais là il
joue une partie normale normale je suis
pas péchu quoi c'est c'est normal ce qui
se passe il peut gagner il peut tout
tout se passer hein pourquoi ça commence
si tôt bah il y a un feu
d'artificeofman donc là forcément ouais
ça passe avant quoi fa
d'artifice non on on a toutes les
parties qu'on va avoir on peut rajouter
firou mais bon attends param est-ce
qu'il est pas
bien c'est Nimzo attends je rajoute
firou je rajoute firou ouais c'est pas
passionnant ouais mais bon c'est que ça
peut quand même être si la partie elle
peut être passionnante oui oui non
regarder en fil rouge mais je veux dire
là ça joue vraiment plus pour rien dans
ce tournoi ça joue pour ses points ouais
mais les points qui peuvent jouer pour
les
candidat ça joue vite fait quoi
enfin non mais on peut regarder du coin
de l'il mais on va pas s'attarder quoi
non on va pas s'attarder mais genre
c'est pas complètement enfin ça peut
jouer parce que genre en admettant
qu'ikarou perde par exemple contre che
parinov et al gagne enfin ça rejoue
complètement le hlo donc si enfin ça
joue
euh ok kwana s ici kwana par contre
c'est bien s'il gagne qui défonce tout
le monde on n'est pas
contre bon Maxime
réfléchit victoire de carwana ça assure
vraiment que les h points passent pour
Maxime il faut que ce soit corrélé avec
une victoire de Maxime c'est plus Maxime
qui est important de base he oui non
mais si Maxime gagne pas ç Carana peut
faire ce qu'il veut ou mais par rapport
à Ikaru on est quand même plutôt pour
caroana mais de base on est pour Ikaru
et pour Maxime
après j'en aime bien Fabiano ouais il
est sympa Fabiano par par
ailleurs et juste ouais c'est quoi les
autres parties du jour enfin c'était
pour non mais le grand tableau pour voir
les apparimentss les machins donc on a
Lon qui va pas pas faire grand chose à
priori alors attends che pas machin erci
la les noir est-ce qu'il risque il joue
une française contre
qui j'ai pas de visuel pour ah il est là
ici il a une fait de CF
ok Naka les blanc euh kzubu sVAN ouais
mais svant ilira jamais ça avec les noir
c'est un truc très solide de la part de
kzubov
euh euh étonnant CF en fait de faire une
telle enfin il fait comme il veut en
même temps mais mais là tuas
l'impression que juste il saute sur nul
quoi
mais te fait peut-être le délire du
chantage dont on a parlé hein oui mais
là tu joues pas quelqu'un d'assez bon
ouais tu s'en fous quoi oui mais c'est
possible mais pe-êre mais en fait d'un
autre côté pour les jeunes genre
cindarof et cetera c'est une chose mais
genre kzubof est-ce qu'il a vraiment
envie de jouer les candidats mais je
pense tu as envie si tu peux les faire
enfin mais tu sin qu'est-ce que tu es
venu faire là en fait tu es peut-être
juste venu parce que tu sais pas quoi
trop faire et puis euh pourquoi tu
saurais ce que tu fais en avril alors si
ouais mais tu vas quand même te faire
ouvrir en deux au candidat donc bon bah
dis donc que si l'autre contre et tu
peux y aller tu va mais enfin en soit tu
fais pas trop d'effort non plus
quoi mais donc ok enfin c'est bon on pe
revenir sur des v ch en vie ou peu
importe cétait juste pour voir un peu
les forces en présence les ouvertures ce
qui se passa un peu à droite à gauche
parce que tout est important maintenant
euh et tout peut
compter bon il a une idée au moins dans
l'ouverture écoute bah il pousse le pion
h comme comme sur chaque ouverture je
crois qu'il veut tour tour machin just
une partie dans son style
h c'est pas marxi hein Maxime pris au
dépourvu lorsque la bise su venue quoi
là il ouais bon après comm je dis ça
m'impressionne pas trop cette ouverture
des blancs mais je crois que tu peux
jouer ce que tuux avec les noir après
justement il doit se réfléchir à quelle
structure il veut est-ce qu'il veut son
E5 son E6 son G6 est-ce que on fait A6
est-ce que est-ce qu'il se cl point
alors là on parlait de kzubof hein c'est
quelqu'un d'autre en fait mais doubof se
ferait exploser mais mais kzubof aussi
quoi mais là on parlait de kubov pour le
coup pas de doubof bon il peut aller
prendre ses petits ses petits Demio
enfin
non mais en enfin ce que je veux dire
c'est que basiquement si tu veux pas le
candidat qu'est-ce que tu es venu faire
ofman
en juste viens pas jouer un tour
rlicatif et que le jour où tu es en en
pôle de te qualifier tu ah en fait je
veux pas il y a quand même pas mal de
kayas fav pour pour le milieu de tableau
tu viens peut-être de base jouer la 15e
place prendre 5 6000 balles tout frais
payer
oui que tu es pas tu es pas tu vas pas
pour te qualifier quoi de base VI pas
pour ça enfin je compr bien
qu'ouvertement c'est pas ton objectif
mais trou tuas un shot
ouais mais tuas aussi un shot pe-être tu
veux tu veux sécuriser 10000 ou 15000 qu
il sa pas que les frais ouais en général
les échecs tous les T que tu vois les j
dépent un centtime ils ont le voyage
payé
l'hôtel des fois ils ont des starting
feill y a quand même beaucoup d'argent
caché dans les é tu VO quoi qu'il fasse
dans le Tour c'est ça va
quoi
tu
12 13 nu à l'hôtel Au Milie
aussi c'est
bien r
d'éche il est pas si vieux il pas je je
il est
pasendraite très fort très jeune en fait
il est en 90 donc il a 33 ouais ouais il
a 33 ans machin en fait il était grand
maître en
2005 donc à 15
ans donc c'est beau enfin je ve dire
comattre à 15 ans en 2005 c'est plus dur
que grand mare à 15 ans maintenant je ve
dire et
euh et voilà et ben justement Fab
peut-être qu'il en a marre en
fait ça fait 20 ans qu'il est grand
maître qui fait que ça de sa live non
mais en fait il a toujours jouer comme
ça c'est solide je j'ava fait la coupe
d'urope l'ann dernière avec lui il jou
avec l'an dernier la Coupe d'Europe j'
joué aussi dans son club quand on était
à grass
ensemble il est discret quoi il conteste
rien il est là quoif
[Musique]
mais bon bref mais peut-être que lui il
pense qu'il joue pour le G C position en
fait que attends fais voir sa position
tu nous int avec ce
K tu vois je vois ça je me dis mais bah
peut-être qu'il joue pour le gar oui B
oui en fait il va te faire fou 2 fou F3
il revien avec la tour il te met le P en
B3 et double les tour enfin je sais pas
peut-être qu'il est heureux quoi
peut-être qu'il est heureux c'est ça
ouais mais bon c'est vient que tu dois
être dégoûté parce que là tu sais que tu
joues pour rien cl enfin tu joues juste
faire nul c'est aussi possible qu'il
prenne ses viandes pour un abruti hein
non mais je rigole pas
ouais que prenent vraiment pour un
abruti qui dit oui contre un tel j'ai
des chances c'est possible hein tu sais
des fois
il doit dire il est très fort
tactiquement il est bon au calcul il
comprend rien je va juste placer des piè
prend C6 et gagner de contre on va voir
euh bon mais tu sais les les joueurs des
pays de là ils sont quand même un peu
cette tendance hein déjà il voit le
drapeau américain oui bon êre très fort
en
fait il doit avir oui regard comment il
a battu firou hier pour te
dire cavalier prend des des C
[Rires]
qui un tel coup quoi mais là B le P il
est pour rien je pense que même sardoch
il fait fou en fait ah bah il sa ouis je
pense mais c'est terrible en fait même
un tel que sardochura fait F pr tu
sais les leçons avec Mazo
quoi mais-ce queir est professionnel de
chess ou de chess
boxing
non mais oui
c'est il pe ils peuvent ouais ils
peuvent être assez assez assez terrible
hein donc peut-être si jou le Gun bon
Maxime qui réfléchit
ouais sur son setup donc bah écoute on
va voir ce qu'il a décidé de
faire je voilà comm je vous dis he je
connais pas vraiment la position j'avais
juste vu la partie de de Sarine qu'on a
regardébe C rien de ouf pour les blancs
mais écoute il s la jouer que lui il
répète soit il y a d'autres parties
dessus soit c'est juste recommandation
de l'ordi
récente moi je su qu'il est capable de
faire5 mais
[Musique]
bon je pense c'est vraiment pas bon
là bien la structure
c'est
dégueulasse j'adore quand ça te dégoûte
complètement le je sais que c'est
dégueulasse non mais il y a des fois où
ça va enfin je dire je sais enfin même
moi je peux faire avec des fois ce genre
de truc c'est
mais là pour5 tu as plusieurs trucs qui
vont pas si tu te fais échanger les fot
C blanche pas là où tu as envie de les
faire
échanger et de de tu as le Cali en F6
SI7 est-ce que tu peux TER cavalier
6 pour jouer 5 au
prochain je sais qu'il a mis la
structure en faitre que je fais
[Musique]
moi mais ok peut-être F prend C6
des4 çare une idée quand même ser à
quelque chose et
que si c'est ça franchement ouais
bon c'est pas si mal pour personne mais
je veux dire tu vas
faire ouais bon c'est raisonnable elle
avait le coup le plus donc euh que je
disais peut-être 5 pour les blancs enfin
c'était ça ma question
ou
euh prendre des 7 puis e 5 je sais pas
dans quel heure tu dois le faire mais
que à mon avis E5 c'est l'idée des
blancs et si c'est pas ça l'idée bah je
sais pas ce que c'est mais que peu
importe
je peux chercher mon ordi pourer des
parties tout ça qu'on PL plus vas-y
vas-y toute façon on a que ça à regarder
donc pour le
moment de jouer hyper théorique mais
Onar pas regarder un truc similaire à ça
d'ailleurs à la partie de
B Fabiano çaun partie
intéressante ça l'air
sympa
mon trouvve que c'est un joli prénom JAV
kir moi j'aime bien c'est pas mal c'est
joli et notbe en fait c'est vraiment
très bec parce quef s'appelle aussi et
puis
B genre le prénom normal c'est Jean ou
ou mais jaavokir je trouve c'est très
joli comme
prénom je sais pas comment ça se
prononce en réalité peut-être c'est Yav
rire je sais pas mais je trouve que
c'est un très joli prénom il a du bol
quoi
enfin non mais tu as des tes prénoms
comme ça que même enfin même tu lesas
jamais rencontré que c'est c'est pas
c'est pas ta langue ou quoi entre
guillemets tu sens que c'est beau h tu
vois il y a un JAV kir quoi non il y a
un équilibre ça sonne ça ouais il y a un
équilibre
alors le cage se prononcit à la russe
rend peut-être la pration moins belle je
avoir rire mais après c'est pas russe
hein c'est Bek c'est pas la même langue
il a fait E5 hein ouais
B
alors sur dame de juste pour te dire je
de
regarder il a fait pion prend et dame 5
c'est très très rare mais il sait ce
qu'il fait hein non non mais sûrement et
dame 2
euh il y a qu'un bon joueur avant ce
tournoi avant qu' Sarine qui joue
c'était le petit George Cory qui a joué
en blitz donc on s'en fout il kzminine
en 99 donc c'est pas du ordinateuresque
mais kzmin très fin ouais qui sait la
puissance du fot cas blanche sur fot cas
noir euh ok bon ben donc il eu de donc
il g6ir je vais juste allumer la turbine
voir ce qu'il disait sur 5 dame 2
pour dans le
mouvement mais il connait là c'est un
peu
relou mais tu vois c'est chaud regarde
la ligne de la petite turbine c'est qui
C6 d prend C5 ok ça Maxime il peut
vouloir faire hein
donc ok G6
main5 main
ok je laisse un peu monter en puissance
en grade
laisse-le monter en grade mon
Fab apparemment ça signifie
bijou
ça peutêtre aucun rapport en fait c'est
peut-être une info chat mais tu ça peut
vouloir dire Bou non mais c'est joli
quoi tu sens que c'est
joli je pense que Maxim il peut
jouer bon la ligne sinon c'est que tu
fais F
B5 cavalier
prend il va te jouer ou
D44 on prend tour et ça tu te dis que tu
gagnes jamais h donc tu élimines enfin
si tu es Maxime dans cette partie et
même peut-être tu vas un peu être moins
bien parce qu'il a je sais pas le fameux
3 compre de et cetera mais ça doit pas
être si terrible pour les Noirs mais bon
gros c'est pas pour ça que tu joues donc
à mon avis il fera pas
euh tu peux faire
donc dame
B6 si tu veux garder le
pion sur quoi je m'attends
A4
et C6 maintenant6 tu tu bouffes
ouais il faut prendre du Fou obligé
parce que D prend5 qui te fait chier ok
admettons mais mon fou fr c'est aussi
logique tu touches F3 et on te fait
A5
dame Mo en B4 mais P 6 pasid tu donnes
un pion Mo A6 ouais ouais non avec la
situation de peut-être j' en B4 en temps
normal mais j'a peut-être ouais al dame
à 6 dame C5 ouais F G
D3 euh bon fa peut-être prendre F3 un
jour je peux pas t pour encore un
coup par que j'ai pas envie de te donner
la case B5 pour moi disons que je t'empo
je te fais
rock bon priori petit rock B ok je te
bouffe en F3 quand même ouais
euh ouis il va nous faire du Tour à
4re mais il y a desoun cont il y a des
semicompensations enfin il y a des
compensations c'est Mme pas semi he euh
non je t'annonce que Maxime ça peut déjà
regarder Manu tour C8 t reprend C3 qui a
des enfin ouais ouais je sais pas enfin
ça je suis content avec les Noirs je
t'annonce hein je pense les blancs ce
qu'ils veulent se ramener la dam E3
faire tour à 4 pour non mais tu es pas
moins bien attention mais je là vu la
situation de tout je si j'ai ça à la
sortie de l'ouverture je signe hein non
mais ça peut être ça ou l'autre comme
tuavais dit c'est k C6 dame fr C 5 ouais
[Musique]
et plusieurs coups possibles 6
à6ouense pas qu'on échange C6 moi a 4 Mo
en A ou C 48
ouaisck73 petit
rock dame 3 je P be là-bas ça j'aime
moins to qui un pion de moins et j'aime
pas ça ça c'est pas du tout mon truc Fab
ouais euh non tu ASAS un peu de jeu vite
fait mais c'est moins bon Maxim ça peut
être mais finalement ce qui nous semble
pe-être le plus contre balancer c'est
dam B6 puis en plus tu donnes pas de
pion bah tu vas finir pour en donner un
mais l'autre doit ouais mais là à court
terme en tout cas tu le donnes pas non
donc nakas ça joue ok on va voir bon
voilà pour B encore théorique donc chez
Maxime il y a pas trop de de théorie du
tout et franchement ça a pas l'air une
vente transcendante pour les blancs mais
sans être mauvais
hein j'é l'ordi on relimera si on a
besoin dans un moment pour le moment il
se passe rien de spécial ailleurs donc
peut rester tranquillement sur sur
Maxime Maxime qui tank beaucoup hein il
enfin il tankque
énormément
écoute je pense pas qu'il va faire fou
PR5 je pense d' B6
vraiment mais bon avec son style
grenfeld je donne un pion machin ça
peuttre qui C6 maisam BC c'est ouais le
plus déséquilibré qu'on ait pu
voir
t parce qu'il connaît pas là je pense he
ah non non il connait pas du tout là je
pense qu'il connaî pas du tout
ouais mais après c'est aussi parce qu'il
doit jouer pour le gain et qu'il doit
chercher comparer voir ce qu'il pense
lui donne le plus de chance ou
pas après là faut clique hein
malheureusement oui oui mais bon gen là
c'est normal de réfléchir non c'est
normal mais gen faut pas réfléchir
encore 20 minutes de plus quoi HM un
jour faut
CLIL
un jour il faut clique bon ben écoute on
attendin n pr chat dame B6 ouais mais ça
tu es content qui D5 qui prend D5 faut
prendre des7 qui prend D7 dame prend H8
cavalier F6 ça tu prends tous les
jours ouais bon évidment faut regarder
pas bête
mais dans sal
dras éche qui arrive tuas B4 tu as déjà
des menaces en fait à Paris il faire
rock du coup grand ro ça jourer tous les
jours
déjà faire des TR pour l'éviter pour
pouvoir on pourra peut-être le faire
mais je pense c'est tôt en façon on
pourra le faire plus
tardà des problèmes non mais ça les blan
peuent pas rentrer làdedans
non non mais après par contre que tu te
vérifies bien avec les Noirs parce que
cl l'a il joue tout tempo tu dis estce
qu'il y a pas une manœuvre où la dame
ressort et j'ai don une qualité comme un
con euh logique mais en soit c'est pas
un problème
ou
alors ça réfléchit écoute Fab
ouais bon on a l'habitude hein c'est
normal hein c'est un moment normal pour
réfléchir mais bon on est un peu on a un
peu fait le tour là dans les autres
parties enfin c'est toujours une partie
en principal mais dans les autres
parties c'est pas c'est pas le feu
encore il y a pas trop de mouvement là
part c'est pas ouais alle resa qui va
jouer
gain k en vis ouais mais on a fait le
tour on a dit k C6 dame B6 c'est les
deux coups qui paraissent les plus
logique hein
ends faut prendre 5 bien sûr qu'il doit
aller mais je crois pas qu'il va faire
pas avec la situation
non avec la situation j'y crois pas trop
mais en soit ça doit pas être un trop
mauvais coup même si en fait
ouais
mets le cavalier là-bas a tu auras du
mal à gêner le cavalier B 5 je sais pas
ça aurait pas été mon choix moi j'aurais
choisi dame B6 c'est sûr
quasiment enin en tout cas j'aurais
essayé de faire marcher dame B6 juste
que ça m'aurait saoulé de donner le
pion non B6 à 4 c'est le plus logique
enfin c'est des 5 faut regarder ça
aurait pu être chiant
euhb6 à
4 mais ok il doit savoir tout ça c'estf
évidemment si a fait une prépass use il
est préparé sur les trois coups quoi il
a joué jusqu'à tarère Sindara fais
voir 40 coups non non il a resté du
temps à la fin en plus non mais tu vois
ça c'est aussi une information qui peut
être importante
ou c'estvec le changement de rythme
enfin le changement d'heure pour pour le
le regarder des des parties c'est vrai
que tu peux avoir fini hier à 21h
22h donc tu rendes tu
bouffes tu vois l'appariment bon ben tu
as quand même envie de dormir un moment
euh tu as pas trop de temps pour te
préparer alors tu as le même rythme bah
tuas quand même 3h de plus jusqu'à
présent donc ça te casse un peu ton
rythme habituel et si tu avais besoin de
pas mal de temps pour te préparer euhah
pas facile donc encore pire pour les
joueurs qui ont joué très tard et qui en
plus é crevé
un changement horaire pourquoi à cause
d'un feu d'artifice apparemment ce soir
mais il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui se
sont plains mais c'est sûr que pour un
temp qualificatif ou quoi ça répond à
aucun standard séeux c'est pas sérieux
après bon écoute on voit des problèmes
dans plein de sport je pense à Bercy là
le Masters sm où il y a CER qui a fini
son match à 2h30 du mat la programmation
le lendemain il a fait walkout hein
ouais mais c'est pas pareil c'est pas
pareil mais parce que là c'est
équivalent de demi-finale de grandchlem
où tu fais jouer les mecs à 7h du matin
enfin je dire non mais je comprends bien
mais et puis il y a pas de public il y a
pas de ENF je je veux dire ça arrive
c'est con à chaque fois quel que soit le
truc mais là c'est vraiment idiot quoi
non mais au tennis il y a enfin je
comprends que c'est débile mais bon en
fait il y a des raisons là c'est juste
que
c'est et puis bon tennis comme je disais
c'est des to comme berc tu en as 20
parents entre les grands Chelem Mo
master quand même ouais mais tu as C tu
as qu grand CHL qui sont déjà audessus
mais je veux dire en a 15
par c'est encore ENF je sais pas encore
dur à dire mais en fait tu es en train
de tu fracasses un joueur en particulier
enfin
me là au moins c'est tout le monde qui
est sur un pied d'égalité qui joue c'est
comme si tous les joueurs jouent à 2 du
mat au tennis la rigueur vrai SAF échec
tu as aucun public tu as aucun autre
problème que de faire commencer les
parties à la même
heure d'organisation c'est quand même on
s'en fout duartifice quo
décaler une partie pour un feu
d'artifice ça j'avais de 3 He en plus
c'est pas une demi-heure ou quoiartifice
qui va aller voir ça au mois de
novembreofman il faire 10 degr ou de la
pluie en plus quoi je veux dire fait le
14 juillet comme tout le monde et puis
[Musique]
voilàon c'est une partie quiand même
important dans ton cle de championnat du
monde c'est pas un tournoi pas un grand
ch tour quoi
c'est étonnant que fédération elle
impose pas pour des T aussi
importants non ou le deuxième truc c'est
que si tu sais que tu as ça tu choisis
la date B en dehors ou tu mets la
première ronde toujours là que si tu
commences 11h du mat en fait et que la
ronde 2 la 15h ça te dérangera personne
bah dans l'autre sens ce serait moins
dérangeant mais là comme ça c'est
dérangeant où tu finis ce jour-là parce
que tu fais toujours la dernière ronde
plutôt Jeur rend l'habitude alors
d'ailleurs c'est une c'est une tradition
qu'on pourra enlever hein ça mais au
moins ça dérangerait Mo parce qu'ils ont
l'habitude que ça se passe comme ça
euh mais bon bref bon c'est comme ça on
a l'habitude de
s'organiser je sais pas comment dire
mais mal
et et ça ne coupe pas la règle alors
d'ailleurs ils font un truc très bizarre
je sais pas si tu es au courant les
filles commencent plus tard aujourd'hui
en même temps donc le feu d'artifice
c'est pas très grave c'est vrai je
savais pas ça ouais ah bah mais mais
pourquoi ils ont la même cadence
pourtant ben je écoute je sais pas quoi
te
dire pour on est d'accord que c'est la
même cadence oui c'est la même cadence
c'est sûr ou une autre cadence non mais
ah j'en sais rien je perd les cadences
peêre à cause de
ça il dit c'est pas tout à fait la même
cadence ouais oui mais bon c'est pour ça
en
ok quoi ça peut quand même durer
longtemps peut-être leur partie
quoi non mais c'est de 20 minutes quoi
1h 30 1h40 mais peut-être qu'elles ont
moins de rajou elles ont peut-être pas
le rajou du 60e bon le jour où aura une
partie de 180
coups je sais pas trop quoi vous dire
quoi
mais
Maxim faut jouer quand même au bout d'un
moment il faut cliquer là au bout d'un
moment tu dois prendre une décision
qu'il va y avoir d'autres choix à faire
plus tard qui seront tout aussi
important voir plus important donc il
faut prendre une
décision on 30 minutes 50
aprèsutut Raj au 60e
mais elles vont pas te déranger quand
elles vont aller s'asseoir je sais pas
s'il jou dans la même salle ou quoi mais
oui enfin si c'est dans la même salle
c'est un peu bizarre après elles feront
pas trop de bruit mais oui ça ça te fait
du mouvement ça fait quand même des
chaises qui grincent ça fait quand même
du truc même si tu veux faire
gaffe donc bon non je sais pas c'est
étonnant un truc de plus étonnant on va
dire dans l'organisation mais en fait
juste pourquoi ils ont pas la même
cadence c'est mais j'en sais rien fa
c'est en fait leur cadence c'est mieux
hein enfin genre c'est plutôt pourquoi
on n pas mis la même cadence en mix quoi
enfin 1h30 plus 30 secondes ça va
hein si on fait un tour deschiquer juste
voir ce qui passe à parce que là on
attend à F ikarou
ça ouais ouais c'est pas trique mais oui
c'est c'est normal rien
pass
B
Fabi ça
joue
etitcout il joue son petit plan il va
essayer de faire marcher enfin il va
jouer pour A4 très prochainement mais fa
m'inquiète un peu quand même
ouis il a gen de position qu'il voulait
enfin je sais pas à quel point c'est
bien ou pas pareil j'ai pas trop étudié
ce genre de truc mais surtout pas qu'il
perde quoi c'est ça qui est
embêtant il y a pas de raison qu'il
perde en il peut comme tout le monde
mais sa position est pas
particulièrement mauvaise non plus
quoi firou ça a l'air d'aller fou il
envoie dans son élément là il dans son
élément la tour va arriver vers G3 le
fot cas blanche sûrement
D3 il a les pièces qui pointent vers le
roi c'est j'aime bien moi genre de
[Musique]
position cousp on va voir qu je crois
qu'il je viment le G avec son truc non
mais il aime bien jouer les petits trucs
tranquilles sans risque F F1 B3 cavalier
A4 G3 fou G2
et bon
bravo on reste quand même sur Maxime
allez faut faut clic Maxime jouer un
coup c'est con ça ou faire une longue
réflexion sur ce
coup maison là il y a déjà tank 40
minutes quand même depuis non mais en
plus c'est le fameux truc à la firouja
tu fais G6 moi je te dis depuis tout à
l'heure c'est clair que c'est 5idé si tu
fais G6 bon l're fait et tu retankes
après ilêtre plutô cavali 5 mais bon du
coup c'est pour ça qu' faut clique parce
comme tu sais tellement pas ce qu' va
jouer qui on la prép pas au bout d'un
moment tu vas peut-être être surpris dès
le prochain coup
quoi tu es surpris à chaque coup non
après bon je suis pas un qui réfléchisse
parce que il faut mais non mais doit
calculer très très loin parce que là
c'est pas anodin quand tu F ton pion ou
quoi mais justement il se il s'épuise
quoi alors que c'est du
clic fa un peu clic et B qui
euh alors bon ben écoutez c'est ce genre
de
position des chez sneakof quoi où on a
un bon contrôle central des cases
blanches avec les blancs mais les n La
perire de fou un jeu plutôt dynamique
euh donc en fait l'un dans l'autre ça
contrebalance mais c'est toujours des
positions où ça joue c'est pas juste
égal sec quoi
c'est un peu tout se passer quoi
pr que qui doit vouloir gagner aussi he
il doit se dire que pour lui finalement
c'est pas un si mauvais shot de tenter
de battre Baky ah non mais bien sûr si
prê de que il se met bien
mais bon je ve dire c'est dur de gagner
ave contre B donc tu peux pas jouer en
prenant tous les risques après si tu as
ta chance tu une partie qui joue et que
ça se goupie bah faut être pr à sa
chance après tu peux aussi dire que B
vient d'avoir deux parties à rallonge
qu'il a perdu hier ça pe met un coup sur
la Caraf que c'est peut-être le moment
de non je suis d'accord pourquoi pas
enfin de tenter quoi ah mais si tente
c'est tout pour Maxime
ok6 donc ouais je dit V son son côté
genre de grünfield qui aime bien jouer
avec un pion de moins
euh bon ben du coup ça dame prend C5 ça
c'est sûr
ou faut prend C6 fa prend C6 et prend C5
mais ça para un peu bizarre non mais
autant prendre
direct le K C6 va pas s'envoler et
peut-être même tu vas devoir jouer à 6
et que on va gagner un temps pour le
prendre donc
euh
donc oui non d prend C5 c'est sûr et
donc le plan des Noirs ça de faire fou
G7 ro tour
C8 il jou un peu cette activité mais
Maxim aime bien ce genre de chose donc
jeux dire c'est pas un mauvais choix de
sa
part après ça peut juste mal se goupier
entre guillemets dans le sens où où
finalement les blancs trendent le pion
et sèche et et nul quoi mais en soit
objectivement c'est c'est pas
mal prend le 6 ok
ok al du coup d'ame 3 peut-être tu veux
qu'
B4 ça a dû calculer loin côté Maxime
h et sur dame C4 il veut A6 fouprend
fouprend ouais mais c'est Dame de ouais
bon tu joues ta conversation avec la
paire de fou machin franchement c'est
pas con hein je pense qu'il y a pas de
coup brillant ici hein G7 ou quoi ça
va ce qui m'qu j en gen de position
c'est tu as l'impression que les blancs
ils vont rendre leur pion tu vas le
récupérer que nul disa c'est ce que
c'est ça le risque en fait c'est pour ça
que je préférrais dame B6 mais même
l'autre he je sais pas
trop dans l'esprit ça que j'aurais voulu
garder le
pion après l'autre peut aussi avoir
envie il un pion de plus tu peux essayer
un peu jouer le gain et on sait bien
comment ça peut se passer des fois non
non mais c'est écoute c'est pas mal
comme début de partie euh on
verra
euh et voilà tu penses qu'il se rappelle
encore sindarov ici non
a c'est fini non par contre il peut sair
à peu près le plçon de pièces mais je
veux dire E6 je crois pas que c'était le
coup main moi quand je regardais et
peut-être tu as a 6 tu as tour C8 tu as
fou G7 ouais ouais tu as beaucoup
possible ouais donc tu vas peut-être pas
tous les
avoir donc je pense que là ça VAE jouer
mais par contre qui sache à peu près ce
genre de scénario qui peut arriver ça
c'est normal et donc peut-être tu sais à
peu près comment tu dois mettre tes
pièces pour pour ger
l'initiative si tu as fait sérieusement
tu dois
savoir on va voir en tout cas c'est
chaud Fab c'est
chaud car il se passe rien B il se passe
rien pass rien
r faire la petite pause en attendant
coup de quoi la B dans son la B dans son
C on lui a renvoyé la balle Fab à lui de
voir et à lui de réfléchir il va comme
tu tu nous as lâché une info quand même
importante il doit plus connaître donc
ça va réfléchir c'est le moment de de
faire la petite pause et et on revient
on revient très vite les amis à tout de
suite à
toute
[Musique]
he
he he he he
he he
he
[Musique]
alors les amis il y a eu il y a eu
quelques coups Fab Fab va revenir il y a
eu F pr C6 F pr C6 et dame 2 donc c'est
ce qu'on attendait entre guillemets dans
dans la partie de Maxime
ouais ça va faire un truc comme fou G7
rock et jouer B5 le le risque en réalité
de de de tout ce ce truc là c'est que on
va avoir un pion de
on va générer de l'activité contre le
pion et il y a peut-être un moment où le
mieux qu'on pourra faire ce sera de
remanger
le de regagner le pion en créant des
échanges en obtenant une position
légèrement inférieure ou égale mais sans
trop de vie donc c'est c'est un peu le
le problème auquel Maxime peut être
confronté c'est le truc un peu
inquiétant enfin inquiétant il fait ce
qu'il peut enfin tu peux pas à un moment
donné si les blancs font pas de faute
les Noirs pourront jamais gagner une
partie d'échec mais mais on va dire que
le prix d'une faute pour les blancs peut
ne pas être trop élevé après
euh ça peut aussi dépendre des véléités
des véléités blanches des vélités de
cindarov qui peut avoir envie de gagner
et du coup je un truc un peu à la limite
pour pour transformer son avantage
matériel et là ça ça peut ça peut
réellement devenir intéressant femme oui
bon en fait tu as bien tu as bien résumé
la situation situation est
résumée 7 ro B5 sont les prochain coups
des Noirs je sais pas dans quel ordre
mais j'is7 en premier ou tu une tour c8è
ta dame l'utre en D8 et
pression peux peutre tu peux même essêre
avec F G7 TR B5 et peutêre pour un peu
original tour à 7 dame8 tour C8 tour C7
vraiment pour avoir full originalité
mais tu fais peut-être toucher par le
fou noir c'éit pour essayer d'avoir un
truc un peu différent mais j'avais envie
d'essayer de faire naviguer cette dame
làbas ça pourrais non non mais je pense
qu'il est content Maxime de la
position maintenant il va falloir jouer
[Musique]
précisindarof je sais pas s'il est
content ou pas mais en tout cas si J c
ouverture c'est que tu sais que ça peut
arriver donc normalement il devait se
douter que ça pouvait se passer comme ça
surtout connaissant Maxime cé assez
logique qu' ve don un pion pour s'activé
plutôt que jouer l'autre assez plat
après
après je sais plus là dans l'ouverture
mais5 et compagnie
quoi mais après il réfléchit longtemps
ça on peut pas on peut pas lui enlever
Maxime mais je suis un peu étonné qu'il
rebloque j'aime pas trop ces scénario
comme tu disais ça rappelle un peu le
scénarioou quand ça joue comme ça un peu
par à
coup pas toujours bon signe
ouais et firirouirou l'ordi aime bien
ok très bien moi je c tu vas faire fou 3
dame D2 F prend c'est peut-être des fois
tu peux m'er prendre direct pas
maintenant parce qu'il F G5 mais par il
a une très belle position ala encore une
fois pour les pour les candidats via ce
tournoi fini après c'est entre une nulle
et une défaite il y a 5 points et l're
différence donc c'est ça va vite les
points sont chers donc on prend
évidemment
ikarou ikarou il va jouer le G enfin il
joue le P isolé ah B il joue le G depuis
le premier coup mais on verra s'il
arrive ça c'est une autre histoire mais
en tout cas il va tout tenter
Baky du quoi eu tour B8 et tour E2 tour
A2
ok ça joue hein les on sait pas enfin
c'est pas pas qui joue pourquoi mais ça
joue Fabi Fabi surtout pas qu'il perde
pour nous mais bon ça on verra si nous
on gagne de notre
côté cas position intéressante et à
triple tranchant vidit ça a pas avancé
mais ça peut être intéressant son truc à
à Sant bienite les
positions qui se joue petit à petit sans
trop de risque ave des petites idées iou
là tuas un meilleur fou tu peux taper un
peu C7 à un moment la Colona si sur pour
le moment vidit et s'il gagne 7 sur 9 il
se place idéalement Fab non clairement
s'il gagne il est très très
bien mais c'est pas fait évidemment
spinko il joue bien et je peux pas
direette position soit très grave les
spinko mais voilà les blancs
il je sais pas il peut-être jouer tour
B1 et et
A4 per désolé j'ai eu un bug tourb à 4
ouis ou moi je pensais qu'il G3 et A4
s'il y a pas de ouais ou C D5 tu peux
aussi5 puisque sur cavalier prend pion
prend tu mets le
cavalier C6 mal et après tu peux faire
D4 enlever tes pion rejouer avec ta dame
sur la diagonale donc bon on va voir en
tout cas intéressant pour pour vidit
kzubof bah ouais il a fait le B3 le fou
F1 il te faire le g3re le fou en G2
maison
non c'est plus pour svant c'est un peu
pénible
position impénible je sais pas si tu
comptes gagner si tu comptes pas gagner
bon en mesure de tenir là tu sais que
gagner tu t'oublies gentiment
quoi Maxime quand même ça pour moi ça
réfléchi un peu
trop on a déjà dépensé 50 minutes mon
Fab
les coups joués sont pas mauvais mais là
faut peut-être mettre un tu vois une
petite accélération petite pointe de
vitesse fou G7 Rock Tour C8 B5 allez Bam
Bam Bam ou au moins fou G7 rock B5 voir
ce que lui compte
faire toute façon les coups tu les
connais hein fou G7 il va sûrement te
faire
rock tu peux faire B5 ici pour éviter le
A4 il va peut-être te faire D3 et puis
là tu verras est-ce que tu veux B4
peut-être peut-être pas rock tu peux
quand même arriver à cette position et
voir là ce qui te fait oui non mais dire
il y a plusieurs options là pour les
blancs ah bah après c'est lui de voir
son pass son pièce est-ce qu'il voulait
d ou B3 tu aussi oui oui c'est ça c'est
qu'en fait tu toi tu es cous son logique
et puis l'autre il a quand même
plusieurs options puisprès taave tu fais
ton tour à 7 le tour C8 est-ce qu'il est
inquiet de ça tuis je me dis est-ce que
un truc direct genre un cavalierco qui
tombe ouais mais du coup tu commences
par B5 tu t'embêtes pas tu fais fou G7
de toute façon la Caval 5 tu fou prend
il te fait rock là tu fais B5 au moins
sur K5 au pire tu fou B7 ouais et là tu
vois tu vois ce qu'il ve faire comme tu
dis est-ce qu'il ve jouer B3 est-ce
qu'il veut jouer A3 est-ce en fait là
c'estme Ren c'est c'est son problème
mais donc je suis enfin c'est pour cette
raisonl que je trouve le moment vu
l'éventail de possibilités pour javir
mais qui sont toutes possibles mais
aucune va te vraiment te mettre mal
c'est peut-être pas le meilleur moment
pour retant 10 minutes quoi ben je sais
pas ce que toi tu en
penses cavalier D5
ok bah on a la réponse à notre question
ouais ok alors ça le mérite d'être
intéressantjà première question
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur cavalier
E5 parce que je crois que cavalier F4
qui C6 h tu as pas le temps de prendre
de et si tu prends G2 il a roi F1 ro
prend
G2 et si tu prends C3
ouais comme ça sil prends C6 tu prends2
il prends D8 tu prends C1 tu rest avec
une pièce de plus mais attends il
reprend
b7elle
attaqu4 pas facile parce que cavalier C1
ça doit pas gagn ah peut-être tu a 5
aussi bon mais bon c'est pas si mais bon
du coup peut-être cavalier 5 il ve qu'
C3 DC fou prend G2 bon ça je pense c'est
es content t G1 bon on joue une partie
d'échec mais je sais pas c'est peut-être
dangereux pour les Nord moi je préfère
les blancs mais là tu joues une partie
d'écheac ok mais je préféris jouer juste
F G7 ro B5 Mo aussi que voir ça quoi
mais je vois pas quelle est l'autre idée
sur cavalier E5
le4 cavalier C6 ouis non c'est CER C6
ouis bon si c'est ça oui c'est non
euh donc déjà cavalie 5 question vas-y
voir 5 C3 si c'est ça le truc DC normal
fou G2 tour G1 je trouve ça dangereux
moi pour les Mar mais bon ça se trouve
ça va hein Dame des 5 c'est dangereux de
part et d'autes quand même hein parce
que là à long terme tu es quand même
nettement mieux avec les Noirs
maintenant
h bon faudra analyser avec la plus
grosse turbine F voir attends on va on
ouais comment mais genre on va regarder
l'éventail des autres trucs par que le
aande petit rock et petit rock je
comprends pas ce qu'il veut ah il veut
cavalier B4 toucher D3 fou prend F3 dame
prend F3 qui prend C2
ouais je comprends parce que si le main
c'est Dame prend B7 qu'il faut regarder
ou mais bon C6 tu le vois quand même
ouais ouais maisame C6 7
ça tu tu vas te prendre une pistache
ouais des5 qui Arve
PIST le T pass
quoi prise
ouais le cavalier je sais pas enfin pas
clair
ça tu pas déjà il avait plus fort que ce
que je raconte he vu que il y avait dame
B7 a priori d'après l'ordi mais je veux
dire ça minima tu vois que [__] mais
alors attends on en était où on était à
petitrooc cavalier B4 D3 fou prend F3
dame prend F3 qui prend C2 dame prend B7
tour B8
non tuas fait oui mais je
admettonsou d C6 dame D7 dame prend
pr
ou donc retourne n
moutons on a dit quoi on a dit petit
rock cavalier B4 D3 prend F3 d pr F3 qui
prend C2 et la dame prend B7 intéressant
OK
donc et si tu fais juste fou G7 c'est un
peu con d' commomencer par C D5 en fait
aucun intérêt puisque que tu aur faire
fou 7 et cavalier D5 tu as juste donné
des options pour
rien donc r est-ce qu'il veut cavalier
F4 peut-être non il y a juste dame
ah tuas pas un truc comme
ça
en fait je voulais ça juste pour montrer
au chat
euh en fait le coup qui me dérange le
plus perso mais il est pas comment dire
c'est pas le coup de l'ordi c'est qui D4
par qui F4 cette fois tu as dame 5
bêtement qui va arriver non peut-être
pas là je je je pense humainement mais
euh en fait il joue pas ça alord il joue
qu' pr C6
ouais ça retombe dans le truc qu'on
regardait tout à l'heure ouais pas
terrible et du coup en fait tu serais
obligé de faire le K B4 sur4
ou alors tu peux faire k prend C3 pere
ça son idée mais c'est une meilleure
version clre fait DC et sur fou prend G2
pour G1 t ouais mais là ça
chauffe fou d des5 fou quelque part je
sais pas com tu veux d des5 on va
dire faut trois grand
rock
pour
toute ouais mais j'aimais mieux l'autre
avec lesations B5 cétait pas assz mais
moi non plus j'aime pas trop mais bon on
va faire confiance à Maxime quand
même bon pour le coup c'est pas le cou
main juste moi qui te
dit c'est quoi c'est c'est
prend prend on pas regardé maison par
qu'on disait que un peu l'idée de Maxime
prend 5 ouais
prend G7 G5 aussi
j'ai pensé mais dis on F
G7 G5
maintenant plusieurs coup mais il fait
D4 et sur G4 il fait
C4 prior de rentrer nor tout etchange
les trucs
et si je fais qu' prend dame prend rock
et que je perds pas de temps je fais G5
direct mais j'avais peur de d'ame 5 mais
c'est peutêtre bête en fait il sugère
tour1 et ça va être une transposition G
4 dam 5 ouais je pense ouais c'est pour
ça que je faisais pas comme ça ouais
c'est pas sûr peut-être l'ORD dit que ça
va pas ce que je raconte G4 non mais G4
il nime pas trop à cause de C4 toujours
le même ressource ah tu arrives pas à
rester tu ok j'ai
compris mais qui prend dame prend
rock et si je fais fou D6 ouais tu veux
jou grand les P euh ouais mais sauf que
du coup je me dis sur C4 j'aurais dam h
5 h et je t pas ça c'est assez
scandinavesque je sais ouais je joue
vraiment comme une scandie quoi je m'en
fiche euh ouais écoute c'est pas débile
hein déjà pour commencer et T 1 grand
rock ouais je joue comme une scandie les
DC 4 et tu vas faire d'age 5 et je do
faire
H3 mais pourquoi pas bah là je te fais
G5 ouais non non mais là pourquoi pas
oua ah mais tuas encore ça c'est
horrible mais bon je dire ok sent que on
peut s'inquiéter un peu non mais qui
prend des je crois pas qu'il va le jouer
avec les Blancs même si euh c'est un
coup
euh un petit rock c'est un coup bien sûr
dans la position de départ ouais
ouais
évidemment genre j'imagine
fa G7 non et moi je pense que je vais
fout D6 wou
ok peut-être mais bizarre non
mais
alors bah c'est déjà là où tu voulais
aller de base avec un f
G7
je je
faire fa que je fasse marcher mon truc
mieux rock je faire cavalier F4
premier5 faut que je
malin je te fais dame C7 tu peux B je
peuxer pr si je veux c'est version
ouais mais c'est peut-être pas si grave
prend fou prend je cont la case C4 je
peux te faire fou D6 non mais tu peux
faire il y a toujours le CAH
des4 qui me gêne plus en
réalité mais att F4 quand même ça marche
pas bien mais bon ça c'est dur à voir à
cause de dame
C4 ça il peut rater l'autre et tu peux
pas me
prendreou pas facile non
du coup ch objectivement mais en soit
pas c'est quoi le truc
pr
je je suis content
H4
il me m'empêcher G5 en fait ça me fait
penser au truc dans la carocane làent
une enfure mais il va peutêtre mais H4
il va pas l'avoir non non il va faire H3
il va pas faire H4
ok H3 disons allez H3
ça cl bah moins bien c'est mieux pour
les blancs
ouais enfin en fait en gros si nul ça te
dérange pas tu peux faire prend F3 d
prend prend C2 et cetera mais mais
sinonement il va juste faire C4 et ou
ouais ou comme une scandinave qui se
passe mal
ouais faut que tu a chercher le pion
quoi euh donc je sais pas bon vrai dire
les BL ont plusieurs options il y a rien
qui trograve pour les Noirs mais et k
prend des5 et k D4 et petitck et petit
ro on et le fameux C 5 regarder de base-
qu' dit c'est jouable en fait mais c'est
chaud c'est pr C3 DC fou G2 ouais ça ça
finalement c'est ce qu'on veut peut-être
le plus c'est Dame D5 tour G1 dame D5
ouais ça c'est peut-être ce qu'on espère
le plus Fab euh alors attends faut qu'on
poursuive le rentre parce que il y a e
fou G5 et k G4 ici K4 bon ça cré des
menaces quand même c'est concrète on
doit ah fou G7 tu fou H6
ça TR en plus hein comm TR en plus je
pensais que der TR c'était forcé à
priori grand serait peut-être jouable
mais bon dire F3 plus on est content
d'échanger les
dames fou
G5
G7 F6 prend prend F3 F prend F3 F6
dégag ça c'est de gagner la colonne D on
l'a
jamais j'aime un peu mieux les blancs
mais juste un peu mieux c'est pas non va
ni gagner ni perdre que perdre ça paraît
difficile aussi quand même mais
ok
euh 5 pr tour j'ai un dame D5 et G4 ok
au F3 il y a aussi grand R qui est
jouable bizarrement parce qu'on s'attend
à C 3 quand même sauf que fou F3 k prend
D5 fou fou2 k B6
C7 fou G5 médiaire
ok bon moi je fais la la plus la plus
normale ah mais F G5 c'est fort parce
que tulè la tour de la colonne D c'est
juste en fait de les l'URA de toute
façon grand cavalier fou prend pr
échec si env mais si tu es là tu peux
faire
P la tour de la colonne et tu prends et
ro prend
B6
il a la colonne D quand
même t
D16 t
G4 non ça fait que bon ça doit aller
mais d'imaginer gagner
[Musique]
quoire dou tour
tu vas tu vas de toute façon pas gagner
ouais ouais bah écoute oui bon après tu
mets que les premières lignes de l'ordi
pour les blanc à tout moment il fait
dame B5 on en parle plus
enfinteint l'ordi d'ailleurs euh bon
bref les blancs il y a pas vraiment de
truc déjà il y a rien qui réfute les
Noirs mais mais il y a beaucoup
d'options qui gardent un petit avantage
voilà ou bon qui t pe-être vers nul mais
après il faut savoir que j'aiavokir en
fait nous on part du principe c'est très
mauvais nul pour nous et que bah lui il
veut faire nul mais d'un autre côté s'il
a un peu mieux c'est c'est aussi quand
même un mauvais résultat pour lui donc
c'est pas dit qu'il rentre dans les
trucs qui sèchent complètement enfin
c'est c'est pas garanti Fab c'est pas
garanti du tout je peux pas te dire
c'est absolument jamais garanti Naka
chez parisov ça va pas jouer Baky c'est
compliqué
carwana c'est très compliqué
vidit il a l'air d'encore connaître ça a
l'air d'être un peu la difficulté pour
rcipienco à voir après il quoi surain B8
c'est ça ouais puis joué dame B2 et puis
et voilà kzubov il est très heureux il
est très heureux je pense qu'il est
vraiment très
heureux non ilre comme ça
ouis solide
euh alirea il a fait fou 3 alirea ça
pourrait être une
masterpiece et et Maxime ça joue et
maoridi est-ce qu'il se passe quelque
chose d'intéressant après on va moins
regarder parce que ça joue plus pour
rien quoi c'est juste par curiosité ah
mais il joue contre
saden mais c'est le même truc un peu que
que vidit quoi pas complètement mais une
bonne prépa il est peut-être bien bon
mais après c'est pas euh on regardeer
plus en début de tournoi parce que c'est
intéressant là comme ça ça joue vraiment
euh on a trois rondes de deux qualifié
au candidats donc forcément l'avant du
tournoi est très
intéressant
et le bijou qui réfléchit
ouais pour le coup qu' D5 ça m'a
vraiment surpris mais c'est sûrement
parce qu'il ve mettre le fou en D6 sinon
il y a aucune raison
de il veut se garder l'option de fou
D6
comment avec un pion de moins bah il
compte tenter hein non l'avantage je
sais pas si un avantage mais il a la
paire de fou dans une position ouverte
toi tuas un fou cas blanche pas
l'adversaire tu as des colonnes pour des
tours et cetera donc tuas une certaine
pression après je évidemment si les
Blancs jouent au mieux tu gagnes pas
mais mais tu pose des questions en
pratique en tout
cas a faut vraiment comprendre he que
avec les Noirs enfin comment tu gagnes
avec les Noirs si les jou le blanc jou
les Blancs jouent parfaitement ah ben tu
gag jamais tu peux jamais vraiment
gagner donc tu peux pas dire avant ver
ça j'ai envie te dire en fait mais avec
les Blancs tu peux exercer une pression
avec les Noirs tu si le mec joue
parfaitement tu pourras même pas mettre
de pression donc comment tu comptes
gagner avec les Noirs c'est déjà bon ben
tu es dépendant de ce que font les
blancpendant en fait tuespères qu' va
pas faire une connerie
ouais et B qui B qui c'est pas clair
après compliqué position que c'est pas
c'est pas inf facile hein c'est pas
c'est pas un marrant à
prendre bon sindarov ça fait quoi il a
déjà une bon quart d'heure de réflexion
là sur cette position attends on a c'est
simple on a fait la pause on a lancé la
pause à 35 après il a joué quelques
coups je pense il est déjà à 10 minutes
là sur ce coupl
oui mais là il peut il peut il peut bien
réfléchirin c'est un moment important de
la partie il y a tellement de coup poss
possiblebl k des4 k 5 petit rock prendre
des
5 prend des C je ferai pas trop moi j'ai
pas envie je sais pas il me plaît moins
spontanément déjà même un coup on a Mme
pas regarder çaê de la merde mais dame
5 bon tu fais juste torger vite hein
mais tu peux commencer à réfléchir un
peu voir à quel point faire torger vite
F D6 tu repars il va jouer avec grand
rock la tour sera mis en G8 qui en H8
donc c'est pas très bon jamais fait d' 5
qu mais non mais tu peux te dire tiens
est-ce que je peux pas faire tu tu as le
temps de perdre une minute dessus quoi
dans le dans le mouvement
tu peux perdre une minute dessus ou il
fait déjà 17 minutes de réflexion ouais
mais c'est pas étonnant ça se sent que
c'est pas moment qui réfléchit mais là
ce que j'aime bien en fait c'est qu'il a
plein d'options équivalente finalement
ouais il y en a pas une V ouais mais ça
des fois c'est pas mal parce que le mec
il peut réfléchir 40 minutes il sait pas
trop quoi choisir et tout d'un coup il
peut faire de la
merde quand tout se quand toutes les
évaluations se ressemblent trop tu peux
péter un C
on demande ce qui devient karyakin on
sait pas trop il avait été suspendu mais
là je sais pas s'il l'a encore il s'en
fout un peu non ouais il jou un C4 ou
peut-être qu'il joue vite fait des trucs
en Russ temps en Russie en fait il veut
pas jouer s'il peut pas jouer s'il est
pas son drapeau pour faire
simple
donc il joue pas il fait sa vie
quoi n Ding avait moins de 2300 avant
ses 15 ans alors attention joueurs
chinois ils sont tout temps sous-classé
parce qu'ils veuvent pas jouer de
tournoi donc il faut pas
ouais pas comparer l'incomparable
hein les joueurs des fois indiens ou
chinois quand ils viennent ils prennent
400 points en en un
an 300 400 points auudessus de Lalo
oui benah en fonction de où tu joues le
nombre de parties que tu fais et cetera
ça dépend
et une autre époque évidemment mais
kramnck plus jeune en fait crramnick n'a
jamais été EMI
quoi pourquoi être i quand je veux dire
c'est ça enfin non mais normalement tu
pour cé pas petit à petit mais en fait
il faisit aucun tournois vraiment
internationaux donc bon il nit pas de
titre et quand il a fait un truc
international qu' allit faire les
Olympiades et qu'il allit faire euh je
sais pas si 9 sur neu ou 8 sur façon est
chi ou quoi bam B bam en fait il est
passé grand MRE direct
quoi donc euh donc tu peux pas dire h ou
regarde crramnick il était grand MRE
très tard oui mais c'est une autre
époque euh il aurait fait les tournois
peut-être qu' va été grandêre à 15 ans
ou avant ou après ou que j'en sais mais
euh mais donc
ouais c'est pas trop pertinent en fait
de savoir si ou ça quoi
mais il faut comparer ce qui est
comparable h bon ça réfléchit hein queté
jaav
k que
fairec une danse pour les trois
résultats
je sais pas pas trop réfléchir comme ça
tant mieux plus il réfléchit tant mieux
mais après pour le moment on est encore
loin des trois résultat
là prod en plein en fait mais je peux
pas vous dire ça va
arriver qu'on est on est dans les trois
résultats mais on est très loin de
victoire ouiou on est plus dans victoire
blanche et dans dans nul on est surtout
dans nul
ouais on va déjà essayer de sortir de ce
de ce secteur là et puis on réfléchira
la gagne
après
ils sont encore sous classés en Chine ah
bah ils sont toujours sous classés mais
en fait ils sont sousclassés dans tous
les pays ou ils viennent pas trop en
Occident il viennent pas trop en
Occident o on est très surclassé ici
mais je crois c'est plutôt qu'ils sont
sous-classés parce qu'il joue peu mais
tu vas dans n'importe quel pays B Vlad
me dit c'était quoi C en Macedoine
ouais je crois que c'est la Macedoine
c'est un enfer en fait ils sont hyper
force en fait il me disait je préfère
jouer un 2003 2004 français qu'un 200
c'est donien mais ils sont horribles non
en fait le truc il joue jamais de tour
class Fed c'est qu'en plus je dire ça
veut pas dire qu'il joue forcément mieux
que le 2003 2004 français mais en tout
cas il a 300 points l de moins bon pour
niveau équivalent tu préfères jouer
ouais mais c'est que sil te fait nul il
te défonce il prend des points Lau quoi
mais VO dis en fait tu joues contre les
mecs ils ont joué trois tourn fi dans 5
ans quoi ils jouent souvent euh non mais
je sais chez eux enfin ils s'en fout du
ho quoi en fait ils sont normaux juste
ils s'en fout du
hlo ils jouent pour jouer quoi pour
progresser pas pas pour avoir des points
quoi c'est des gens
normaux mais donc oui dès que tu joues
contre des joueurs qui sont dans des
pays comme ça où il y a peu de de
tournois homologués feed les mecs ont
des hos ridicules et ils jouent très
bien
une question sur le top 10 mondial je le
regardais en fait il est à peu près
normal le top 10 mondial il carlen
Carana Naka normal Ding normal nepo
normalouja bon il est peut-être un peu
sur ce qu'il propose mais qu' soit dans
le top 10 c'est pas choquant so ça va
kakin toujours là bon il joue plus mais
il est là
Anand pourquoi pas
Dominguez doming pourrait ne pas être là
il pourra être remplacé par Guir ou par
Maxime rapporte sonelon la forme mais il
y a pas d'énormes surprises soit ces
joueurs là dans le top 10
quoi il est pas vraiment biaisé quoi tu
peut-être param qui va arriver C4 il est
en forme et puis tuas un changement de
génération tu as des joueurs plus
anciens comme Mara foiran qui baisse un
peu grinchou mais c'est la force des
choses c'est comme
ça et puis on verra si les jeunes ce
qu'ils font mais ils ont du mal à
confirmer quoi enfin ils sont là mais
pas encore
2750 ah Vichi oui non il a plus deine du
tout Vichi hein mais quand il joue il
fait pas n'importe quoi il joue encore
pas mal hein mais il joue peu et je sais
pas il approche des 55 ans non donc bon
on va pas trop lui ont demandé
quoi
ça réfléchi côté Chav
bijouana Gaé nous
[Musique]
intéresser tellement
compliqué c'est devenu ça
l'italienne normale
l'italienne tu te prends G5 et compagnie
c'est tous les jours
quoi tu fais plus ton petit Jo
piano fout des v je regarde s'il y a eu
des dingueries là en fait mon fou est
très bien Naka ça joue
ok ça joue
pas tu es déjà là en massdine d'ailleurs
je crois
pas parce que Vlad ne veut plus y aller
quoi ben ou normal TR sousclassé dégager
je veux plus vous voir même pour ne pas
jouer quoi
tu le vois ici ou là il était à la Coupe
du Monde il a fait un parcours pas mal
je crois euh on le voit dans les grandes
cha tours euh ou ser là ouais il est un
peu là
quoi mais oui tu vois pas dans les open
mais bon on voit pas beaucoup de joueurs
dans les open de ce calibre de toute
façon
tu comm à beaucoup réfléchir chez Sindar
ouais ça ça réfléchit ça réfléchit ça
réfléchit position est intéressante et B
ça joue ou pas du tout non tropun qui
viarap écoute en gros Maxime il a donné
un pion pour s'activer un peu tu vois
position avec per de fou pas clair comme
il aime bien on verra
c'est
ça va dépendre un peu de comment joue
sindarov aussi pour l'instant notre
serve central c'est que c'est correct ce
qui fait Maxime AC les blancs bon si te
rendent le pion pour simplifier nul
probable mais après c'est pas dit que ce
soit ça dans les plans de sindarov qui
veut peut-être garder une position très
compliquée et là tout est possible tout
est tout est
imaginable
voilà
allez réfléchis mon grand là on prend la
réfléxion Fab faut réféchir fa une
demiheure juste plonger dans le livre de
Yanan il appelit ça le
scafandrier tu te mets ton scafand et tu
plonges dans la
mer des
variantes ouais il est très heureux
raconte une partie contre un mec après
14 coup il rest 10 minutes j' réfléchi
1h50 c'est vraiment gros plonger dans la
position du coup il le
défonce le scafandrier mais j'adorais le
mot c'est pas mal c'est pas mal c'est
imagé c'est
bien c'est une merde quand même aussi
quo non tu es très heureux quoi mais ton
scafond va plonge quoi nous on avit ouis
roman qui adorait faire ça quoi c'est
vraiment un
plongeur dans les grandes profondeurs
quoi
non je connais pas le jeu là je sa
pas dame 5 pas non dame 5 tour G8 tu vas
te faire chasser as on peut vous montrer
mais je veux dire ouais d 5 on pense
qu'ils vont juste bouger la tour les
noirs et après tu vas te faire chasser
la dame voir de ce côté hein mais je
dire plutôt ici la Dame Noir bouger
allez en C7 et grand rock et donc en
fait après il y aura les fous braqués
par là-bas et la tour elle sera pas si
mal elle sera même bien parce qu'elle va
aider l'avancer du ponger donc dame 5
c'est probablement la enfin c'est la
fausse bonne idée mais c'est normal de
l'envisager hein euh pour le coup il y a
pas de souci
euh mais on va vite l'éliminer
normalement avec les
Blancs Maxim le plan long terme non long
terme c'est que tu fais jouer étais fou
tu met sur les colonnes tu vois où est
le roi tu tu fais
un et tu le défonces quoi voilà mais ça
va demander que l'autre fasse une
bêtise Maxime avait été mieux contre lui
avec les Noirs la dernière fois il avait
réussi à le à le dribler à le bousculer
dans la position avec avantage il avait
raté un truc pas super dur mais bon
tjours pareil aux échecs un coup un coup
détaché des autres est pas super dur
mais c'est tous les trouvé qui est dur
il en avait manqué un pour prendre le
dessus et Fabi on dit Aï une gaffe
encore non mais ça me rend fou en
fait ouais les échecs c'est pas un truc
que tu c'est dur en fait
à
regarder non mais genre je comprends
quand tu es amateur tu vois un point
d'interrogation et tu comprends pas
forcément que c'est pas si grave mais
peut-être je dis pas qu'il est gagnant
quoi mais c'est pas si grave son coup il
est déjà logique dans le plan et il y a
pas de grosse réfute c'est pas comme si
fil une
pièce mais je pense que cette évolution
d'ordi ça fait du mal fait ah ou ou tu
cherches plus jamais rien à comprendre
avec ton cerveau bah tu regardes la
barre tues la barre et tu regardes les
trucs qui te popent à la tronche
et PE rien c'est pas nous qui maîtrisons
les sites et compagnie mais je vous
suggère vraiment de pas le faire et de
regarder les parties sans évaluation
mais j'ai remarqué un truc là
dernièrement enfin j'ai remarqué tout le
monde a remarqué en fait mais il y a
vraiment une grosse baisse de de la
popularité des échecs sur les
plateformes type YouTube même twitch
enfin partout en réalité mais ça été
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup poussé par
les algorithmes et j'ai l'impression que
ouais
c'est c'est trop du superficiel en fait
les gens il ah mais personne cherche à
bien enfin personneespère a quelquesun
mais personnees cherche vraiment
s'intéresser aux échecs en profondeur et
de deux oui peut-être ça été trop pouche
ça m un peu superficiel tout ce hype
tout ce qui est fait machin et j'ai
l'impression que
c'est et sinon pourquoi on dactive pas
bah là on n pas sur blit stream en fait
hein on fait ce qu'on nous dit de faire
quoi nous ditésationésation enfin moi ça
me va aussi hein mais en
soi si vous regardez comme là ceux qui
nous disent Fabi a machin c'est que vous
regardez vous-même donc vous vous pouvez
mettre ou pas
mettre après vous regardez S et puis des
fois vous pouvez rallumer pour confirmer
ou infirmer votre opinion de la position
ce que vous avez cru mais de se forcer
un peu à réfléchir à faire marcher le
cerveau bah c'est bien euh et ça sera
plus utile dans une démarche d'essayer
de de progresser et même que soit soit
stimulant intellectuellement plutôt que
je regarde une barre qui monte et qui
descend
quoi bon c
D53 Alesa ça a l'air de bien se passer
visuellement c'est
cool c'est5
ouais B il veut ouvrir un peu la grande
diagonale marquant c'est compliqué il a
une pièce de moins mais il a trois pions
c'est intéressant
ouais je sais pas trop qu penser
mais
peut-être visuellement j'aurais pas fait
quand mêmeta pas si
mal B écoute c'est peut-être enfin
c'est un peu léger pour jouer le G
mais c'est talesque quoi
c'est peut-être fort je sais pas c'est
dur à dire c'est intéressant B ce qui
m'embête c'est que les de faire des 5
ça moi aussi je si on avait C4 avec les
Blancs ouais tu fais C4 B5 oui mais là
là tu vas te prendre dame bouge et D5
ouais alors sinon tu do échanger les
dames mais c'était pas trop ton but de
base si tu commences à avoir ce genre de
position les pièces elles vont être
fortes ouais et le Roi peut devenir
faible donc à
voir que ça marche bien le livre ben je
sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas les ventes
euh je peux pas trop vous dire on compte
sur vous pour pour vous le le
procurer il y a quoi le 3 novembre peux
regarder vas-y regarde hein il est
là alors le 3
novembre s'est bien passé quelque chose
le 3 novembre ou al il y aura un conseil
il y aura un exercice il y aura un truc
hein
partie célèbre en fait voilà bon c'est
c'est un truc en deux journées le 2
novembre c'était un petittique sur
l'attaque de nuit et le 3 novembre c'est
une partie célèbre sur l'attaque de nuit
de Rudolf
spinman beau
joueur voilà donc voilà c'est pour bien
débutter novembre c'est son son
anniversairenersaire de mais on l'a pas
ici pour l'année proch chaîe ok quand on
refera une nouvelle édition envoyez vos
anniversaires on remplira plus
facilement comme
ça c'est quoi le livre bah c'est un
c'est ça un Almanac 365 jours pour
gagner aux échecs c'est son titre et
chaque jour quelque chose une date ben
oui chaque jour une date c'est logique
mais ça peut être une date célèbre pour
la la naissance d'un d'un joueur connu
pour une partie qui s'est joué ce
jour-là qui était importante pour un
tournoi pour un championnat du monde
pour je ne sais quoi euh ça peut être
juste un conseil ça peut être une
citation ça peut être un exercice euh
plein de choses voilà c'est varié et tu
en as pour toute l'année tu as même un
29 février on l'a pas
oublié
voilà donc en fait c'est 366 jours en
fait
oui c'est un peu comme le cahier d'échec
exactement et comme le gagner aux échecs
tout cours le premier livre de Kev avec
couverture les gens s'y retrouvent en
librairie code ouais c'est pas la même
mais ça bien sûr ça fait penser
quoiateur qui offre un à Pierre TW pour
pour son
anniversaire
bon mais ça réfléchit quand même
beaucoup pour cindar c'est bien ça ça
plombe pour le moment pendant qu'on
parle on parle on
parle French Fighter est-ce qu'il connaî
fais
voir super der Liv en tout cas pas pu
attendre le 1er janvier pour l'ouvrir ah
ben merci
ouais c'est pas4 le mat mais c'est un
mat de
cavalierou ça être un beau cadeau
d'anniversaire aussi
au cadeau anniversaire cadeau de cadeau
de tout de pour si vous connaissez des
amateurs d'échec et tiens un petit
cadeau pour la nouvelle année pour Noël
pour je sais pas quoi hop ça peut voir
le coup puis vous pouvez vous l'offrir à
vous-même aussi si ça vous intéresse
euh voilà en gros l'idée c'est de d'un
peu mieux connaître le jeu euh
l'histoire les joueurs et cetera et
cetera
quoi fait peur de cavalier C4 alors c C4
c'est vrai que si tu si tu fais le
déplacement du cavalier d'une case en
diagonale peut-être tu peux faire un un
zigzag le fameux zigzag du cavalier mais
bon je pense pas qu'il ait peur de cette
règle spéciale du jeu non mais donc F4
euh oui évidemment c'est c'est une des
idées mais c'était pas la question
Fabien non non non je sais don ça parle
de cavalier C4 et ça parle évidemment de
la règle de la croix du croix d'agneau
hein mais il faut faire le double 6
avant non faire le double 6 avant et si
tu fais un double double 6 tu peux après
manger la dame sur re bond donc c'est
évidemment est-ce que ça lui fait
peur toujours le risque de devoir faire
le double enfin tu vois sortir de double
6 comme ça sur demande c'est pas
forcément simple après tu dois
l'envisager B c'est fa beaucoup de
chance ouais peut-être tu dois mettre un
P en D3 du coup pour au cas où il arrive
ici ouais il va pas te manger la dame
direct tu intercepté
après il est largé sur les règ d'ch ou
mais le règle de la Croix d'agneau est
rarement euh mais c'est ça TUC pasass
naps pour pour comprendre
ouais
alors on dit firou f Il A4 à tempo mais
l'autre il a peur d'aller faire matter
en fait donc il Essie de bloquer ça crée
de nouveaux
problèmes donc je comprends ce qui se
passe mais i il est très
bien allez c'est
bien TR fairete
[Musique]
vaêtre c'est pas mal
n tout le
monde pas on est même endroit
maximitar ça bouge
doucement
ti est-ce que c'est pas ouais fou G4 ça
est-ce que c'est pas fou F5 dame 2 et F
G4 est petitte nul qui peut faire
plaisir à tout le monde en fait ou à
personne mais c'est comme ça quoi
après
Fabi aime bien mais bon enfin c'est le
bordel hein
oui oui ben jeen sais pas moi enfin non
mais de candidat ça serait wou
après écoute s'il gagne ses parties non
mais bien sûr mais je sais que c'est de
la loterie de toute façon c'est tour la
coupe du
mond personne il a fait nul tar battu
Enriquez il fait nul Malou nul corobof
nul kubof et tout d'un coup il a b
j
personne au candidat là gagne
évidment je trouve que c'est n'importe
quoi en fait ce grand Suisse je suis
désolé mais non mais tu fais le grand
Suisse et tu prends les huit premiers
ouais mais là quand même nul tar machin
tu fais nul mal cou kurubov kubofas
B enfin il est pas encore il est pas
encore qualifié mais bon on va voir les
parties quoi mais bon tu vas jouer ma Bf
non mais il est déjà il est pas encore
qualifié la partie il l'a pas encore
gagné quand même grand c'est pas
grandiose quoi enfin non mais après faut
le faire son tournoi ça il fait rien d
qu'on dit wou incroyable
mais tu es invaincu après ne9 rond tu as
joué une moyenne à 26 et quelqu tuas mis
plus 4 dans la tête t bon tu as fait ton
tournoi quand même mais je comprends que
c'est pas waou et que et qu'en soit on
préfère voir Naka et d'autres genre ok
ah mais just que tu sais que s'il joue
un match en 10 parties contre Naka qui
est pas sûr de se qualifier ou contre
firou va perdre donc pour moi il y a il
y a un côté qui va pas avec ce grand on
va pas refaire le débat une une Dième
fois on l'a dit une fois deux fois 10
fois mais juste à chaque fois que jeis
des truc comme ça possible bah après
faut bien qualifier les gens d'une
manière ou d'une autre hein ah tuas un
truc qui s'appelle le ho qui mais tu
sais on AJ le même problème avec le hlo
c'est que les gars une fois que tu as
monté ton hlo tu joues les petits tour
ferm tu fais tu fais nul entre toi et tu
forces à faire 6 si si tournois et tu
sélectionnes je sais pas tu prends une
liste de 60 tournois dans l'année qui
sont forts parce qu'il y en a et tu dis
bah tu dois en jouer si sur ces 60 et
puis si tu en joues pas 6 et ben ton élo
il compte pas et puis c'est tout non
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que quand
tu joues les T fermés tu as un avantage
quoi quand tu ah mais peut-être je
compte pas les ton ferm peut-être quand
é obligé de jouer je te mets des Open en
fait tu faire le catar le truc quoi
ouais et le tu faire le grand Suisse
enfin qui sera peut-être pas
qualificatif en soi mais qui compte dans
la je te mets je te mets deux fermés et
qu open
enfin tu fais pas ce que tu veux mais
toujours oui non mais évidemment enfin
en fait c'est chaque fois par quand
toute façon c'est un événement qui
qualifie un truc c'est le risque que
quelqu'un soit très en forme question de
forme
c'est les mecs s'envoi en l'air et tu en
as un des deux qui gagnent enfin je sais
pas comment dire et après il te joue
Naka il te joue machin ils sert tous
pour faire nul et quand il joueent entre
eux ils jouent pour gagner donc
forcément ça fait un système d'ascenseur
c'est obligatoire non mais je comprends
le c'est tu as forcément un ascenseur
c'est obligé ils vont te fermer quand il
jouent contre les forts et après quand
ils jouent entre eux ils vont tout
risquer les deux non mais c'est la
réalité du truc enfin je au bout d'un
moment c'est un beau tournoi c'est pas
le cas c'est c'est pas le mais
bon ne favorise pas les gros hos mais il
y avait la CDM pour la Coupe du monde
pour les gruelo mais non mais
c'est c'est pasire de ou pas enfin mais
dur à dire enfin ok je suis pas compte
je suis pas je sais pas non mais il y a
trop de places qui sont de la loterie en
fait sur les h places il y en a que une
à Léo c'est tellement peu alors que
c'est le truc qui est le plus important
tu vois ce que tu vois tu en as une que
tu as pas de toute façon vu que c'est le
finaliste ouais d'accord donc sur les
SEP tu en as une à Lélo et tu
si bah qui ça répété B nous on pensait
que ça ferait nul he av la ou nous on
pensait que Bul bah en fait il suit by
sa stratégie de de tournoi c'est-à-dire
ben moi je veux pas prendre de risque si
vous voulez faire nul je fais nul si
vous voulez tenter de gagner c'est votre
problème quoi je c'est une bonne
stratégie c'est une très bonne stratégie
ça c'est peut-être même sûrement la
meilleure et et ça porte ses fruits donc
là aujourd'hui nul contre prête que
c'est pas un mauvais résultat bah qui
reste bien placé alors plus pour ce
qualifié quelque part il accepte que la
qualification est vraiment fin en ayant
perdu hier mais cétait vra il pouvait
essayer tenter machin faire le 3 sur TR
mais c'est pour ça qu'on vous disait en
préambule que pour Maxime fallait
surtout pas jouer contre voassek ou
contre Baki parce que c'est deux joueurs
en fait qui ne jouent enfin qui jouent
pour se qualifier mais si tu dis nul et
je POC monalif il y a pas de problème en
fait c'est ça leur pose aucun problème
et donc c'est assez malin sauf que là
bah prê que lui comme il a un demi-
pointo de plus B il te dit oui bon ben
moi aussi en fait là j'ai pas besoin de
te battre donc donc faisons nul nul donc
faisons nul euh du coup voilà non ben
qui au tournoi bah pour le hlo pour
gagner voilà il a aussi des beaux prix
il joue aussi pour des beaux prix donc
je sais pas jusqu'où il y a des prix
mais je pense qu'il pas mal de PL primer
et puis bah pour le Loo aussi évidemment
mais c'est c'est c'est une très bonne
décision de Bakis voilà son adversaire
aurait pu B qui est fatigué et tout dire
ah ben je prends des risques pour gagner
mais il a pas pris bah ça avait payé
contre you hein cette stratégie et et
même pendant le tournoi ça a plutôt été
une une stratégie payante donc
euh je je trouve le le choix de Baky
excellent
top 10 c'est déjà dans les 20 cas voilà
c'est ça donc tu as pas tu as très peu
de chance de Ré 3 sur 3 en prenant tous
les risques tu as tu prends 99 % de
chance que le truc rate et tu peux tout
perdre pour rien ouii tu prends ta
qu'est-ce que tu t'embêtes que prê que
s'embête s'il a envie de s'embêter par
que pr que maintenant il doit faire de
sur de peut-être en réalité bah il verra
c'est son problème aussi c'était un bon
oui mais genre c'était peut-être un bon
shot pour lui mais peut-être que prè il
dit aussi moi jeen fout qualifié j'ass
ma place dit je prends mes vinqueurs et
là on est peut-être entre deux joueurs
qui V l'assurer mais c'est pour ça donc
qu'on était pas mécontent du de de
l'apparillement de Maxime par qu'il
aurait joué VO ou ou Baki c'est toi qui
est top mondial c'est à toi de te
démerder moi si je me qualifie pas j'en
ai rien à faire prends tous les risques
et puis si tu t'empales tu t'empales
donc en certain sens et pour Baky et
pour prê que c'était pas forcément un
super appariment quoi que prête que avec
les Noirs ça lui permet d'avoir une
nulle facile donc il est peut-être pas
mécontent en
réalité et apr je cinderov qui est passé
derrière Maxime à la pendule en tout cas
pr besoin d'un enemi et je suis pas sûr
que CEMI qualifie même avec un excellent
départage en fait dis il a ses chances
ça suffise
mais dis aujourd'hui par exemple c'est
SR qu'il faut en
fait mais bon il pas encore perdu pas
encore
[Musique]
perdu
V
rapidement
et donc il veut sûrement jouer B4 après
peut-être garder une pression là-bas et
au cas où le C pourra venir en B3 C5 par
la suite alors est-ce que ce serait pas
le moment de de faire une petite
respiration après cette nul de Baky
cindar qui réfléchit il va d'avoir des
coups qui vont s'enchaîner nous est-ce
qu'on a pas besoin fa de
souffler soufflant soufflant et et
revenir dans une petite dizaine de
minutes plein d'énergie on a eu la
premier premier résultat de de la
journée l'annul de Baky plutôt
intéressant donc encore un bon résultat
pour Étienne et et on va suivre la suite
dans un peu moins de 10 minutes à tout
de suite los amigos à tout de
[Musique]
suite
he
he he he he
he he
[Musique]
he
les amis on est de retour un peu plus
vite que prévu alors il y a eu qu'un
seul coup alors c'est que des variantes
qu'on avait déjà regardé mais c'est
intéressant de les revoir puisqu'il y a
eu cavalier E5 c'était un nos coup
principauxf c'est un des premiers coup
dont on a parlé cavalier E5 même le
premier peut-être prier parce qu'on
sétait dit qu' prend C3 de base ah caver
C6 cavalier E2 cavalier D8 cavalier C1
que tout le monde que personne sort mais
en R ité ici à cavalier D4 menace qu'
prend C2 et de récupérer le cavalier
donc les blancs sur cavalier prend C3
vont être obligés de reprendre alors il
va prendre de d ça c'est quasiment
certain Maxime va aller chercher G2 tour
G1 c'est forcé alors là évidemment pas
de coup comme comme fou H3 complètement
ridicule il va y avoir juste fou G5
tourd en fait peutre peut-être que dame
F3 aussi bien peut-être dame F3 aussi
ouais peut-être dame C7 là-dessus trouve
que non mais bon en F G5 est tellement
fort que maisur c'est pas des coups
qu'on regarde donc dame D5 euh protège
ici euh cavalier G4 tout menace cavalier
F6 et cavalier E3 et Maxime comme il a
joué tempo on s'attend à Dame F on
s'attend à Dame F3 il doit avoir ça
maintenant fou G5 pour réintérer les
menaces fou G7 Cali quand même fou prend
dame prend fou pr ouais on échange les
dames en premier et on fait fou prend F6
et ici probablement petit rock mais euh
c'est égal en fait malheureusement
maxime n'a pas mieux que égalité ici
mais bon comme on l'a déjà dit à maint
entreprise avec les Noirs
malheureusement là il complique il fait
tout ce qu'il peut mais bah si
l'adversaire fait pas d'erreur il fait
pas d'erreur quoi après bon tu peux
jouer hein mais le FU F6 c'est un peu
chiant après si peut avoir le seum
d'avoir cette position là parce que pour
lui comme on disait c'est l'avantage de
jouer contre un joueur quand même qui a
quelques ambitions mais je crois que et
l'un et l'autre peuvent jouer mais que
nul c'est normal quand même dans oui
mais il est peut-être pas content
cindarof de voir cette position non plus
c'est ce que je veux dire ah ben joue
pas qui 5 c'était pas content en fait
pas quoi dire non mais j'interprète
comme ça Fab le cavalier pran TR tempo
peut-être qu'il revérifie un truc et
peut-être qu'il s'est trompé quelque
part parce queok prend ses trois tempos
et sindarov qui réfléchit déjà depuis 6
7 minutes hein ouais je pensais enfin
moi j'ai pas la cam je sais pas mais je
pensais que le fait qu'il réfléchisse
c'est qu'il s'était barré une fois qu'il
a joué son coup ouais mais tu'es pas tu
te barres pas 6 minutes ça dépend ce que
tu as à
faire je prfère pas en savoir plus
Fab
mais Maxime Maxime qui régale évidemment
comme
toujours il joue
bébran alors ça
euh cétait c'était pas prévu je sais pas
en fait du coup j'ai plus F prend F
prend G2 c'est sûr tour G1 c'est sûr
dame D5 c'est plus ou moins sûr ici
voudraz jouer avec C4 dame 4 D3 dame
prend2 roi
prend2 3 pour essayer de garder le matos
tourb quelque chose comme ça mais on va
voir si on peut pas dévier on va pas
aller plus loin pour le mond dans la
ligne est-ce que icion pe se bar avec le
fou ouais je sais pas où4
j'imagine en fait ok il rêve de C4 F B2
quoi si je repars là ça et maintenant
j'ai dame
C7 parce que tu avais pas G5 F7 dame H3
plus oui mais
bon
déjà je sais pas quel le plus faible
mais mais je suis pas content tape
là Chud en fait c'est Chud
mais que quand Mme qui un peu en ligne
de M faire t C8 C4 je pour C4 4 D3 C4 je
peux pas faire si D3 je fais B5 non mais
ça joue mais je sais pas moi je prends
les Noirs je pas ce que je prends je
sais pas
mais ça peut être une mais du coup c'est
ma mais Maxime j'adore ce qu' fait il te
fait F Pranger ded dans la tronche à
tempo genre là il est sûr de ses coups
et il lu envoie dans la tronche c'est
bien parce que bon tour il le joue tempo
mais du coup oui non en fait joue
vraiment pas pour nul non mais bravo
c'est clair oua ENF bravo messieur quoi
peut-être qu'il a vu l'autre ligne et
mais du coup il joue ça mais les deux
jouent pour le gain c'est les deux
joueurs se livrent à 100
%. les deux joueurs se livrent à 200 %
cindarov qui a pas joué la ligne qui
menait alors à la nul qui mena à
l'égalité on va dire euh mais nul très
probable a reposer tout ça et ce il joue
la position qui est aussi égale mais qui
est très complexe donc bravo à Sindar je
je vais applaudir le le joueur h pas
pleutre pas pleutre non ça c'est des
gens qu'on aime bravo bravo à
lui pourquoi dame des5 marche plus alors
dame D5 en fait l'idée c'est de faire un
ça marche mais de faire un D3 mais c'est
pas forcément le plus intéressant c'est
pas incisif
quoi c'est pas incisif tu fais B5 je
sais pas enfin mais bon c'est une petite
finale
quoi et tu recommences avec ton histoire
de compensation pour le pion mais un
moment tu sens que ça tu vas pas gagner
quoi donc je sais après H3 je suis pas
sûr qu'il jouer d D5 bonne chance qu'il
fasse H3 pas con et c'est qu'on C7 un
peu derrière les
fagot je pense sil voit cette position
c'est en
D6 j'aurais pu le mettre en
G7 est-ce que c'est si
grave F 7 fois 3 grand RCK du coup
ouais mais c'est moins je me barre
là-bas pas je sa pas que c'est pas bon
hein c'est ça va mais c'est moins moins
le feu que les ro opposés ouis ouais
mais c'est quand même intéressant même
là en plus peut-êre faire tour des5
d'abord mais c'est intéressant enfin la
position est bizarre juste
cette idé je sais pas trop à quel point
ça c'est pas complètement con quoi non
non c'est pas complètement
con c'est pas clair du tout non c'est
pas clair mais moi je préfère faire F C
petit probablement dans l'optique de
Jolien mais j'en sais rien en
fait c'est un choix difficile F
F6 demand si on peut
faire
je dirais
oui je
pas tu peux tout
faire j'aime pas trop c'est que il y a
beaucoup de pion sur blanc d' on aim
bien a le ça me fait un tout petit peu
peur mais après tu peuxut-être fout au
prochain
et structure avec les
noir si la ligne c'est TB1 F6 dame dame
quelque
part
fait tout va pour moi pour
ou c'est très complexe comme position
très intéressant
Fab pour le coup c'est extrêmement
intéressant
je sais pas une question sur les cam en
fait oui les joueurs sont filmés mais
nous on n pas la caméra ici quoi donc je
sais pas ce que je disais sur la cam pas
la cam mais
voilà Fab c'est beau quoi dam G5 ce qui
regarde avec l'ordi B5 et A5 très grave
dame
C2 vraiment une grosse
erreur c'est le
bordel VI toujours pas si
mal marque
quand qu'est-ce qu'on
cliquit kousuf mais il trés kous ouais
bon nul probable hein mais et chez les
autres enfin qu'on regarde pas trop mais
dans le tableau principal
euh c'est qui ça c'est firon ah oui bien
peut-être c'est pas clair mais je dire
c'est une bonne tête sa position h et
dans le tournoi les ceux qu'on regarde
pas est-ce qu'il y a un truc intéressant
ok c'est compliqué vous voyez pas
l'écran regarde de notre côté là vous
pouvez voir param param
il mais il va une partie ça il va se
faire neutraliser après on est les
autres
cont il a qui dans son groupe il
ESS lui aussi il peut croire un 3 sur TR
peut-être tu vois il va TER sa chance
nan qui va jouer à fond on sait pas
contre V et après c'est firou et c'est
le groupe des battu enfin là cétaitjà un
groupe des battu c'est un groupe des
battu qui peuvent se battre qui peut qui
peut ressusciter
quoi et donc by déjà déjà match nul hein
pour pour vous tenir au au courant
ou il y a pas de grand combat
aujourd'hui mais bon après de partie
longue c'est normal pe un peu de
fatigue peut-être de la déception aussi
de de hier je sais pas et puis quand
même ça début de 3h avant donc quand tu
as fini tard duure de
récupe les joue français très il y a
Sophie m ouais qui fait un beau tournoi
je sais pas si tu as la position Fab
mais est-ce qu'ells ont commencé je CIS
que oui comm en décaler
aujourd'hui ça va peut-être commencer
mais je on ouais on a peut-être pas les
coups
ouais ah oui bah qui a beaucoup donné
face à des grands
joueurs demain il aura les Noirs c'est
certains plus doubler les
blancs il peut avoir un nouveau gros
morceau hein au tirage mais semigro
enfin c'est des joueurs qui oui il aura
plus de qui vont jouer pour jouer quoi
OK ouais il joue la structure al je
pense que cavalier prend pision prend
dame 5 c'est
sûr ça donne envie Fab non non non mais
juste question ça c'est gagnant ou pas
du
tout c'est évidemment ça va pas être
joué hein c'est juste curiosité
professionnelle parce que moi je me
sentirais bien de la gagné quand même
mais bon
a jou qui prend C6 point
d'exclamation B prend point
d'exclamation ou pas ah de points d'
trop normal non dame 5 c'est normal je
suis d'accord mais je me demandais s'il
y a pas d'autres coup je vois pas de
coup très intelligent d 5 tour g
vite l'i préfère les blancs mais bon
ouais mais tour G8 tour B ça me semble
normal prendre la colonne F D6 c'est
normal F D6 c'est normal dame 4 c'est
normal alors fou D6 tu peux peut-être
penser à faire dame D5
d'abord tomber vite c'est
bizarre est-ce que c'est
grave je sais pas à quel point c'est
grave
mais tu te dis pourquoi pas faire fa
des6 plutôt que laisser ça quoi
tu vas pas faire pour faire quoi
peut-être que c'est pas grave mais alors
pourquoi c'est parce qu'en fait F D6
dame4 j'aurais bien aimé avoir la dame
en
d5ou8 mais f6éit parce que je me dis F6
dame4 j'aurais bien aimé faire dame D5
ici donc c'est pour ça que jeand est-ce
que je peux
commencer tu fais cé
pas ou
ou
mais bon c'est la case du roi quand même
ou mais peut-être tu bougeras ton fou
j'ai l'impression que je suis en train
de me [__] en
galère en fait faut savoir si ça ça va
être joué t t bien non je crois
pas bien c'est hyper normal ouais c'est
normal quand même où en fait 4 c'est
normal tu gagnes un temp
C pourquoi pas dame
D7 je sais
pas bien ah je suis d'accord avec toi
mais je me demande si je peux faire
F5 je sais pas si
damagetion ah mais ok alord dit que tu
laisses tour B6 donc oui tu peux pas
donc dame C7 un peu obligé il va faire
un coup de développement type
D3 trop normal pr on peut jamais ou
c'est un
pion on a d'aller les prendre aussi les
pions des
fois H5 et juste F4 ou
ah tour G8 tour B1 c'est joué c'est
hyper normal bon il va réfléchir un peu
mais il va jouer fou D6 c'est sûr dame 4
ça ça et du coup D7 logique
ou
fou3
admettons t B8 c'est normal ro D2 c'est
normal peut-être des F5 F4 peut-être 32
plutôt et alors l'ordi va prendre H2
maintenant vasy pour
voir et si je rev D avec
le6re C d'abord mais bon avant ça
change6
F3 c'est trs
ok pas fa prendre
h est-ce qu'on peut Esser jouer avec7
bizarre
[Musique]
mais
H4 je fou 5 F6 en fait en fait moi
j'aurais aimé idéalement faire F6 ro F7
et H5 tout tenir
idéalement genre quand j'ai voulu jouer
ro F7 c'était l'idée c'était de de
louvoyer un peu parce que les blanc on
pas vraiment de menace direct mais juste
il on a du mal à se mettre en place il R
de C avec leur
pièces on crois D7 F3 ça paraît quand
même hyper logique tous les coups
quoi B8 c'est normal al ça peut être
l'autre ou la a moi je mettrai la a mais
ça peut être l'autre aussi je trouve
plus VO des de je sais pas j'ai
tellement peur de me prendre F5 F4 mais
bon c'est peut-être pas si grave hein
mais j' de me faire vraiment fermer le
fou quoi
mécaniquement je mettrai plutôt en E2
mais bon après ça
c'est mais c'est pas sûr qu'il fasse
parce que en fait déjà si la ligne
préféré de l'ordi c'est de faire une
répète comme il veut jouer pour le G
avec les Blancs aussi et si je fais ça
qu'est-ce que ça vaut cette
finale
ch c'est complètement nul mais je je
sais pas en
fait bon disons moi j'aime pas trop les
blancs enfin j'aime pas trop je
comprends que ça doit aller mais je je
me sentirais pas très à l'aise quoi
comme je tu as l'impression qu'avec un
setup noir tout d'un coup tu te
consolides tu vas avancer tu vas avancer
ouais alors que les blanc de faiblesse
machin je je suis pas très fan du du
choix de cinderof mais du coup c'est une
bonne nouvelle hein j'ai envie de dire
mais
euh disons quand tu as la position après
qu' D5 que tu rentres en force làdedans
je comprends pas moi non plus si c'est
pour faire DC et l'autre je comprends
j'ai une question d'ame
D6 ça a pas l'air qu'on amené 6 en fait
bon l'idée pour expliquer c'est fou ENF
fa ça cette finale là j'ai l'impression
qu'elle est vraiment
relou peut-êre Tor peut-êre Tor B7
peut-être pas enfin bon c'est un coup
qui qui actif au moins mais mais en fait
à vrai dire même comme ça enin pour
montrer une ligne en fait tu peux sortir
avec les
noirsin bon je sais pas c'est juste pour
montrer uneg un peu à la con
mais c'est c'est une ligne un peu débile
maisendre c'est pour dire que tu es pas
obligé de tu as une sortie de la tour en
G6 tout ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'
momentné si tu fais G5 tu as tour G6 et
ton roi ça ça peut être un plan aussi
pour Maxime d'ailleurs
h bouffer H2 de passer comme
ça non mais j'aime bien c'est c'estes
chances on pouvit pas espérer mieux non
déjà après évidemment s' joue
parfaitement sindarov Maxime ne peut
toujours pas gagner il y a pas eu
d'erreur à proprement parler en tout cas
de groses
erreurs a des choix question va avoir
des positions pas faciles à tenir en
fait
donc
donc questionnable comme il a jou en
tout
casou il a l'air bien il pris un pion
ouais car il a l'air de gagner donc ça
peut être très bien ou très mal en même
temps s va pas au candidat ça peut
vraiment être cata mais bon il va
commencer à avoir des vraies chances là
ah il les a toujours eu mais
ouais il doit recoller au groupe de
leaders alors moi qui un vainqueur
machin mais si le vainqueur s'appelle
Fabiano parce que le Val de l'ordi là je
suis pas d'accord il donne avantage noir
franchement
plus d'accord c'est pour ça qu'il est
content peut-être ou mais bon
c'est mais
euh j'en sais
rien c'est quoi ça c'est c'est vidit
celui qu'on appelle le prince du
Gange
euh bon écoute c'est solide hein
mais c'est quoi c'est marquant ça Mar
ouais bon je sais pas trop ça
joue je vais faire cavalier prend D1
cavalier B2 cavalier
C4 je pense que nul dans la
poche firou c'est le
bordel et donc ça nous ramène à cette
partie de
Maxime en gros faut être pour Fabiano
ikarou mvl en gros c'est ça voilà le T
c'est
gagnant et B qui a fait nul
ouais tuuras pas pris le pion parce
qu'il y av des fou B4 échec c'était
c'était réellement très
complexe
il un mec qui marche dans la sage adore
son style nous on n pas les cas
malheureusement Maxim du coup il a
plusieurs coups intéressants dame D6
c'est pas con fou D6 c'est le coup
auquel on s'attend madame des ouais
après çap le tour7 mais je pense que tu
regardes pas du tout le ma de l'ordiam
G3
ch ta bonne structure quo ENF ça te pose
pas de problème
quoi non mais en fait stabiliser ch des
dames tu as du mal àer t B7 que quoi
jeis enain de réféchir pe ça fait juste
un peu chier et que du coup
machin c'est
bien
bar il peut forc c'est grand d'ailleurs
il peut jouer pour nulêre simple de
passer mais en tout cas il a pas du tout
joué pour ça depuis le début de la
partie il va pas juste changer d'opinion
comme ça du jour au lendemain donc il va
pas ça va jouer c'est plutôt c'est bien
comm ça se passe pour Maxim en
faitre hyper entreprenant
c'est tout ce qui peut
rêver après après faut être plus fort il
faut la gagner ça c'est une autre
histoire mais au moins tu as ta
chance attends j'ai une idée dame D6 dam
G3 grand
rock
B6 qui non j'a d D3
le roi il contrôle pas très bien en
fait h c'est le faire c'est ça
ouais tour qui
démarque très bizarre compe
positionition il se passe des manœuvres
qu'on attend pas et des trucs
intéressants 3
44 je sais pas quelque part
is c'est vraiment dur à anticiper t ces
trucs là de part et d'autres par que dam
des c'est grand rock c'est pas
complètement con
hein non mais pensez à g t r t t machin
quand tu l'as sous les yeux tu peux tour
G1 comment je l' fait jouer
mais en amont c'est
dur ENIT c'est bizarre c'est le coup le
plus logique le meilleur mais en fait
quand tu réfléchis tu as tellement envie
d'essayer d'être
malin que Dame des 6 moi ce serait je
pense que j'aurais fait le truc Dame des
6 grand j'aurais été trop heureux la
géométrie non c'est bien en c'est mais
peut-être qu' va faire Maxim d'ailleurs
c'est pas c'est pas absurde du
tout fait le seul truc qui aurait pu
m'en disuader c'est ça non pasame F4
mais euh c'est grand qui est tour
B6 ça ça aurait pu me dissuader
ouais j'aurais pas rentrer là-dedans en
fait ou pourquoi tu dones un piion
ouais
d' prend son nul on quand même un peu la
jouer
hein c'est pas vraiment nul parce que
bah tuas une structure pourri par
structure pourri alors après tu fais
tour B7 évidemment tu t'activ un peu et
je sais pas trop ce qui se passe mais ça
joue
euh mais mais là en fait les n ils ont
un espoir à long terme en fait je sais
pas c'est faut pas croire parce que
tuchanges des pièces tu joues pour nul
hier on a
eu une tonne de gens dans le chat quand
Maxim a fait dam C2 contre Pichot ah
c'est une propotion de nul alors que
c'est juste une finale gagnante avec le
RO r sur les cas noirs donc je enfin ça
existe de gagner des finales aux échecs
quand même quoi on n'est pas obligé de
mater avec les les 32 pièces sur les
chiquers quoi
donc donc il a différentes manières de
gagner et donc je dame des6 c'est pas
jouer pour faire nul c'est jouer
justement pour jouer une finale parce
qu'on structure et qu'on veut gagner là
en gros on va pas les mat roi blanc à
priori not roi noir il est pas mieux que
le roi
blanc non il est pas
mieux merci à cpharbus qui
sabonné d'ailleurs d des6 dame prend
l'ordi d'un avantage noir bah c'est sûr
ouais enfin pas un avantage noir mais
c'est sûr que tu prends les noirs et dam
4 pas jou bah là encore he c'est les
coups de croix d'agneau donc toujours
très risqué surtout pour juste mettre
une dame sur une case
ouais tu peux te faire contrer en
plus mais après c'est si si si tu tentes
le croix d'Agos c'est pas un
coup dénué de sens d'AM
A4 attention à Dame prendre C6 double
croix Bros dame H4 sinon ou là
non bah à minima il y aura toujour tour
B8 hein et tu vois tu commence à te
prendre des trucs et sinon al le coup de
l'ordi c'est Dame C7
bon pourquoi pas ça faut regarder mais
c'est tu te places tu me laes d prend C6
tu me laes t B7 tu crées des problèmes
en
fait un petit tour rapide sur les autres
allez Naka bon c'est bien ça pas
bougéana Kana faire cavalier F1 qui3 il
va reviser les cases ça compliqué peut
passer ça bouge pas ça bouge pas
marquant c'est le
bordelub c'est égal j'ai préféré prendre
de la tour pour bien contrôler la
colonne et ça c'est
qui il est bien on verra
gagne et les autres regarde pas on peut
juste regarder pour regarder et vous
dire donc pr rangé deè
rangée ici qui va pas gagner en tout
cas param iless c'est solide en face
mais c'est une partie tout peut arriver
nul plutôt mais bon V caronan on
s'attend à
nul OK
et on voit pas bien
malheureusementer qui qui de plus en
fait donc ou de pièces légères ça doit
pas suff doncer devrait
gagner écoute il tente lui aussi le 3
sur
3 un peu dans même cas de figure que
Maxime leev
tout
sur F6 il y a quoi non fre coup
principal c'est le coup
qu'onens qu'on en premier qu'on estimit
normal il y a rien de grave les blancs
dame à priori en E4 attaquer C6 on
s'attendait d C7 dessus et juste D3 pour
les blancs et ça joue donc totalement
jouable et normal et naturel
F6
non Sando fou c'est fini même avec 3 sur
TR il peut pas se qualifier via ce
tournoi par contre il doit essayer de
faire sonie pour prendre des points h
parce que ça va être ça sa carte joker
pour se qualifier alors évidemment
encore plus Joker si nakamora se
qualifie ici ce qui luerait un boulevard
pour se qualifier sans rien faire de
spécial juste en faisant pas une cata à
singlefield par contre si Naka finit pas
là singlefield il devra aller chercher
un stratosphrique stratosphérique
exactement pour pour le coiffer au
poteau un score qui pourrait être
atteint avec un plug
ouais tu fais juste 9 sur quoi tu les
défonces
ouais parce Queau classement la camera
actuellement à la bagatelle de 12 points
et lo de plus et ça va encore peut-être
non ça va stabiliser s'il gagne tous les
deux mais ça fait
cher fou
G7 d 4 Croix
Rouge pourquoi Croix Rouge je comprends
pas d F4 gros
avantage là mais c'est ce qu'on avait vu
en fait il voulait contrôler
B8 et donc dame D5 on avait regardé ça
tout à l'heure en fait parce que tu me
parlais dam D5 directec du machin et oui
ok petit raté je sais pas à quel point
cétait grave dame F4 pour nous mais
c'est quoi ce t G4
là euh est-ce qu'on fa du coup j'
mettrais enfin moi j'aais peut-être bien
commencer par FO à 3 en
fait moi j'aurais regardé ça avec les
Blancs il y a
rien parce qu'il y a F
oui mais genre c'est mon truc enfin
ouais ça aa été mon truc en première
intention ça contreetourbé ouais mais
bon c'est même pas bon c'est quand même
bien
ah tu es bien parce que si tu gagnes h
tu as gagné en fait tu vas prendre un fr
D6 ou quoi mais bon euh non c'est chelou
mais attends c'est
quoi dam des5 d D5 c'est 100 % il va
bouffer c'est prend et il veut tourb7
non ouais mais on fout
E5 roi E2 roi F8 ça ça aurait été mon
idée
D4 d'accord si tu
veux F D6 et fou H6 échec
dc je comprenais pas je très Moch mais
attends et si je fais prend
euh alors chelou oui et chelou non parce
que j'ai B7
non quel dommage je
petit je pe on est beau bah si tu fais
CD non mais CD c'est plus logique ouais
si tu fais CD petit rock tu es beau he
tu es magnifique
ouis donc TB je pense c'est ça la
game on a dit quoi F 5 mais F 5 c'est
hyper logique hein alors après il peut
nous jouer F 3 quand même si fait rater
un peu les les trucs euh du coup c'est
ça en fait le truc il a des qure OK ou
des 3
ok c'est mieux des4 pour faire ro
D3 on est un peu paralysé c'est bizarre
mais
ouais mais bon on peut pas en vouloir à
Maxime c'est hyper logique ce qu'il fait
il a fait tour G4
ok il veut
pas W pas trop t'aider et peut-être
qu'il veut échanger un jour couissé de
l'autre côté super belle game ouais mais
du coup là j'ai peut-être fou5 d'autant
plus
fort H
3 pas le
donner H5 du coup moi je d' prend ouais
je pense aussi c'est prend il aller
là-bas je B mais a
S
D76 B5
mais ouais peut-être c'est4 tu as envie
d'enlever tes pions dou de merde et ça
s'équilibre un
peu je pas tu Chang tu fais tour
B3 bon tu peux toujours te créer ton P
pas séloigné mais c'est assez égal
ouais tu peux quand même jouer avec les
ça mais bon il va te faire H3 F3 tu vas
devir faire F5 G5 mettre ta tour là-bas
faire G4 mais ça ça suffira pas c'est qu
partir un jour ouais
ok mais bon on n est pas là parce qu'on
a joué beaucoup de coups et on a pas
joué les trucs enfin là j'ai
l'impression qu'ils jouent tous pour le
gain ils jouent tous pour le gain donc
comme ils jouent tous pour le gain et
que là on est rentré dans un truc nul
ils peuvent dévier de folie quoi et et
attends juste une question si jeoue fou
E5 on av bah j'ai une idée chelou hein
on avait dit H3 mais H3 je voulais faire
F5 prise je vais prendre de e tuim bien
ce truc alors tour B
4 je vais voir si je peux faire grand
rock
attend non je peux pas et ro
des7 en fait mon idée de prendre de ça
c'est que je veux garder mes deux pions
là tu bloque T3 tu fais des3 C4 je m'en
fous je te prendrai enfin on va essayer
de pas te laisser machiner et en fait je
veux essayer juste de te dire j'ai un
pion de plus tu comprends le scénario
que je veux c'est de là tu te crées pas
de pion passé moi je m'en crée un et du
coup j'ai une vraie chance de gain et
j'ai envie de me machiner en fait je
peux même vouloir du Tour B8 ici et la
finale de fou je pense qu'elle est
nul elle peut être un peu relou parce
que toi tu auras pas de pion passé c'est
sûr moi j'en aurai
un mais ça doit être
nul mais après je peux garder une tour
je vais te faire une tour B8 te
reprendre du Fou mettre le fou j'ai
l'impression que je peux un peu machiner
quoi
merde je me pas
grandchose non c'est pas con je sais pas
[Musique]
trop et F5 tour
B7 tour
B8 j'ai peur que ce soit juste nul ce
truc là
je sais pas quoi
dire ça va jouer un moment ENF pas et
dans ce genre de scénario aussi est-ce
qu'on peut les
chercher les
blancs chcher
h de son fou
pe H5 G5 HG
h
chaud il en prise en fait le
P alors des fois il est pas vraiment
tour H4 et tu contre-attaques le fou H7
mais en gros H3 il est pas touchable sur
une case blanche tuas pas de pour
attaquer pendant un long moment donc on
est tranquille avec
ça d prend2 j'ai peur de dame
PR est bloqué en D5 tour du PC
mais
je pense ça va faire fou5 hein il a de
bonne chance mais
pas en fait il nous joue des coups un
peu surprenants du coup les deux sont en
mood créatif surprenant mais intéressant
oui oui non jamais absurde vraiment
intéressant pour le coup c'est pas pas
manière de parler pour
dire
je fais un petit tour he je regarde
juste si c'est pasé une dinguerie mais
non il y a pas de
dinguerie
c'est tellement compliqué j'essaie de
réfléchir mais c'est
ouais le tour G4 pourquoi bah pour euh
défendre la dame et effectivement pour
aller en B ou en a ou il va aviser sur
les qure
figures donc c'est pas
bê bah fou le 5 he ça l'airi quand
même mais j'aime bien la poon de Maxime
voilà F5 direct ça dit quoi F5 dame
prend dame et il va partir aprs avec sa
tour donc c'est un peu ce qu'on voyait
mais envie de faire fou5 en fait pour
contrôler un peu tout ramener ton roi
mais en gros si H3 sera la même POS mais
peut-être tu donnes l'option de faire
tour B7 plus vite ou quoi
enfin tu comment dire
ouais il jou H3 donc bon c'est le CP
c'est pas obligé H3 c'est pas sûr soit
le
meilleur c'est loin d'être dit mais FO 3
ça peut être une option aussici c'est
pas de sens et peut-être là tu fais ça
ça ça
ça
ro F7 tu dois te faire Bam Bam Bam Bam
donc tu fais roi ici échec
ça c'est un peu un truc comme ça qu'on
ve avec les Noirs parce que si on
réussit à mettre le rang en C6 on va
être blindé et puis on a on a on a
énormément de jeux à l'roit derrière
donc si on stabilise en fait on peut se
retrouver même gagnant ouais ouais ouais
ça c'est pas mal on tour B8 h
ouais on menacera tour B8 8 machin ou
même de pas le faire direct on peut déjà
commencer par G5 H5 tener les pions de
faire tourber8 à bontion alin bontion tu
peux
me j'ai l'impression que c'est bien pour
Maxime moi aussi je suis plutôt
heureux pour le moment je suis plutôt
heureux il trouve
àimbonéion ça sera incroyable Maxime qui
serait sur du 4/ 4 qui reviendrait du
Diable vaau
Vert là il faut 5 c'était sûr hein c'est
vraiment
sûr je rêve tellement de voir une gaffe
là
dur bah F4 il pête un
C ça mettrait tellement
bien le
phénix le
phennix F4 on prend ouais F4 on
prend on prend dame
D4 prend on prendrait même D4 en fait
même ça je prends ouais on prend d'
machin prend dam G2 ouais mais moins
moins d' machin on prend tour
B8 on prend plein de coups en
fait dame prend E5 on prend t G5 on
prend t G5 c'est un clouage
mais bon F4 c'est
beau ça défend le pion
H2 dame prend D5 bah en fait il vient de
jouer tour G4 pour ne pas le faire pas
le faire mais après il peut aussi le
faire na la tour mais d'unutre côé F 5
c'est loin d'être il peut faire d' me
prendre des5 évidemment mais mais ou pas
enfin mon avis il va attendre de devoir
le
faire commence un peu à stresser dans la
FAB on est vraiment dans le vif du sujet
ouais mais ça va bien se passer tu es
confiant
ouais
C sub battle
F4 Garf qui sent bien un dame à 4
ouais
je sais pas je le vois pas du tout non
mais en fait il peut faire tout ce qu'il
veut mais c'est
pourquoi pas hein
ouais re pour F6 c'est peut-être pas
débile ouis j'urais bien mis F mais j'ai
ouais des4 et Machin mais euh B encore
que est-ce que je peux me faire
ça
ça pas l'air de passer mais c'est quand
tu commences à devoir regarder des trucs
comme ça c'est que ou c'est non
[Musique]
mais mais aucun des deux veut faire nul
ça qui est
extraordinaire en ce sens cétait pas un
mauvais apparent mais j'adore k il est
magnifique en fait
fou B7 fou
G2 il est extraordinaire
Kub c'est chaud on aime bien mais c'est
pas c'est pas
fait
ikarou de plus je crois qu'il va gagner
je pense qu'il va gagner aussiouser la
petite initiative machin fa c'est chaud
et vidit c'est
chaud ça va s'égaliser vid l' dame a été
vidé qui quoi ça a donné nul assez
rapide nul tranquillou il va pouir
récupérer et aller en arrivriver en
pleine forme
demainè on espère victoire de kwana et
Nakamura quand
même
5 King
F6
Juicer
h
h P pou
pou
ouais c'est c'est un peu
stressant c'est exceptionnel en fait
caroana il explose toutes les têtes de
classement pour laisser la place ça
Maxime ça ferit plaisir ouais ouais ça
peut en fait
hein en fait bon faut pas compter dessus
tu comptes sur toi-même tu gagnes tes
parties et puis après tu espères que ça
se soit passé comme il faut à côté quoi
tu mais tu contrôles ce que tu peux
contrôler non Maxim faut pas c ennemi
faut vite sur obligé parce qu'il a un
départage tout pourri il a il a joué
aucun joueur à plus de 2700 quand même
donc comme le départage c'est la moyenne
ho des joueurs advers s'affronter
euh tu imagine que sa moyenne elle est
pas terrible
quoi donc il peut pas être exé
quoi faut finir premier ou deuxè ou 3è
au pire si carwana dans les deux
premiers vu que il compte pas étant déjà
qualifié mais c'est seul ça les les cas
de figure et Ben qui serait max à 7i
ouais B qui je pense c'est fini c'est
fini B qui je pense que ouais cette
fois-ci c'est c'est
mort il y a plus que Maxime Le dernier
des
moan Carona sera sû les deux premiers on
c'est pas sûr il peut perdre aujourd'hui
il sera pas il peut faire nul et nul nul
nul et peut-être
pas il peut aussi l'être il est
complètement en course pour yre
donc donc c'est assez fort ce qui fait
car de toute façon il avait déjà fini
second la dernière fois il est encore en
course la coup il aa bien joué enfin il
est tout le temps là en
fait M Maxim ça peut ne pas suffire mais
je pense comme je disais hier en fait
que tu arrêtes des g non ça pourrait ne
pas suffire mais c'est hautement
improbable je pense c'est plutôt bon il
y a de grandes Chan si tu fais vite tu
te qualifies
quoi que le truc c'est que déjà surtout
avec Fabi qui compte
pas c'est quand même un petit
détail qui
pu faut voir que là demain par exemple
s'il à 6 sur 6 il joue contre un autre
mec à 6 donc s'il le bat c'est un mec
qui peut pas faire 8 et la dernière
ronde il rejouer un mec à 7 ou 7 et demi
suivant et s'il le bat c'est encore un
mec qui l'arrête je pense qu'à ce petit
jeu des des tirages de
maillot non non l'ut surt qu'il a
beaucoup nul genre la prè que il est que
ass
finalement un super départage qui a
égalité avec Maxime aurait pu le raser
au poteau il tous les gens il s'arrêtent
quand même pe va refaire nul
contre G qui sont encore devant Maxim ça
cré pas un gros mec
quoi ça peut suffire non non c'est
impossible mais regarde imagine vidit
etpenco ils font nul aujourd'hui après
ils font win et Draw et ben ils sont bah
ils sont à ouais mais bon le problème
c'est que probablement en fait si Maxime
est à 7 et à un moment donné qu'ils sont
à 7 et demi bah Maxim risque d'en jouer
un des deux en fait pas sûr enfin on
sait pas en fait comment dire je peux
pas vous garantir que ça qualifie hein
c'est ce que je vous dis mais il y a de
très bonnes chance et toute façon tu
peux pas faire mieux il se trouve que
tout façon voilà donc
euh toute façon tu tu tu fais H8 et puis
tu vois ce qui se passe puis peut-être
ça suffit pas bah tant pis c'est comme
ça mais tu as pas vraiment de regret tu
as fait ce que tu as pu tu as fait ton 6
sur 6 et
bon Max a joué avec les Noirs bah
probablement c'est pas sûr mais
peut-être il peut faire de blanc pour
finir aussi mais déjà si gagne
aujourd'hui qui gagne après à 7 avec les
Blancs il peut très bien tomber dans le
cas de figure ou là il joue un autre mec
à 7 sur sur le mec fait comme joue à
fond est obligé de gagner pour se
qualifier et il peut passer enfin
c'est CEMI c'est mort non CEMI c'est
mort mort non c'est mort enterré
quoi récurencebut ben non mais bon il
était malade he comme il l'a dit donc tu
JIS avec un virus c'est dur
quoi
petite pause vu que son ouais petite
pause comme ça on revient pour revient
et jusquau 40e après voilà exactement
Fab on fait un petit tour rapide nakamur
a toujours un pion de plus carwana plus
ou moins
égal un pion de moins mais bon il a sa
paire de fou il a la case F5 il a de
trois arguments ici ou là vidite
probblement ça fera nul aussi ça fera
nul marquant compliqué
kzubof égal il très heure prend à 6 dame
français
3 va faire sa petite nuit il va être
très heureux et fou compliqué allez on
vous laisse on prend une petite
respiration on se retrouve très bientôt
pour le Z not est probablement le le
moment décisif de la partie de la
[Musique]
partie
he
[Musique]
he he
he
alors il y a eu il y a une toute petite
avancée dans la partie on é en train de
se questionner là quand on revenait tour
G4 F donc ouais on aait ça il a fait
tour B7 et nous on s'attendait à tour B8
ouais c'était
ça
ouais il a fait F5 donc il force prise
puis on prend maintenant c'est nor de
décider ce qu' fait de sa tour G4 qu'il
va en H4 en B4 en A4 donc on va dire
qu'il va en B4 dans un premier
temps7 moi je pensis Bou bouf tour B7
retour x
3 je pas un coup droit
on va tellement pas gagner ça bah c'est
VI que la tour B7 est pénible parce que
très active mais donc on on a voir notre
belle structure on a du mal à avancer
parce que on est contre contrarié on va
dire par par les les les les pièce
blanche h attends j'ai peut-être une
idée tour
B4 pens ça un grand
rock je prends
H7 je t H8 ça mais je vais faire l'autre
en ou
B7 je fais fou C7 pour complètement de
cut
ouais bon j'ai jamais gagné bah le truc
c'est que ouaisag au pire je vais faire
oui pas gagner mais faut pas oublier que
sinderof bon il joue pas pour nul donc
peut-être que ça ça lui plaît pas non
plus bon après il joue pas pour il joue
pas pour perdre non plus hein donc G7
tour B6 ouais mais ça c'est plus
con plus con c'est pas sûr tu prends à 6
ouais c'est ce que j'allais dire tu
prends H2 tu ramènes ton fou ça c'est
très dangereux pour les blancs ouais non
mais il peut faire parce que il se dit
bon ok c'est dangereux mais bon je
prends ma chance et si je gagne est-ce
que est-ce que c'est pas Maxime qui FAA
un cums contre cums quoi c'est-à-dire
que il a compris que le jeu compr je
jouer pour le gain et peut-être que
Maxime il se dit ouais bon si je fais
tourb8 machin je vais pas y arriver mais
là je tu vois est-ce qu'il jouerait pas
au con le prendre à son propre jeu mais
moi je pense faut jouer au suprac con
hein dans cette situation la dernière
fois en fait Maxime pourquoi il a perdu
contre cindarov parce que il a voulu
gagner il voulait se faire un jour de
repos de plus enfin et du coup il a tout
donné mais là peut-être qu'il dit bah du
coup je fais la stratégie inverse vas-y
prends des rises moi je m'en fous je
t'élimine mais euh tu as les blancs tuas
la responsabilité du jeu tu es plus fort
que moi tu m'as battu ou mais pour moi
je jouer au con c'est toujours très bien
enfin ah bah oui mais en fait Maxime
j'ai plus h mais tu m'as battu tu es
plus fort vas-y ouvele tu es plus fort
que
moi mais bon a priori tour B4 c'est le
meilleur et donc on avit tour G7 quoi
d'autre bah quand même pas tour 4 c'est
merde après l'ordi tour tour B4 je sais
pas ça me paraît plus logique moi moi
j'aurais fait tour B4
mais Maxime il a pas fait ça pour rien
il y a peut-être des trucs qui nous
échappent tour G7 para logique bouou
deème tour qui
arrive B par je sais pas ce que tu fais
fou F et si je prends H7 tu me contrer
avec T8 toimême ou
ça ma et le fou il est enfermé une belle
idée d'enfoiré quandme ah c'est une bel
Maxim de compétition Jol CP enfoir maim
du
coup
g
tell pas
bouose
F D2 tour C5 tour H7 tour H5 ouais
bon ça ça peut jouer hein un peu
mieux mais c'est pas nul direct et au
moins il y a un truc ça quand même être
bien
nul c'est dommage qu' c4as oui oui pas
C4 te reprends à de ouais tu peux
commencer mais C4 ça bouf
bouff
c'est
ok bon mais bon on est toujours dans le
même truc c'est que l'autre s rentre
là-dedans mais est-ce que je peux faire
ah fou E7 tu fais tour B6 roi D7 t
reprends A6 ouais là tu ten ton pion
ouais il a joué tour à 4
ok bon c'était le coup numéro 1 de la
tempo bien pour B6 ro D7 tempo
oui mais ça on était content en fait
ouais alors roi D7 en fait il veut caler
D4 avec
ID merde désolé il veut caler D4 avec
idée sur fou prend il y a peut-être tour
B7 fou C7 ah non ça va je croyais qu'il
y a fou F4 mais il y a ro C6 à la fin
désolé faus
alerte donc roi D7 il veut
quoi si ton idée c'est de faire tour PR
6 je F prend H2 enfin je t'annonce que
je gagner peux pas donner H2 il va faire
H3 et à 5 et a 5 et fa C7 et F 7 bah tu
es sorti là avec les noir enfin tu es
sorti ah non mais bien sûr mais moi je
suis pas je je suis pas très très
impressionné de to à 4 c'est pour faire
ça disons
euh non
mais bon toute façon des 7 tu vas pas te
laisser bouffer auuss quoi mais ça joue
en genre là on a enfin réussi à
se sortir les trucs quoi gre tuas enfin
mis ton D7 enfin ton F en C7 qui pe être
couvert par la tour tu peux enfin
avancer tes pion
bon on est toujours loin de gagner
mais et
ok vas-y ro des7 t 6 T 6 T
6 non je ouou non mais t 7 C7
D3 mais je pense que je mais non mais je
sais mais en fait c'est une question que
j'avais tu vis savoir ça ça
drit ça mais ça je pense qu'elle gagne
j'ai C en fait qui te
bloque mais je sais pas en fait mais j'y
vais en fait je vais le prendre juste en
fait je vais te [__] un pion H3 un
pion G4 tu me touches jamais mais je
fais rien comment ça tu fais rien je
fais C4 bah je te prends prends ouis
mais là j'ai 4 je vais gagner là oui je
sais mais je sais pas si
B je vais faire G5 G4
H3 ça va en force ouais ça va en force
ou du coup il peut jamais avoir ce
problème
non non je comprends ce que tu voulais
dire
mais faudrait le F F4 faudra un truc
pour bloquer les les mecs quoi mais du
coup
euh du coup je sais pas roi des 7 ro
c'est forcé par contre non ah oui oui
enfin il y F7 aussi mais non mais tu es
content d' C7
ouais mais ro F7 c'est peut-être pas si
con bah il enfin Mo j'aurais fait ro
des7 mais genre j'essaie de comprendre
pourquoi il réfléchit al pr un jeu
direct j'ai pas une donnée auss mais
peut-être c'est jouable tu tout recette
dessus mais mais il a tour H4 à la fin
ah ça le problème je perds tous ok donc
ça pasess jouer normal non FO je tu as
eu raison de regarder mais le problème
c'est qu'il y a les dou le double
décalage le deuxième
mal ça donne quoi Baki Baki ça a été nul
rapide une grosse heure de jeu quoi une
heure de jeu je rapide dans le sens
c'était pas loin là après la sortie de
l'ouverture et sur les autres tables
rapidement pant que ça joue bon Naka
bonne chance quand même de la gagner
celle-là
Fabi hyper chaud on va dire pronostic
plus nul
mais vidit ça devrait faire nul
euh c'est chaud c'est toujours chaud il
a donné sa pièce pour les trois pions
cou on s'attend à nul
inamment et fou c'est ultra complexe
ouaisutre va bien se défendre quand même
et euh chez les autres on s'en fout on
va juste passer comme ça n nul bah c'est
pour ça en fait ce don par les CER qui a
gagnéer a
gagné lon ça va faire nul pr que ça été
nul
B SV ça va être nul par il arrive pas
quoi ouais ça va peut-être être nuliga
ici ça va sûrement être nul beaucoup de
pièces non ouais mais c'est plutôt bien
en fait tout le monde fait nul quoi
bravo messieur ilarou qui va gagner
c'est parfait et nul nul il y a
énormément de nul en fait nul he et puis
nous on gagne
il pas bien par non il est pas il fait
nul
quoi C aujourd'hui l'histoire du Fau
d'artifice
ouais D4 D4 ok je crois que c'est le
coup numéro de la turbinette attends et
sur fou point H2 il veut non il veut F4
ouais mais est-ce que c'est grave tu m
tour B7 après quand
même je peux pas repartir
dans l're
sens'en fous un peu
ou ouis quoi je
pensais c'est intéressant ce qu'il fait
et si je fais fçon le
bouer comme
ça G6 un
jour G8 c'est hyper bien joué
Maxime il peut avoir ce genre de
sacrifice actif c'est c'est logique t G8
en fait tu bloque complètement la tour
elle galère tellement à revenir que si
tu commences à faire tour A4 tour b4en
réalité tu as pas vraiment de pion de
Mos avec les Noirs non tu l'as mais oui
oui mais
enfin ce serait ça ça changerait pas
grandchose
quoi en plus tu as les PL la con de H5
F3 G4 FG FG Hg
H4 la con qui t'amène jusqu'en H2 mais
ça si Maxim ila c'est hyper intéressant
C7 bouff bouff bouff G5 H3 pour moi
c'est forcé t tour8 le coup de l'ordi
il va pas faire
ça non mais il t 7 ah il a T à 7 du coup
tu peux te le prendre parce que tactique
à la con bon mais bon quand même tu fais
tour à
mais il se Baras plus le même problème
ça tu peux
prendre que s fa H3 ça j'aime
vraiment du coup tour
à6 je pas faire tour
B8 je veux dire le truc aime pas mais
non en fait tu vas te prendreends4
prends toujours puis je sais pas TR ce
que ça fait
mais
si joue comme ça ah du coup tu as C4 que
la tour qui protège ok tu peux pas donc
fou C7 tour H3 t tour 6 tour 6 tour A6
G5 et là tu as le tour A8 qui est hyper
fort mais hyper
dur après quand bienen
même non mais du coup tu es peut-être
pas trop mal tu fais 4 tu fais ta vie
aussi et on y est pas encore à G4 H5 H4
j'ai3 pour le pas toujour chite ouais
mais d'un autre côté euh
c'est plus le problème de gagner mais
enfin là je serais confiant de pas
perdre avec les Noirs quand même non non
mais bon parce que à 4 à 5 genre ça me
fait pas très peur je vais te mettre un
roi en B7 et je vais te bouffer ton pion
de merde hein mais ouif les blancs sont
pas Koo quoi ah non c'est probablement
nul en fait ça mais
oui et donc fa H2 F4 c'est si grave
enfin juste
pour qu'
pourquoi FO
3 c'est
joué doit faire il a pas le
choix je pense qu'il
prendendre s et G5 c'est sûr en
fait
il joue vraiment bien mais bon s'il a
pas tour à 8 en fait non ouais mais il
l' je c'est pas sûr on va voir c'est
quand Mme
dur que j'ai 5 pour empêcher F4 en fait
tu l'empêches pas encore attends et tour
A8 j'ai pas
G4 ah tu as tour à 7 3 C6 fou ici et
tour D7 et celle-là parce qu'en fait
cette finale faut bien la Jer elle se
regarde celle-là quand même
ok3 joli ou
F4 admettons F3 mais je te bouffe tu
viens
ouais mais attention tu montre le roi
mais j'ai un pion passz protégé quand
même ouais enin je ça pour moi ce serait
pas évident en fait non c'est pas
évident eninement je comprends que tu as
roi E3 roi A4 roi D3 roi ici et tu as C4
qui gagne mais a peu de chose Pr ou mais
et si je passe via C4 tu vas pouvoir
faire A4 la t' ferm ouais bon
c'est c'est loin enfin non mais c'est
loin
d'être faut bien la juger hein et si je
fais
H5 faut très très bien la juger quand
même hein c'est costaud hein oh c'est
très costaud quand même je
sais donc tu peux penser tour à 8 G4 en
fait que si sur tour à 7 j'ai ro C6 et
sur fou F4 t D7 tu peux pas prendre tu
es très con ah tu peux faire
fou tu peut-être faire cellel T ou je ne
sais
quoi mais c'est pas facile deav de toute
façon on va voir c'est un moment
important de la partie quoi ouais parce
que G5 tour à8 avec l'idée sur n'importe
quel coup offensif de revenir en A7
c'est vraiment dur h mais c'est des
trucs d'ordi ça c'est bon tu peux
l'avoir parce que tu es un peu d's au
mur de toute façon euh que H3 tu sens
que tour G8 ça te bloque ou tu as peur
de tour G6 tour H6 et que tu dis ouais
bon fait c'est de la merde ah tiens
c'est sur H2 je peux faire F4 il y a
l'enfilade euh ça tu peux avoir le thème
tactique et donc par la force des choses
c'est très très dur mais il y a beaucoup
de coup qui sembl pas mal pour les Noirs
mais il se trouve que malheureusement il
y en a pas un seul qui décide mais bon
allez on va se rassur en disant que Fabi
il a raté des truc plus dur hier oui que
ça donc c'est s'il trouve il trouve
enfin au bout d'un moment après s'il a
des tels coups que tour à
8 bon c'est vraiment tu as juste pas de
chat du tout pour Maxime enfin tu peux
jouer des mecs à 28 qui vont faire des
moins bonnes parties parfois ou à 2750
et là le mec il va te sortir un truc
pareil ok bon bravo r mais en fait
j'allais te dire oui si je fais pas t r
je fais un coup droit alors moi je P je
pense à ro 2 comme un con mais roi ok
ouais mais t on veut t G8 roi G2 et T B8
ah non il y a a il y a le G en l'air
pour l'instant G4 il est pas tellement
en l'air d'ailleurs parce que tu peux
revenir moi j'aime bien les Noirs quand
même jeis sour à3 là pour revenir en B3
sur tour
B8
H5 D3 tu avance F4 ouais non mais c'est
ouais on pas gagné mais oui
euh en fait l'ordi a l'air de te dire
que tu dois faire absolument tour à 7
oui mais en fait ce que je voulais dire
c'est admettons admettons ça parce que
c'est les coups logiqu jusque là tu t à
7 je fais ça et tu me fais le chantage
je fais ça quand même mais du coup
peut-être le fond F4 sera ou mieux que
ce qui d éé ouais mais je voulais te
faire ça ça ça
ouais non mais tu peux mettre une B
impression peut-être faut per ouais H3
F3 casser les pions là-bas
peu mais bon en tout cas c'est que les J
pour gagner normalement non mais pas
très plaisant avec les Blancs
quoi je vais essayer de tenter un truc
comme ça repartir avec le fou de l'autre
côté ouais
ouais non fa pas overpush pu c'est la
vie mais non c'est dangereux pour les
blanc j'aime bien le coup logique on
aller de l'autre côté elle a fait sa vie
en G7 et puis aussi dans les tu fais G4
F4 et il te fait tour à 7as
tours4 c'est aussi un scénario tu peuxi
jouer comme ça
G4 mais déjà aussi l'autre est-ce qu'il
va
répéter mais tu rendte tu peux
ou je suis 100% d'accord ACI mais bon
vois bien cétait pas son objectif de be
mais bien Toa donné don une par que tu
pourre champion de France
our
contreèement
fouo tiens d'ailleurs question
G8
prend
G56 mais peutêtre t c'est
chiant6 nelle B6 j'ai pas
de il fou B6 quand même par que du coup
je veux jouer avec H6 c'est jamais
donner F
F4 non mais ça se tente et là en fait je
te fais H6 justei jeis
pas plutôt confiant en fait en fait je
te tiens un peu chien de faillance
faillance aide faillance a ouais
ah mais là tu as peut-être des
H4 mais bon peut-être je peux te prendre
tu bouffes t un point H3 dans ta tronche
tu peux pas prendre il y a tour H8 tu
dois décaler le roi quelque part je te
refous un échec de merde enfin non mais
oui mais euh non mais tu vois tu fais FK
je fais TG regarde je te défonce en fait
tu fais un coup de con et je te fais
torger si c'est tu enfin tu perds quoi
Dieu le fou tu as le droit de te tromper
là quand même non mais tu as le droit il
a vraiment plusieurs trucs pour se
tromper bah pourquoi pas hein de toute
façon l'autre il a pas l'idé et là
maintenant sur tour A8 c'est ce que
c'est
gravissime tu fais h ouais tu fais H4 en
fait là dans ce scénario tu mets le pion
H4 et tu dis bah j'ai passé mon pion du
coup tour H8 te gêne moins et sur tour
H8 tu peux carrément même peut-être
jouer des fous D8 parfois toi tu peux
prendre H 2 qui nous embêtait C être
plutôt plus schématique et en fait tu
peux replacer le fou là-bas et enfin
peut-être tu un scénario tu réussis à
chacun son rôle et ouais
euh pas mal H5 bah si le coup main de le
enfin H4 ça pas être jouer le cou main
hein ah parce qu'ils veut ça et tour à 7
ouais mais c'est chaud en fait
ouais ça c'est hyper compliqué en
fait
pas sûr qu'on gagne mais bon bon quand
même on a
je pense qu'on gagne en fait on va la
jouer jouer un petit peu quand même là
j'imagine Maxime C petite tête tu sais
Maxime on va quand même un peu la jouer
celle-là R de jouis
ouais
normal
normalcout on va voir là tu as le choix
tu peux jouer F4 tu peux jouer H4 t G8
toujours t G8 t G8 c'est le coup qu'on
aime bien tout le temps en
fait fou qui est bien l'adversaire a
fait une erreurcoute ça c'est ça c'est
important
aussi tour G8 maintenant mais je pense
que tu es content d'avoir introduit H5
qu que on G2 quand même ça revient au
non il y a une différence c'est que on
laiss fr
5 H4 H6 et là on a plus
ça mais là on a un peu de H4 ah parce
que regarde ID H4 peut-être tu menac H3
dire prend t h7end H2 et peut-être que
tu fais vraiment mal
avec G3 g3end
C2 je sais pas c'est compliqué pe voir
frérot là il y a le not de Maxime qui
joue encore la Calif on va peut-être
quand même rester sur Maxime là si ça
t'embête
pas dans le sens où on va rester sur les
joueurs qui jouent encore la
Calif la partie est hyper
intéressante al il te fait un peu de il
te fait F4 en
fait c'est pas con F4 maintenant dans le
sens Fab ah mais F4 tour à8 G4 en fait
il va te faire F3 maintenant ouais mais
ah il veut te fermer comme ça G3 il veut
plus jamais bouger son roi et si je
bouffe et je te passe par derrière
avecid que tuas pas F4 j'ai tour F1
ouais bon ça je suis content
je suis content avec les noir je suis
très clairement très content en
fait on va
voir
fait le problème c'est que bon l'ordi
donne égal tout le temps mais nous on
est content mais quand je vois la
position comme
ça bien parce que maintenant quand il te
fait tour à 7 3 C6 ça te déclou tout
automatiquement et peut-être dans un
monde peut-être sur tour a 6 on même ro
B5 T reprends6 et je sais pas no pion
qui avance ou un
truc
ça être que tu c'est abandon on va avoir
il va juste se faire mater
l'autre H6 c'est pas évident quand
même ah tu as
ça non tuas pas
ça
ça ouais bon en partie c'est quand tu
joues tu trouves mais
bonuta c en fait peussi juste bouger
duxire pas quoire Mo fort ça va
gagner faire ça nul max on est en train
de le
voirut
encore
faana
P de Mo c'est ça ouais mais non mais oui
en fait il a tous les PS qui
[Musique]
disparaissent ça faire nul B beaucoup de
nul en
fait ça se neutralise allez il en faut
une où ça fait pas nul c'est
celle-el
donc là on a plus tour B8 par contre
parce fut pr G5 tour G8 et
H44 euh donc on pourra le faire le jour
où le ponger sera plus là où Onra jouer
F4
ouais le pion a de s non il peut
peut-être être dangereux un jour
lointain mais pour l'instant c'est très
dur de l'avancer en fait parce que tu as
la tour qui le bloque devant c'est
simple de s'en occuper on a le droit
dans les parages enfin les pièces
blanches sont mal coordonnées la
structure de pion regardez en réalité
regardez ces pions que je mets en en
rouge en vert ils s'égalisent en quelque
sorte donc en gros tu as un pion passé
d'un côté et tu as un 3 contre de de
l'autre côté sauf que Ben les pions
blancs ils sont un peu moins bien
placfin on sent que les noir ont plus de
potentiel d'aller en chercher un le roi
est un peu mieux placé il pourrait
débouler en C4 on sait jamais sur les
finales qui arrive la tour A6 elle est
bizarre elle est enfermée tour a 7 3 C6
enin déjà la question c'est est-ce que
tu veux faire nul avec les Blancs
c'estàd que en fait les blancs ils
peuvent forc enfin forcer nul non mais
en fait si les Noirs font r C6 tu es
obligé de jouer pour nul donc si tu
restes il a fait tour à 7 si tu restes
dans ton délire
que tu veux pas faire de nul
ouais mais comm je je crois qu'à un
moment là tu vois que tu peux plus rien
faire de plus en fait toute façon Maxim
moi je ferai roi C6 il fait tour à 6
tuas tu peux revenir en D7 et changer
d'avis mais au moins tu vois s'il veut
faire nul bah il va changer d'avis de
toute façon mais
Maxime non mais moi je C6 t à 6 ro D7
bon écoute t à 7 t 7
je mais je te donnerai le choix une
première fois quand même pour voir en
fait tu as deux choix soit tu fais ça
soit tu te dis tuis on a plus trop de
temps je suis mieux ou pas
çapense moi je prendrai enfin joueur de
poker je prendrai l'info pour
savoir check pour voir quand
même c'est un peu joue de j'aime bien
avoir les informations enfin pour être
bien sûr
quoi histoire que tout le monde dévoile
ses cartes en gros toi tu es un pleutre
problème d'Ur b5en c'est qu'il il y aura
tend pionus Maxim qui fait H4 il fait
pas du tout ça donc Maxime ouais Maxime
en fait écoute je te méprise
quoi est-ce qu'il doit faire h avec les
blans ou pas parce que les n le menacent
peut-être
[Musique]
h est-ce qu'on dirit pas qu'il lui
crache un peu à la gueule avec H un
petit crachin
il s'en fout de l'info il marche dessus
en
fait il a 4 juste pour les V pour
ça parce que je crois que à quel point
c'est la menace voilà su je me
barre pas le choix
ok de merde qu on fait g non pas GC
d'ailleurs euh oui il faut avec la tour
fr C
7 joli piège très joli piège c'est
marrant hein ferm la tour comme des cons
il faut pr F4 il faut prend F4 donc il
faudrait faire ça ça ça et ça pr F4 et
bah c'est bien ou il a de bonnes chances
de G ouais c'est
gagnant c'est gagnant
euh ah mais ça peut être ma maximesque
he ouais A4 H3 prends tac tac tac tac ch
att c'est pas fait en fait
encore donc F prend G5 c'est mauvais euh
A5 je vois bien F4 maintenant
Mo R de
plus mais bon à 4 non j'en sais rien je
je juste un coup eu bah je sais pas j'en
pass quoi ce quire un peu c'est que je
peux plus faire RER 6 ou B6 maintenant
HM et je peux pas faire tour
B8 si je prends tu fa le mê pi je le
même piège
ok marrant donc en fait c'est peut-être
ça l'idée de Maxime
H3 maintenant à tempo c'est peut-être ça
l'idée tour à 6 on va voir bon on
s'attend à F6 mais peut-être il pe une
répète avant
ouais donc Maxime qui fait le fin
psychologue qui veut l'info il prend
l'info
ah l' nul ouais ben on retombe sur un
pleutre encore comme d'hab commence à
avoir l'habitude il a fa B je
pense imagine il répète non il va pas
répéter il répète il répète après
qu'est-ce que on va pas lui en vouloir
peut-être qu'il juge que ça gagne pas
mais je pense qu'il va jouer F6 moi qui
va tenter un peu et ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'objectivement il ah
objectivement il pas gagnant après il a
pas gagnant avec les les blancs ça va
mais il est pleutrre en face hein quel
pleutre oh là là non mais bon genre ça
dégoûte en fait il y en a un qui joue
aux échecs et il y a l'autre qui joue
pas aux échecs en fait c'est horrible
non mais j'appelle pas ça jouer aux
échecs en fait enfin c'est ta seule
chance de te qualifier et en fait tu
veux t'éliminer enfin gen jouer aux
échecs non mais je crois qu'il peut pas
faire mieux ouais mais tant pis enfin tu
perds c'est pas grave en fait qu'est-ce
que tu es pleutrre enfin j'aiajou on
sait jamais qu'il y a une g non mais
t'inquiète il faut B 6 de toute façon
non mais je sais mais genre qu'est-ce
que c'est que ces pleutre en fait j'en
ai marre de ce jeu en fait enfin c'est
bon faudit faire comme aux échecs
chinois tu as pas le droit de répéter en
fait oh oh
[Musique]
non je m'attendais pas
et ben
voilà bah après c'était sûrement nul
mais je vois pas pourquoi Maxim a pas
tenté un
peu
ouis du mal avoir le risque noir
après j'ai mal à comprendre le le choix
là en
fait je comprends que tu as très peu de
chance de gagner mais je comprends pas
pourquoi pas jouer un peu
quoi
ça dégoûte
ouais je sais pas je
ouais moi je sais pas je pensais que bon
ENF on a des chance he que c'est pas
facile à facile avec les Blancs
évidemment si tu fais pas le comp tu
feras nul mais que on peut encore te
poser de tris
questions après
euh bon ok max te il il c'est mieux que
nous mais euh
ok j'ai l' qu'il y a rien de risqué à
faire ça
quoi en je c'est pas comme si euh il y a
deux Gon coup des blancs et un - ins3
c'est après clairement tu es pas gagnant
he avec non mais c'est même pas mieux
hein bon écoute
euh bah la clim et la clim est terrible
à tout enfin j'étais sûr qu'il allait
faire fou B6 en fait
oui moi aussi
ouais c'est une des plus grosses clim de
l'histoire des échecs
là ok vas-y on zappe hein tu veuxon sur
scanner quoi j'ai envie de scanner là
voir si firou a trouvé le truc
final avir un peu carou et puis
aujourd'hui on finira un peu plus tôt
quoi 3 4
ouais en fait je comprends il qu' peut
rien faire quoi non mais au pire tu
feras nul
là mais oui trop évident on est trop con
quoi
mais côé
supporter en fait tu peux rien faire
en fait tu doas pas avoir vraiment
d'idée le fou F4 est trop fort et si tu
reviens en C St avec le
fou mais il va revenir
HM trophée
échec tu pe pas si veux faire nul tu
peux pas t'on dépatouiller en
fait du coup euh peut-être à la place de
H5 estce que c'était plus malin
de mais te faire F4 tu veux
dire un truc on voulait faire qu t G8
direct on G2 il va quand même le
faire on vou quoi nous
mais bon de toute façon on avait le même
problème hein B6 et quoi 3 4 on va dire
h
en fait facee au même problème en
fait si jeis ro B7 je joue pas en fait
ah il commence à faire C4
ouais non en fait il y avait plus rien à
risquer
malheureusement4
fait tu V être obligé de faire ro B5
pour éviter C4 échec il revient faire
échec il revient il va
revenir en fait tu peux rien faire
ouais donc c'est normal en fait pas le
choix ok vas-y vas-y on zppe un peu
ouais il y avait pas le
choixou pas sû qu' gagne ENF il est en
course pour gagner mais c'est pas une
finale facile facile t c'est TR un peu
chiant et active les autres c'est quoi
vidit machin on pe fa tour des stades
peut on prend une pause
d'ailleurs B on pe attendre le 40e quand
même pas à droite à gauche c'est qui ça
c'est Fabi ah bon ça va faire nul
ouis mais est-ce qu'il peut trouver un
moyen de de poussauter un truc nul enfin
tu vois comme il aime bien faireite
ça ça changer firou ça va gagner
j'ai juste une question pour vite dit d
c'est qui 5 c'est ça
ouais ok euh je pense qu'il faut qu'on
se pr une petite pause ah il a perdu un
marquant il para que c'est fait maté
j'ai entendu mais j'ai pas vu
ouis pas très bien je
H6
Okou ça va gagner bon je te propose
d'aller un peu digérer notre seum ok on
revient et on
revient ouais dans 10 minutes on a
besoin de digérer le se là trop élevé
maisou va gagner c'est
termin dernière chance française mais
pas ici oui mais c'est déjà important
maintenant c'est important AK donc ça
joue encore mais ouais il va falloir là
je me sens belge
he je me sens complètement belge là j'ai
l'impression qu'on a dominé toute la
game et qu'on et qu'on a perdu
ouais là je me sens complètement euh
complètement belge complètement belge là
on va bouffer deux trois frites et on
revient
ah le diable de
monstre ça dit quoi ça fait nul depuis
plusieurs heures déjà bon allez petite
pause all
suite
[Musique]
he
he he he
[Musique]
he
he he he he he
he he he
[Musique]
he
bon les amis on est de retour avec une
grosse dose de se et donc
alira il y a eu un peu de mouvement ça a
joué les coup logique entre guillemets
pas les meilleurs d'après l'ordi mais
bon on on peut pas leur en vouloir et
donc on se retrouve en cette finale qui
a l'air quand même bien gagnante pour
alza priori il faudrait jouer F4 avec
les noir parce que sinon les blancs vont
faire F4 puis D5 et avancer en force
alors qu'en faisant F4 en fait on
empêche au noir d'avancer au blanc
d'avancer pardon et et voilà donc
peut-être on peut faire dame B4 d prend
B5 mais peut-être l'autre tour vient en
F5 et si est noir à un moment récupère
H5 qu' prend le5 et ce peut essayer de
mettre en place un blocus il quand même
beaucoup de
ça a l'air pas mal mais bon pas encore
gagné en fait pour les rais on pens
qu'il allit finir vite
euh pas que ça il est
peut-être plus gagnant d'après l'ordi à
cause de A4 et sur tour PR4
D3 pe peutêt même
prendre ça va aller ouais qui est
peut-être en train de rater un énorme
truc hein mais alors je sais pas quel
point était gagnant soit c'est peut-être
une énorme défense de chparinov soit
c'est Naka qui a pas bien joué je sais
pas en tout cas bon il a pas trouvé A4
mais en tout cas il essaie de tenir avec
sa position relativement active
il va revenir vers F4 avec le cheval on
va voir je sais pas Naka Naka il a pas
gagné encore alors clim Naka muresque
oui et non
aprèsarza il gagne aujourd'hui reprend
du ho enfin on sait jamais
hein on reviendrait à combien on est à
12 points on reviendra à 7
points non 7 c'est rien c'est beaucoup
mais c'est il reste encore de rondes ici
peut aller vite hein ouais salut un
dragono c'est climesque aujourd'hui
ouais C5 c'est un
peu il y a pas torcer C6 tour C2 G3 tour
D2 tour C5 tour B3 tour D3 je veux
dire
ah ouais c'est la turboim en fait ça
devrait faire nul chez en
fait fa
nul nul Naka avoir alors il a pas joué
F4 l'autre t B6 ah il veut jouer son
pion passé c'est pas complètement débile
non non non non mais je sais pas est
mauvais mais
bon j'en sais rien à quel point c'est
mauvais 40e
coup c'est quoi dame G3 ça dame H4 on8
c'est Chud D6 tour F7
AB je AB ouais
E6
b2ou le F 3 prend dame 7 3 G8 dame
tu te fais choper les trucs sur
échec a des Mach au pire elle va revenir
en
B5 ah c'est B
ouais bon c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué
mais je pas c'est pas gag en fait il est
peut-être aux
anges ah ça peut être la journée la plus
climatiseuresque
de de l'année là on enchaîne les climes
ça avait commencé par bi qui avit fait
nul vite puis ça enchaîné avec Maxime
qui a fait nul moins vite mais voilà
puis là ça peut enchaîner avec kikarou
qui gagne pas et enfin pour se couronner
par par alirza qui manquerait une
position gagnante une petitte ceris
marquant que s pris un mat ouais petite
cerise marquant qui se fait défoncer je
crois que côté Sophie qui av aussi une
chance c'était dur ça avait l'air mais
en fait j'ai mal à voir les parties je
comprends pas en fait mais quand on met
le grand écran là de pause ouais on a vu
que c'était pas terrible on voit la
position mais c'est pas foutu mais c'est
plutôt moins bien a
priori bon bon on va voir c'est mort il
y a quand même le feu d'artifice ce soir
et donc tout va
bien après il PE trou c'est un bon
calculateur
ouais ça fait uneè position ENF ouais
ouais mais c'est pas dit par là c'est
compliqué tu vois P arrivé la tour
derrière par qu' dire déjà il a pas
trouvé le truc le plus
clean je plus on a ça tout à l'heure
mais
ça c'est quand même trouvable très
trouvable ton pion très loin
donc moi je trouve moi je trouve juste
qu'il a régressé à Ris en fait bah je
sais pas son investissement nous échaque
aussi le temps qu'il pay consacrer ou
qu' y consacre non mais je ve dire il
faut pas
le il faut plus le just le
bah rien troué du tout
euh alors qui est Prem 5 a priori c'est
le coup et B3 juste pour par curiosité3
que je comprend D6 c'est ça et tu le
plantes en fait c'est assz simple donc
tu es obligé de faire donc il va faire
dame C5
obligé tuas perdu ton à tout ouais tu
peux même la perdre en fait
oui je crois qu'il va pas gagner si
l'autre trouve qu' pr 5 mais il a 6
minutes pour le trouver et vu que B3
c'est trop pourri à cause de
D65
cavali5 dame
C7
il un damage j'essaie de regarder des
trucs qui peuvent faire peur mais non
mais un moment le cavalier les deux
tours ils peuvent travailler
ensemble plus si simple non mais tu peux
pas enfin làira je c'est trop bah il
fait pas un bon tournoi voilà et attends
j'ai une question quand
même
rien enfin ouais F4 je bouffe tu bouffes
je prends pas je faire E6
tu peux pas prendre je sais pas où je
vais mais je faire non mais c'est
peut-être ça que tu vas jouer avec les
blanc ouais ouais mais oui dire tu as
raison mais c'est
[Musique]
probablement pas asse mais tu peux non
mais tu dois faire
ça en plus ça assez logique tu mets C F4
machin enfin est-ce
que je question tu peux faire ça non non
non
non le truc c'est que tu es bloqué en
fait ou c'est que je dire je dois faire
B2 tu vas me prendre donc prend bon ça
va être le
40e il exagère mais je crois qu'il a
vraiment régressé assez
nettement parce qu'en fait pour moi ala
sur ce que je vois il est moins fort que
Maxime maintenant Maxime il est 27 30
donc Maxime pe-être un peu sous-classé
mais bah c'est pour ça queo même par
rapport à sa tu vois petit à petit euh
ouais ça Tom bien que ça s'arrête
maintenant
quoi et euh juste je te pr ça pour aller
voir le tableau
des d'autres parties qu'on a pas trop
suivi mais genre ici c'est censé être
égal param et ben écoute il essaye un
peu par il se met pas mal
pas bon on sait que ça va faire nul mais
ça joue encore et ils ont pas fait
[Musique]
nul il joue je sais pas çare finir en
nul mais bon sa pas et le reste c'est
c'est kimer qui s'est un peu replacé ok
très bien bon retournons
ici pire journée
de est-ce que so essaie de se qualifier
ouais parce que je crois qu'il peut ah
mais en plus on peut avoir de la chance
et qu'il peut se qualifier via les
grands prix via les des points points
machin ouais mais c'est un vol
incroyable si si en fait tu as kwana qui
passe par je sais pas quoi plus mais
pourquoi il fait
qui don roui il fait
nimpe tu as récupéré 50 minutes tu as le
droit quand même de trouver dame enfin
c'est quand même pas sorcier dame 3 F6
dame D4 pour faire F4 B tu es content de
récupérer un cavalier
ouais bon je pas til mais ça peut finir
par perdre enfin on est pas encore c'est
le roi va être vraiment à poil tu vas
avir des perpè des trucs mais à
force faut arrêter l'hémorragie des
mauvais coups quoi c'est pas encore
assez grave sur Mo pour perdre commence
à attention
quoi je comprends pas je comprends pas
ce qu'il arrivent avec firou parce que
et puis là c'est pas une foot de guerre
quand même à ravine enfin c'est il est
nul c'est vite dit mais c'est pas enfin
non mais c'est un bon joueur c'est un
bon joueur tu peux le cartonner quoi il
était cartonné en fait il y a qu' coup
bah oui surtout que tu es gagné
machin mais c'est pas fait la nul por
che par juste bon benah là reprend 50
minutes mais en fait Naka il va faire un
truc un peu comme fabianer il va essayer
enfin si tu défends tout bien tu vas
tout bien défendre et et bravo
d'ailleurs mais mais c'est pas facile de
tout bien défendre des heures et des
heur et des heures jusqu'au
B
je peux te dire que là j'ai un se
extrêmement
élevé on ferme les deux autres aussi on
fait
nul j'ai le
seum on peut ouvrir ceux qui jouent
encore pour on va zpper de temps en
temps bon voilà on reste comme ça et
puis on refait des pauses hein non mais
s'empêchera pas de faire des pauses he
c'est juste comme ça on a on a on a on a
je sais plus qui Sarana et par
voilà pourquoi
pas et puis pu on a le se on a le se
mais B la en plus c'est trop genre tu te
tu pars en pause tu as le se dis bon
toute façon est gagnant dans trois coups
c'est fini tu reviens en fait s
tu en plus il est foutu et puis en plus
fait pasame 3
D
alors pas foutu mais oui non pas foutu
mais tu as le seum quoi
ouais tuas se de dire que demain tu vas
devir encore regarder
après on va regarder pour le pour le
haut du tournoi du coup ona plus trop
les Français quoi on mett en fond
là-bas il a gagné il a fait nul il on
fait nul en 30 minutes et voilà
mais
mais sans s'intéresser plus que ça après
on s'éressera bah la Calif au candidat
et la course devant avec bah
vidite iipenko caroana peut-être qui
peut empêcher des gens de passer Naka
est-ce qu'il revient ou
[Musique]
pas il en est où est-ce qu'il y a une
remonada d'un mec derrière les rig les
param les machins à voir
quoi
par peut-être dans le groupe de tê on pe
regarder si tu
veux le groupe de tête il a autant
[Musique]
de
peutir bon il a pas encore gagné mais il
travaille sa position il a sa petite
paire de fou la paire finalou très fort
il peut se créer un pion passé alors
qu'il peut se faire peut-être bloquer ou
quoi mais ça peut être long long
courrier comme position le roi qui monte
un peu c'est une partie qui va durer par
et il prend sa
chance et Fas à quel point c'est
complètement
égal il peut peut-être la perdre enfin
c'est égal mais c'est plutôt les noirs
qui essayent
non c'est un grand mot
mais faut naturaliser param en
fait est-ce que fou c'est le plus gros
flop de la saison ouais c'est le plus
gros flop du du du cycle très clairement
puisque il était numéro 2 mondial avant
le début du cycle il a il avait 18
ans et 2 ans après euh bah non mais il a
il a netement
régressé sinon ouais il est plutôt sympa
pararemment on avait fait un nouvel an
avec lui et euh et sinon moi j'ai joué
deux saisons avec lui à clichi dans le
même club donc ouais mec sympa à fond
dans les chc
hein très concerné il travaille beaucoup
Essie toujours d'avoir des idées
ouverture ou quoi il calcule bien il
calcule vite
donc va être bien en avril à soutenir
vidit et
Abas exactement mais donc param
sympa level de se
Mao on est
abattu
mais c'est vrai quand tu vois le
scénario du Grand Suisse côté français
ça pouvait pas être pire
c'est cat c'est je ve dire là c'est
enfin tris rondes enfin deux rondes
enfin à trois rondes de la fin c'est
fini de rondes de la fin mais je veux
dire c'est tôt quoi non on aurait pu
espérer être en cours jusqu'au bout et
puis c'est dur de se qualifier mais tu
te bats jusqu'au bout et puis bah tu
arrives pas tu arrives pas que c'est dur
de dire que tu as plus aucun joueur qui
peut faire deux sur deux pour passer
ouais que de sur de déjà c'est dur à
faire hein ou oui mais mais que même
crantier ça suffise pas c'est quand même
abusé bah plutôt mauvais tourn
d'ensemble voilà c'est comme ça som
supérieur à courtour en 2018 diazovski
ouais ouais non la
somme
intersidéral non mais en fait en plus
même là la partie c'est qu'en fait firou
genre s'il gagne là avec Nakara tu dis
il est plus qu'à 7 points et l' il y a
une chance en fait là s perd etvec qui
passe
pas 17 tu rattraperas jamais c'est fini
en fait Mme la tu as même pas une micro
vibration de quoi que ce soit en fait tu
vibres que G
tour c'est tout etè pas faire rraper par
que gagne pas aujourd'huia
pasire sur de il va pas essayer en fait
tropavance il 17avance pas faire a
noir
en que là ce soir tu peuxêre éliminé des
candidats de partout en
fait pas officiellement
mais mais quasi
ou que Naka passe par le grand pr c'est
quoi le classement de ce truc ils vont
pas tous passer par là par
que est où fa voir c'est quoi le
classement ça s'appelle comment ce
truc je sais pas en fait
PE
mais je pense pas nak qui va gagner ce
truc parce que tu as carwana qui qui est
mieux mais il existe pas d'cord il est
13e c'est quoi ce ce ce truc à la con là
désolé de parler comme ça
mais pourquoi ça représente pas du tout
la saison en
fait donc c'est carwana qui sera en tête
je sais pas comment tu calcules les
points deuxième Goh je sais pas pourquoi
parce que on peut voir les 5 qu'il a
joué mais
vas-y WR master c'est quoi cette merde
c'est le truc à
dueldorf ferm a épau et tout ok
un ouais bon ça c'est nul TP SMAN c'est
nul charge master ok noress ok
euh super B ouais bon non mais tu as le
Gliss rapide qui compte aussi ouais et
catar il a joué et mais notre
valide il des trucs notre valide au
milieu en faitut-être tu c'est parce que
tu prends les 5 meurs résultats ok euh
ok euh carwana bon je comprends que soit
bien mais sa il est quand même pas mal
alors il a fait quoi ah il il a gagné
tata style ok c'est quelque chose
ça il a gagné son championnat national
euh Naka il est où enfin il fait quand
même une B il est 13e ouais mais il a
pas trop joué de gros trucs je crois en
fait il a joué que deux tourn il a joué
que deux tournant en fait il s'en fout
là ça ça va compter peut-être ici un peu
ouais mais bon mais il rejoue pas
derrière en fait non mais qu'il a quand
même gagné norwchess il fait 3 du Qatar
et c'est tout ce qu'il
fait pourquoi il y a un truc not valide
peut-être que c'est du Blitz mais alors
qu'est-ce pourquoi tu voulais noter si
c'est not valide je crois qu'il m tous
les
tournois
euh d'accord
et désolé on est sur un autre écran pas
vraiment vous le montrer c'est un peu
complexe mais mais ça dégoûte qu'en fait
si joue 5 tournois il les dépasse en
fait il joue pas il les joue pasou
[Musique]
27e 23e on sais pas pourquoi mais il
fait que de
temps par il est loin tout monde est
loin après ouais
donc peut grill g s fait une bonne
dernière
truc
qu'est-ce qu'il peut améliorer champion
des USA il fait Dee bah il peut faire
mieux que 5è
ici il a fait 5e il fait second de
singlefielden fait si Naka se qualifie
il est vraiment bienou ouais
Bonfin c'est mais ah le se que j'ai en
disant
ça tout repose sur Ikar cur
ou mais sera vraiment une qualif pas
mérité du toutf là pour le coup ce sera
vraiment un truc mal fait parce que on
serait content d'avoir un représentant
mais là en fait est-ce que je me fais un
défi complètement débile alors je me
fais un défi complètement
débile pas c'est donc je un engagement
défi
vas-y faut CLI
ça CLI ça pas ici
maisou se qualifie au candidat grâce à
la victoire de Naka au grand Suisse donc
il faut enfin grâce si Naka se qualifie
au grand Suisse et qu'après Alera se
qualifie au candidat je fais un tweet je
m'engage à faire un tweet en disant en
recommandant en disant pour les lecteurs
anglais le livre de Gotham Chess est
excellent non je m'y engage non mais
serit mieux un truc direct pour Naka que
goth lui il va se prendre tous les
lauriers pour rien au milieu quoi ouais
mais c'est un peu son ah ouais tu veux
dire que c'est pas son pote je sais pas
trop ça compte pas
faire un truc pour Naka quoi pour
Naka parce que c'est tu trouves un truc
pour Naka mais tu t'engages à faire un
truc pour Naka après si tu veux tu fais
ton truc hein c'est ton défi à toi mais
voahà c'est un peu le pire truc à faire
hein
ça floppé je pensais que ça marcherait
un truc pour Naka je peux trouver
mieux il a quoi son livre B on sait pas
en fait mais on s'attend pas à ce que ce
soit un truc de ouf mais on sait pas en
fait on l'a pas vu pas lu pas pris j'ai
pas lu non mais le Kip compte pas
alors mais je sais pas ce que tu peux
faire pour unaka en fait c'est ça le
problème je me déguise en nanas pour un
stream allez c'est ça le le le truc avec
euh avec un truc pour cararou ou quoi
ouais
ouais non mieux ça y est j'ai je viens à
la BUP à déguiser en ananas ah ouais
magnifique parce que ce sera
après il faut que je trouve le
déguisement mais euh mais je viens à la
BUP déguisant en
ananas avec la chemise
aussi bon est-ce que il y a des
déguisements ananas trouvabl oui c'est
sûr pe un peu comme le pion de rench
mais tu es dans un ananas quoi je pense
mais tu auras ta ta petite touff verte
sur la tête tu V être très très bien
quoi allez d'cord on a gag cette finale
ah ouais j' en a ah magnifique ah c'est
extraordinaire
allez en fait faudrait que tu sois comme
ça quoi qu'il arrive
non il est tellement beau ce déguisement
je vais être magnifique quoi j'arrive
déguise en ananas comme ça c'est
magnifique quoi ça tellement
[Rires]
con
qu'est-ce qu' n fait son on va voir s'il
AR à gagner ça va être dur mais bon il
va la jouer longtemps peut-être essayer
de faire
craquer mais il y a même des costumes
pour enfants je pour un fille quoi
très heureuse dans Anan va être bien
quoi et pour
Micha pour Micha ananas déguisement pour
chien Micha en ananas
quoi non ilsement de liyon quoi mich
j'ait très bien je
pense
[__]
Micha
is c'estison àanas pour chien
[Musique]
quoi les circuit je crois pas que Maxime
puisse faire grand-chose non on l' pas
trop vu dans le classement en fait
malheureusement
B petite pause pe faire la petite pause
vas-y on va juste voir firou si ça a
bougé pour comme ça
euh C5 tour D6 m B4 qui F16 bon c'est
cou ça bon il seit bouffer tous ses
pions les uns après les autres mais le
cavalier a survécu et euh
ouais il va pas gagner
heing allez pause et puis à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
he he he he
he he he
[Musique]
he
les amis on est de retour on vérifier si
Naka avit joué assez de tournant en fait
pour être éligligible à l'éo et la
réponse est
oui
après de de belles recherches ouais un
peu partout à droite à gauche ça se joue
en fait au fait qu'il est passé TR enfin
qu'il joué trois tours à la Coupe du
Monde bon sinon il aura cherché un autre
à jouer mais ou
ouais parce que les règles en fait pour
être éligible à pas juste rester à pas
jouer il faut jouer au moins quatre
tournois qui compte on va dire pas pas
l' du coin
et et donc il a joué le Qatar il a joué
nor wichess il a joué la Coupe du monde
et il est allé jusqu'en 8e de finale il
a joué ça alors après une petite finesse
quand même c'est qu'apparemment dans le
circuit Fed vont mettre des points avec
un coefficient je sais pas lequel le
championnat du monde de Blitz et de
rapide que Naka peut-être à la fin il se
qualifie via le en étant double champion
du monde je sais pas combien ça donne de
POS bah non mais c'est possible parce
queil fait des bons résultats quand même
mais tu sais que je crois qu'ils font le
truc parre chronologique ah oui mais
sera le dernier dernier c'est le dernier
dernier bah ça arrive après en fait
celui qui arrive le dernier en fait ça
arrive le 1er
janvier on peut faire plus compliqué
non du cou supporte de Naka partout tout
le
temps il en est où en parlant de
Naka il ve f32 tour H3 tour G3 prend5
ça prend un peu forme quand même ça pour
Naka il
ESS non il va pas lui lâcher une nulle
comme ça he c'est sûr qu'il va tenter
euh bon ben ça ça gagnera jamais pour
les
blancs ça devrait aller pour nul
quoi
en gr tu vas te faire dégommer des ça
paraît clair et faudrait échanger ce
pion F tu fais plus rien et c'est bon
ben qui joue plus mais depuis longtemps
il a fait nuile assez vite
aujourd'hui une petite vingtaine de
coups je dirais il a eu raison il
récupère de l'énergie pour
demain
il a joué très longtemps hier
avanthier
maisira il va falloir qu'il fasse
quelque chose pour revenir au niveau où
il était hein bah si ça l'intéresse je
sais pas ça a pas l'air enfin je sais
pas quoi dire c'est
tout porte à croire que non quoi il joue
aucun
tournoi je sais pas quoi dire après ce
qui compte c'est que lui soit content de
sa vie et peut-être tout va très bien
comme ça et on va pas lui en vouloir de
mais après oui si ça compte les échecs
il faut faire quelque
chose
ça dépend de sa motive en fait peut-être
qu' a pas motivé du tout mais jeis
d'accord avec toi
he parce que on a là un genre de grand
grand grand talent évidemment qui qui a
battu plein de record de précocité qui a
déjà dépassé les 2800 ho et cetera donc
tu on peut jamais enterrer jouur comme
ça mais après bah si il a d'autres
priorités qu'il a moins envie de
travailler qui ve faire d'autres trucs
ila toujours plutôt bien il aura
toujours un bon clic mais pas pour être
top top top joueur quoi et voilà mais ça
je pas forcer quelqu'un à le faire c'est
il fait ou il fait pas
quoi peut ne pas être motivé à jouer au
niveau mondial ah bah c'est un peu relou
de jouer aux échec je sais pas comment
dire quoi non en plus quel que soit le
sport ENF les échecs c'est ça demande
une exigence ou quoi mais un mec comme
Borg il a pris quoi ça retraite à 26 ans
il arrête pu continue à de gager des
grands chlem ou quoi bah non il s'est
arrêté euh donc tu as eu des gens à
travers l'histoire dans différents
sports qui se sont arrêtés à un moment
alors qu'ils auraient pu faire encore ou
quoi tuas ficher qui s'est barré très
tôt aux échecs tu as des gens comme ça
donc je veux dire c'est pas c'est pas
spécialement habituel ok mais ça peut
arriver et euh voilà jou aux échec c'est
très exigeant ça prend l'énergie tu dois
penser quasiment qu'à ça euh
peut-être tu dis autres truc à faire
dans la vie ça va j'ai déjà bien fait ça
longtemps j'ai bien joué j'ai déjà joué
les candidats j'ai été numéro de mondial
je gagne encore ma vie avec assez
facilement je fais quelques tournois ça
me pay une belle vie j'ai mes sponsoring
j'ai mes trucs pourquoi je ferais plus
et tu t'arrêtes là enfin tu vois ce que
je veux dire pourquoi pas c'est pas
forcément un mauvais calcul c'est
ainsi en cas là s'il veut pouvoir
prétendre à regagner beaucoup de kayas
il va falloir qu'il MRE les bouchées
doubles parce que moi je parle killas
non mais la cayas je crois que ça va
pour lui mais le problème c'est si ça
prend cette pente et que tu redescends à
2720 par là tu seras peut-être un peu
moins invité partout tout le temps je
sais pas les sponsoring ce que ça
donnera et cetera
mais je me fais pas trop de souc pour
lui pour se retrouver sous un pont je
veux dire ça va
il y a la cas quand
même ah tu veux dire que peut-être il
pense pas à ses Cillas quoi je pense il
pense bien kayas mais que mais
que mais qu'il est pas en trayarde de
kayas il est pas en trard d'échec après
peut venir de différents endroits
quoi
donc je sais pas puis mais je vous dis
enfin c'est pas le gen de tu pe il est
toujours très jeune il a un énorme
talent mais sans travail la puissance
n'est
rien donc il faut c'est hyper
important et le truc c'est qu'il l'a
déjà beaucoup fait ces jeunes années
donc voilà ça dépend juste de lui de sa
motive et son envie
enfin pas le talent qui manque
c'est non je pense pas que ce soit trop
tard sil remet très sérieusement parce
qu'il est il est t dans un très bon
temps de
passage par rapport aux autres jeune
joueur il est pas largué mais il est
autant il était au-dessus enfin il était
très en avance là en en fait il jouera
un match contre abusatorof ou pragananda
ou quoi je suis pas sûr que soit
meilleur je te dis pas qu'il est moins
bien non plus mais du coup il est plus
trop en avance quoi il a perdu son son
avantage et les autres ils travaillent
donc en fait c'est ça c'est que la
courbe va s'inverser au bout d'un moment
et au bout d'un jour ça deviendra
irrécupérable après les mecs qui sont
plus âgés de toute façon ils vont
décliner par eux-mêmes petit à petit
même Carlsen ou quoi à un moment il
jouera plus peut-être dans 10 15 ans ou
ou avant bien avant je sais pas donc eux
ils ont ils ont à peine 20 ans donc ils
seront encore là dans 10 ans donc de
toute façon normalement c'est un de qui
qui reprendra le titre
quoi non tu as bien parlé hein je v
laissé parler mais ouais non je pas trop
je regarde un peu ce que ça dit aussç il
y a rien d'autre à dire enfin on a tout
dit
hein VO son pion
a les gens disent qu'ils espèrent qu'ils
espèrent ce que qui a les rés au
candidats sinon les candidats vont être
longs et chiant ouais mais en fait ça
veut dire beaucoup plus sur le sport et
sur les format que que
sur que sur les Français qui se
qualifient ou pas c'est-à-dire que si
ton sport est inregardable si tu as pas
un joueur que tu supportes ça veut dire
beaucoup sur ton sport en fait pas
normal tu peux pas avoir ne pas enfin je
sais pas une finale de grand schlem j'en
ai regardé combien sans qu'il y a de
joueurs français parce que juste c'est
Banger parce qu'il y en a jamais quoi ou
il y en a jamais
Banger tu regardes tu regardes les trucs
mais si en fait le truc tu as besoin
qu'il a un joueur c'est qu'en fait c'est
vraiment très très
naze
bonsoir param est vraiment bien mais on
a toujours dit on a pas le bon iranienin
ouais fais voir on peut cliquer c'est
juste là ouais alors il a pas gagné ça
s'accroche en face mais oui il essaie il
va la jouer longtemps il peut il peut la
gagner il a des vraies bonnes Chan
réelle envis la un jour moins commenter
ses formats au profit de format plus
orienté commu j'ai pas compris le
malheureusement c'est pas nous qui
faisons les
formatsubaon
plus c'est bien
il se bat bien
quoi je crois qu'il a juste PERP en fait
que F5
ouis mais bah c'est très bien
bravo il s'est bien battu quand
même j en danger de
perdre ça va faire
nul ça
devrait devrait faire nul en fait aussi
non non ben oui ça devrait pas traîner
de ouf Naka et Naka moi je le vois bien
gagner bravo à lui s'il y
arrive il fait ouais il tente il pousse
il va pousserinov dans ses
retranchements et c'est dur he de
défendre défendre
défendre bonne partti de live des
candidat est parti avec Magnus aussi bon
je sais pas oui mais oui c'est vrai que
le fait cl le de championnat du monde
soit ouais tout est rien n'est bien en
fait ça le
problème
donc c'est ça que tu te reposes un peu
sur tes joueurs plus que sur les
compétitions en fait bah après je mais
même le tennis en fait si cétait c'était
tout d'un coup plus que des mecs
complètement nuls tu regardais pas non
plus tu as besoin qu'il a quand même des
bons joueurs alors tu as pas ça sera pas
forcément de la classe du Big 3 ou quoi
mais mais ça joue quand même et donc
pareil C tuas des candidats que avec des
abasof on va s'en [__] complet mais et
puis j'ai l'impression que quand tu as
plus de d'équité sportive quand tu sens
que le truc est mal foutu ça dégoûte un
peu
aussi de regarder un truc un peu bizarre
que c'est l'impression que ça donne les
échecs aussi mais mais bon cette année
quoi qu'il en soit tu devrais avoir un
Naka d'une manière d'une autre carwana
nepo
raganonda pourquoi pas bon tu auras
quand même un tournoi qui va être
intéressant est-ce que vous envisagez la
perçu d'arrêtez carrément de commentter
ces T pour faire plus des sessions Blitz
bah on en fait déjà toute l'année STZ
donc au bout d'un moment 365 jour de
session Blitz c'est pas non
plus le sub battle il y en a ici ou là
mais ça peut pas être tout le temps
parce queent ça perd son côté sympa
quand même bah oui c'est trop vu c'est
trop pareil c'est trop ça par contre
c'est bien de le faire de temp en temps
parce que un côté marrant et cool
enfin je pense un mélange de tout en
fait en fait faut pas tomber dans le
même problème que ces tournois làen fait
quand c'est toujours la même chose et
que c'est long et Machin ça devient
chiant B parce que c'est
rare l'intégrité d'une compétition une
condition nécessaire au succès du sport
mais ça je suis tout à fait d'accord en
fait quand tu as un format globalement
qui veut rien dire de a Z les cadences
qui veulent rien dire et tout ça ça nuit
fortement mais après c'est pas grave on
s'en
fout qui quand même très inquiet les
candidat ser mon fleur la journée tontau
le soir
oui
une festin vers 18h bah festin à midi
festin à 18h enfin full
festin c'est bien on pour entendre la
petite Sophia pleurer à minuit à 1h à 2h
à 3h on saura qu'elle se réveille
hein bon mais là faut le bouffer ce pion
F3 non mais après Naka c'est pas fini
là il est bien il va il gagne
aujourd'hui il revient il est égalité
avec les premiers non euh oui ah non
mais Naka peut se qualifier mais ce ce
système de départage est complètement
con aussi non mais gen au bout d'un
moment enfin je donnais un exemple à par
l'arurde à fabière admettons Taka tu es
2780 h tu joues dernière ronde B contre
vidit admettons même si ont déjà jou
ensemble il est 2720 toi tu es Naka tu
as joué une une moyenne ho à 26 on va
dire 90 et l'autre a joué une moyenne
hlo à 2688 donc tu as deux points de
plus de moyenne que l'autre donc de base
tu es devant mais tu joues contre lui et
comme toi tu as plus d'élo que lui dans
le 1 V1 bah ça va ça va retourner les
les moyennes parce que lui il va enfin
toi tu vas perdre des points par rapport
à lui parce que toi tu es plus fort et
en soit rien que cet exemple par
l'absurde montre à quel point le truc
est juste débile en fait ça ça ne peut
pas en fait mais en fait le problème
c'est que chaque départage a son
problème oui mais celui-là il est juste
débile enfin par absurde je bah là je
t'ai démontré par absurde TR est ils
sont tous mauvais en fait les départag
bah alors que pour un truc c'est
important si c'est égalité qu'on fasse
des matchs en faiton joue quoi enfin
mais tu peux pas faire tabler sur un
truc pareil genre là par l'absurde je
t'ai montré que le truc est déjà débile
en fait c'est c'est évident que c'est
débile une fois que je je t'ai fait
cette présentation
c'est comme di Jos c'est pas pour rien
qu'il est absolument jamais utilisé
enfin personne n'utilise ce départage
parce qu'il est complètement
débile mais genre pour un truc si
important que des quand candidat tu peux
pas reposer là-dessus tu ne peux
pas tu fais des matchs en rapide ou ce
que tu veux tu prévois un jour de plus
s'il faut mais gen au point où on en est
on joue des cadence tellement longu des
trucs à rallonge pour être bien sûr de
machin et tout et après on te fait des
trucs comme
ça tu sais mais globalement on aura
probement pas le cas de figure comme ça
mais ça peut oui mais juste il prouve
que en fait ça va pas mais de toute
façon il y a toujours un enfin il y a je
connais aucun bon départage
malheureusement il y a toujours des des
défauts dans l'un dans l'autre dans si
dans
ça enfin là au moins les départages en
rapide pour les places au candidat je
veux dire au moins tu joues au moins tu
jou au échec quoi là ils vont te dire
mais imagine il y a TR joueurs ouou oui
il te disent c'est un truc infernal mais
bon en fait tout est un infernal enfin
ben il y a trois joueurs et ben on jou
moi je fais jouer jusqu'à jusqu'à
épuisement bah moi aussi ça va bien
finir à un moment donné par se
départager je m'en fiche que vous soyez
trois en fait cet argument tient pas
dans en bah par exemple au foot bah les
tir au but but ouis tout le monde peut
marquer son tir but tout le temps tout
monde peut le rater enfin pe importe
mais c'est infini donc non mais tout
peut être infini tout bah le tennis le
tennis aussi mais en fait un point peut
être infini personne s jamais la balle
ouais non mais j' avec ce r mais bon
c'est les joueurs d'chec hein tu as des
raisonnements des fois mais d'une bêtise
mais d'une bêtise mon
Dieu est-ce que m'avait dit j'avais un
un un ami en Russie qui était un grand
économiste assez connu en fait
d'ailleurs enfin vraiment connu en vrai
et il m'avait dit un truc il m'avait dit
euh la chose qui peut enfin c'est dur à
traduire mais la chose qui peut mettre
l'intelligence à terre c'est la bêtise
pure quoi ais mais ouais mais là les
échecs tout le temps dedans c'est des
trucs c'est tellement bêtes que ça te W
c'est puis ils sont contents d'eux tu
quoi tu peux être aussi bête hallucinant
des fois ça peut pas être infini fauter
ta connerie ouis
oui mais c'est dur d'être aussi bête en
fait mais alors là mais oui mais gen en
fait ça t'épuise ça ça te on on joue pas
les départag d'ailleurs il y aura TR
vainqueurs d'ailleurs mais même elle est
parti avec 30 secondes par coup a vu le
nombre de coup enfin tout peut-être
infini en fait avec le ah la bêtise pure
c'est hallucinant c'est c'est d'une
puissance en fait il c'est hyper
puissant mais tu ne peux rien faire
contre l'intelligence est complètement
désarçonné par la bêti en fait c'est tu
tu tu as plus ton arme en
fait je sais pas si si grave il a
beaucoup
réfléchi pourquoi il fait ça
çon il y aura r G2 c'est pas trop le
choix non mais là je trouve que en gros
si tu pars du principe qu'il y a pas de
système de départage correct et ça je
peux très bien l'entendre pour des
places au candidat tu tu dois jouer des
matchs en fait c'est soit tu pars du
principe je peux faire un départage qui
paraî bien increct et qui et et qui suit
l'équité du sport et du coup tu
l'utilises et j'ai aucun problème avec
ça soit tu décides ben il se trouve que
c'est pas possible et et dans ces cas-là
ben tu joues des matchs tu joues des
matchs
mais et puis puis il y a pas d'argument
pour nous dire ah oui mais c'est c'est
un tourno cadence lente vous qualifiez
des mecs sur un match en rapide et vous
faites quoi la Coupe du monde et vous
faites quoi au championnat du monde
d'ailleurs championnat du monde se finit
en rapide tout se finit en rapide donc
donc bon voilà ce n'est pas un
argument c'est pas les joueurs d'échec
c'est des organisateurs il se trouve
que c'est des joueurs d'échec donc ou
non
c'est je sais pas
pourquoiir fou si ça fait nul si ça joue
bon comm çajà c'est une bonne nouvelle
rou c'est enfin voilà par rapport à il y
a une demi-heure on va dire 1 heure on
est quand même un peu mieux là ouais il
va mettre ses tour sur la 6e et faire
blocus et puis se passera rien et puis
et puis ça peut durer le temps que ça
dure mais bon on nespère pas trop quand
même quoi
le bourreau stronquet je suis aussi
assez d'accord je trouve déjà mieux le B
stronqu que
ça et le cumulatif est assez bête mais
d'un autre côté au moins tu peux t'en
prendre qu toi-même quoi fallait marquer
les points mais bon après comme on dit
tu es très dépendant de de tes
adversaires et de si tu commences avec
les blans ou les noirs sur dans un TR
comme ça oui mais tu peux mettre en
premier du coup que tu peux vers le
cumulatif en départage 2 et départage 1
le nombre de fois o que tu as eu les
blancs ou les Noirs parce que c'est un
tel avantage un T comme ça d'avoir une
fois de plus les blancs tu es plutôt
mieux ouais que tu es plutôt mieux donc
tu peux euh tu peux quand même tu tu
peux tu peux y réfléchir quoi
ou
alors je sais pas tu prends plusieurs
départages
et tu non mais tu prends le cumulatif tu
prends le bols tu prends le BR tronqué
tu prends la perf tu prends je sais pas
quoi bon peut-être ça suffit d'ailleurs
et tu comptes combien de fois tu es
devant par rapport à l'autre ouais tu ok
s'il y a de de déjà bon tu vas réduire
les trucs et peut-être tu tu'en tires un
au sort qui sera décisif à ce momentlà
parce que faudra bien décider mais que
en fait si tu es de ais et les couleurs
aussi je les mettrai dedans en 5è au
moins si a de de c'est les couleurs qui
décid on va peut-être séparer encore
mais dans C cas tu bon tu finis par
piloufass quoi mais oui je suis d'accord
avec toi tu cumules les
départages comme ça tu tu ténu un peu
tout mais bon je pense dans tous les cas
que pour une qualifou Candida ça doit se
joue en départag en oui c'est norm c'est
normal mais tu rajoute une journée pour
ça enfin tant
pis tuas déjà envoyé tellement de fric
pour ça personne regarde enfin ouii non
mais évidemment tu déjà envoyé rien que
pour les hôtels les machins des JS les
avions je sais pas déjà un million
d'euros déjà enfin tu es plus un jour
près quoi pour les cas départage mais
surtout que tu fais venir un jour avant
machin tu changes les horaires pour un
feu d'artifice ouais c'est ça c'est que
c'estjà ça va quoi tu peux tu peux on va
pas t'en vouloir
quoi
un nombre de rond perd pour le même
nombre de blanc et noir bah tu nous
expliqueras comment tu fais bratque en
fait tu réussis à nous faire une formule
mathématique qui le permet je pense ce
serait révolutionnaire mais
malheureusement par faire des
des appareillements ultra chelous qui
font plus aucun sens c'est pas
possible en fait il y a toujours un
paire parce que malheureusement tu dois
doubler par-ci par là ENF tu le demandes
pas mais c'est comme ça et de finir avec
64 ça fait une énorme différence là tout
le monde va faire faire 65 dans un sens
dans l'autre mais tu essayes d'atténuer
l'injustice mais si tu mets un nombre de
rond paire il y aura des gens qui vont
devoir doubler un moment ou un autre a
priori par la force des choses et et du
coup il y aura un trop gros
écart après peut-être qu'il y a une
solution mathématique enfin ça par
contre c'est possible il y a peut-être
une solution mathématique pour le faire
juste on l'a réellement pas trouvé
j'étais premier degré en fait
ou il fait trop long sinon alors toi tu
as vraiment pas eu de chance he pour le
coup et ça peut vraiment arriver oui que
bon là ça c'est mais c'est ce sera pour
le seul TR de ta vie çaarriveras
mais tu devais pas être bien quand
même
GCO ilpère mettre un cavali en F4 et sur
G3 faire tour de avec un réseau de
math à cause des points fictifs une
belleention les points
fictifs c'est bien pour les norme
attention
mais tout ce
qui ave
nor des normes en fait pourquoi ils sont
tout le temps si heureux des normes je
sais fait ton tournoi différemment
limite
par ça
but point fictif l'ession que norme
c'est une fin en soi pour beaucoup ouais
qu'est-ce qu'on s'en
fout c'est le titre quoi oui mais non
mais je sais on s'en fout quand même le
tit tellement dévalué qu'il a plus de
valeur quoi enfin il a une valeur mais
genre on s'en fout ENF c'est puis de
toute façon le jour où tu as vraiment le
niveau tu l'auras en c'est pas le titre
de Grand Maître il a plus le sens qu'
avait le ah bah oui quand il était en 50
on a enlevé toute la la magie toute la
magie du titre alors maintenant ça
continue à dire à grand maître mais en
fait
c'est début je crois que c'était 48
c'est ça même moins non je sais plus
faire on
peutou c'est un peu de
lecture un petit peu de
lecture fautil
trouver
mais on va
trouver B ah
non
gaffe euh grand maître grand maître
grand
matre
1950 c'est augmenté oui
d'accord 27 joueurs seulement en 1950 on
reçu ce titre honorifique en faon de
leur réputation leur résultats dans les
compétions internationales parmi ses
premers grand matr on peut citer des
légendes du jeu comme mich V max ou
samuelsk et d'autres d'autes titre
Postume d' je crois
ok c'était que 27 grand m dans toute la
planète de base quoi
ouais mais pas c'est tu montes à 150 200
joueurs actif je veux bien mais après
auudessus c'est beaucoup
quoi après tu dois rendre les règles
drastiquement plus compliqué après qu' a
plus de joueurs que le niveau moyen
monte un peu que si que ça bon ok mais
là
c'est bah c'est devenu
trop ça doit vraiment
être grand ça doit vraiment être réservé
à du très très lourd quoi de la nation
HM il a peut-être pas gagné he le Naka
non il fait fait bouffer
[Musique]
B3 tu te fais bouffer B3
quoi tu moins de joueur avant faut faire
le calcul en proportion non mais c'est
pas une question de nombre de joueurs
c'est que cétait un titre d'élite quoi
non mais c'est vrai quand tu dis je suis
grand maître quand les gens connaiss pas
les échecs j'ai l'Impr qu'il croit que
tu es euh tu es
exceptionnel alors ok sur la masse des
joueurs ça reste pas mal hein mais euh
tu es loin d'être exceptionnel à
prétendre être dans les meilleurs
mondiaux quoi euh alors que normalement
ouais tu t'attends à ce que grand ma
soit vraiment un truc élitiste élitiste
genre que maintenant les grand matres
son les mecs à plus de 2700 ouais à peu
près
ça pourquoi pas 2650 après on peut
discuter je veux dire mais ça devrait
pas être
moins aujourd'hui avec toute les
l'inflation qu'il y a eu le machin le
truc pour garder l'esprit de l'époque
quoi 2700 c'est ultra exceptionnel ouais
mais bah oui mais cétait ex à la base il
y en avait 27 dans le monde donc là même
même 2007 tu dois avoir 40 50 pu que tu
gardes les mecs qui et puis ceux qui les
ont eu et qui sont redescendus genre by
serait grand maître zler il sera grand
maître pono
mariof acoup je sais pas ouais voilà
enfin carpof et cetera
quoi donc je sais pas c'est
ça peut se discuter mais c'est vrai que
c'est je pense ça été plus dans l'esprit
de comment ça a été créé au début alors
après tu peux créer un autre titre de
super grand maître
mais ça ne serait pas grand maître non
mais bon bah tant pis hein je serai rien
ou je serai autre chose ser peut-être
maître en fait tui je serai
pour non mais ou du coup peut-être que
j'aurais été d'autant plus motivé pour
essayer d'y
arriver Mo jeux pas te
dire9 a jamais été grand maître mais bon
après il était pas si fort enfin il
était fort mais pas tant que ça quoi pas
assez pour être grand maître quoi mais
maintenant il serait non ouis maintenant
il serait très facilement mais genre à
l'époque c'était pas choquant dire que
fa pas grand maître
ouais puis bon au final c'est pas le
fait d'être grand maître qui te fait
vivre je sais pas comment dire mais en
fait c'est ton classement ho donc te
dire que les gens ah ouais lui il serait
pas grand maître il virait pas des
échecs ça changerait strictement rien en
fait oui oui tuuras le même truc
c'est pas bon bref c'est comme ça c'est
pas grave enfin
mais plus avec les points fictifs dans
les tourn pour faire les noroui
vraiment nétait pas grand
mretait pas à l'époque
ou il on donné un titre Postume ou pas
d'ailleurs je suis pas sûr je crois je
sais pas ce qu'il mériterait
ouior
incroyable
al Kin non plus alekin il titre poum ou
pas je sais plus comment ils
ont en tout cas il donna à des gens qui
étaient inactifs gen robinstein jouit
plus aux échecs il était vivant et il
l'a
eu mais bon oui bon alikin normalement
devrait l'être enfin ça va tous les gars
champions du monde normalement quand
même bon on va faireien mais est-ce que
les grand d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas quand
même le niveau suffisant pour battre les
grands matres d'avant bah si mais en
fait c'est comme si du coup au foot que
les joueurs de national aujourd'hui ils
sont plus forts que les joueurs de la
clsao qui a gagné les deux Coupes du
Monde d'affilé parce que c'est
probablement vrai que les joueurs de
Ligue 2 sont plus forts aujourd'hui mais
enfin je chacun est dans son
temps donc tu c'est pas bien de comparer
les époques sur des choses qui évoluent
c'est même stupide quoi en soi pas le
même matériel pas le même entraînement
pas le même plein de choses
quoi non mais Platini probablement moins
fort qu'un Kakuta
quoi peut-être pas quand même c'est
jouur Kakuta non mais il est il est bon
un bon joueur mais bon platiniste quand
même je suis vraiment pas sûr
ouais mais physiquement et tout ils sont
tellement plus forts
aujourd'hui il fer des feuilles mortes
sur les coups francs il ser quand même
là distriba le jeu je pense Zizou même
là 50 ans Lu fais une là ça Sainté quoi
tu peux jouer monor Jeu
euh c'est bon vas-y on va trouver
comment jouer tu troublieras pas trop on
va courir pour toi
quoi et puis là en plus les échecs ça a
tellement évolué avec l'ordinateur aussi
non mais là oui les échecs non les
échecs serait plus comme comparer les
mecs au tennis qui a leur vieill
raquettes en boîte avec tes trucs
bam c'est vrai que ça a complètement
changé le jeu hein complètement bah tu
vois les balles avant euh les échanges
j'étais beaucoup plus en cloche parce
que bah c'est pas ouais ah c'est pas le
même matériel mais je crois que je crois
que Mazo il joue contre les mecs des
années 4050 il numéro mondial mais sans
problème ENF c'est même pas enfin c'est
60 60 à tous les matchs je sais pas fara
voir c'est pas sûr mais P mais tu tu as
vu la la vitesse des services
aujourd'hui par rapport à avant
il suit un peu peut-être que même le
raquette av même pas
capacité trou les raquettes
quoi
nabuse pas bah il est 2 6 Mazo 4 6 4 6
ou 5 c'est il tape hyper fort et tu leur
laisses leur matériel d'avant tu vois
que ça va pas être puis les prend dans
revers après ça bouge pas
quoi
le pire ce serait au vélo avec la
pharmacologie
he nous dit PV la Cuse je lui mets un
vélo mais je pense he qu'
[Rires]
F avec les
Mousquetaires une HE et dem
après se fre la pharmacologie
néerlandaise dans la tronche
quoi triplé triplé à la
[Rires]
f il fa un trou la raquette avec sa
première balle ouais mais Kakuta du coup
il vaut quoi alors ce Kakuta bah écoute
il est bon euh
on a une gros eSport peut-être pour une
plus grosse carrière mais je crois qu'il
est parti tôt à Chelsea il était repéré
enfin c'est un beau joueur mais après il
a joué un peu àance et je sais pas amen
machin enfin mainant il do plutôt en
Ligue 2 non ce qu'il fait ouais donc bon
en Ligue 2 tu bah tu c'est bien en fait
déjà Li 2 quoi just la concurrence qu' a
au foot mais g Kakuta ouais parce qu'en
fait Bendo sa chanson il numéro 10 comme
Kakuta enfin ok c'est de là que ça vient
alors mais mais bon quand même Platini
tu
vois je crois que c'était vraiment très
très fort moi je l'ai pas pas vu jouer
en fait j'étais trop je suis trop
jeune mais
ok trois fois Ballon d'Or quand même qui
platinist international aussi
non euh non mais international eSport il
a été je pense qu'il é formé au Havre si
des gens qui peuvent me dire dans le
chat
[Musique]
euh mais bon joueur enfin il a fait sa
carrière Heine il a quelqu'un qui a un
autographe de Kakuta à côté de lui quoi
enfin bah oui
parce qu'il te cite quand même du Kakuta
enfin il te le cite directement en fait
numéro 10 Kakuta
directement
du coup moi j'attends à ce qu'il soit
très fort quoi
h l'équipe d' m'a fait le plus rêver
euh écoute j'en ai eu deux que j'ai bien
aimé on va dire alors de mon vivantin
euh parce que sinon c'était mieux avant
mais c'était l'équipe qu' remoné avec
Alexo devant c'était cool ça jouit bien
avec nos arr entraînurs fa passeport
c'est arrivé après mais c'est pas eux en
fait mais c'est d'autres enfin était
n'importe très mal géré euh c'est quoi
cette hisire de passeport d'ailleurs ben
je crois que tu av le droit à trois
joueurs extra communautaires pu ils se
sont mis à dire ouais tiens lui il est
deses grec lui machin puis mis à faire
de la merde c'est ridicule quoi
c'était et c'était pas les présidents
actuels desjà on est tombé sur des
génies avant quoi donc pourquoi ils ont
fait ça je sais
pas c'est c'est hyper comp en plus on
était remonté on a une bonne petite
équipe on avait pas besoin de faire ça
quoi c'est incroyable
quoi mais comment c'est
possible je sais pas ils sont cru malin
je sais pas je peux pas dire tu aussi
con bah ils sont dit ouais tiens c'est
cool en plus c'est pour recruter des des
rouskov quoi il y avait Maxime levitski
au goal qui était nul d'ailleurs qui
faisit jartter après on avait remis
alono et Jano et pour prendre panof en
attaque le petit attaque en russe ouais
je me rappelle qui était bon mais je
crois qu'il a chopé une une hépathite
une merde quand il est venu après il
avançait plus il é complètement nul chez
nous alors de bas le recrué c'était pas
idiot mais bon c'est comme ça mais ok
quoi en fait on a un frein les règles
pour faire jouer des crétins qui était
qui apportait équipe on est redescendu
on est des points retirés ENF on a tout
eu quoi laisse tomber donc
euh non mais cette équipe là j'aimais
bien avant les faux papiers les faux
passeports quoi la première année quand
on a remonté il y avait un mélange entre
un peu les l'ature de l'équipe de Ligue
2 plus alexizo tu Péron i gauche il
était bien Péron il venait de l'Orient
puis il a fini sa carrière un peu à
Paris lance ti Gouel à droite petit
petit y voirien qui
euh on se batit quoi défense il y avait
jean- Guy wallem tu vois quiort son
expérience metomo quarm c'est un
norvégien qui qui était bien bon écoute
c'est une équipe qui se battait on avait
Patrick Guillou on avait des mecs
vaillants quoi en plus donc j'aimis bien
cette équipe et puis sinon euh oui bah
l'équipe d'obame tout ça qu'on a gagné
la Coupe de la Ligue c'était sympa
ça jouait bien auame Branda au devant tu
avais amuma tu avais un bon milieu de
terrain avec des gars qui se battaai
bien CAD le moine Clément en général
mais guilavogi qu'on est formé qui
arrivait on avait Zuma du centre de
formation qui était
bien une bonne petite équipe du Zuma
cafeo quoi Zuma cafeo et puis pin
derrière qui tenait la
baraque c'était c'était une belle équipe
et voilà c'est deux meilleurs que j'ai
connu ouais il était bon lui ouais ouais
c'est de meilleurs équipes que j'ai
connu tu avais pas un sablé si ah mais
ça CIT la première équipe c'est plus
année 2000 mais c'est hyper fort lui non
pant longtemps il se battait à fond non
ouais pas hyper fort mais bon on l'imait
bien il tenait bien c un milieu défensif
qui qui se battait bien puis il a fini
sa carrière
après il a joué un peu à lance il a joué
je crois Nice et Basti si je dis pas de
bêtises mais on l'imit bien était
capitaine de l'équipe il bon joueur quoi
et
[Musique]
euh et voilà mais oui non l'équipe de
2013 CIT sûrement la plus forte quoi
Ruffi auul c'était fort Perin derrière
c'était bien Bayal j'aimais bien c'était
c'était c'était c'était costaud
quoi François clar droit j'aimais bien
enfin belle équipe
quoi Alexo c'est plus j'étais jeune on
redécouvrir la Ligue 1 ça faisait un peu
rêver ça faisit football samba donc
mais objectivement je pense l'équipe
2013 c'est la plus forte que j'ai connu
ils ont fait quoi ils ont ils ont
terminé combien ils ont fait ils sont
allé en Ligue des Champions ou non
jamais on a d faire 4e 45e c'est sûr et
régulier en fait et gagneré la Coupe de
la Ligue
et coupe d'urope on passait des tours on
était là quoi bon ça coinçait quoi mais
tu as eu du funo ah j'aimais pas du tout
al funo ouais c'est un peu après c'est
milieu des années 2000 on l'aimait bien
il était un peu un peu foufou quoi des
fois il jouit bien des fois moins bien
mais très très talentueux
quoi mais c'était l'époque où non on est
une bonne petite équipe quoi mais là on
c'était pas du niveau de 2013 quoi j'ai
envie de
dire bon bref voilà
pour CIT du Cabella non aussi ouais mais
ça c'était bien mais ça céit plus récent
bonne petite équipe c'est un peu après
c'est plus 2018
et
et maintenant c'est vraiment pas
terrible non non on est nul mais j'aime
bien les mecs se battent là c année il
s'arrach sur le terrain et écoute ça
peut ça peut monter après faud
on verra mais là oui enfin c'est pas
comparable c'est moins fort tout les
équipes qu'on a cité là et tuas encore
là le génie comment il s'appa Crass non
il son contrat c'est fini et il est
parti à l'Étoile rouge de
Belgrade je crois pas qu'il soit trop
titulire mais de jouer un peu il génie à
pintor
non génial P rien que nom ça un peu à P
ouis non P était pas très
[Musique]
bon il nous a pas laissé un grand
souvenir grass bien il nous a porté à
bout de bras l'
dernier bon joueur en
fait avez des joueurs genre mythi ou
quoi ça pas
joué
ça aurait pu non non dans les derniers
vraiment gros joueurs on a eu Laurent
Blanc mais il y a longtemps hein mais
bon leuran blanc c'est pas mal quand
même
quoi on a vu Morf chic dans les années
90 c'était un euh je crois c'était
slovaque enfin je sais pas s'il av déjà
eu la S entre Tchécoslovaquie mais euh
et puis dans les joueurs plus modernes
on a eu paayette et matuid mais qui
étaiit pas leur prime mais qui étaient
jeune et fort et puis après ils sont
devenus c auudessus quoi
mais mais genre blanc je veux dire quand
on l'avait était titulaire enfin était
équipe de France
quoi donc ça date ah ou ça date
et vous avez aussi non jamais eu
non non Saliba ouais mais on l'a formé
très fort on a des bons petits jeunes
quoi je veux dire
mais Marl qui souent de moi j'étais un
peu jeune mais je ouais je de lui je
l'avais vu au stade ou
quoi et auam ouais non auam c'est s
notre dernier pépite ouais mais vraiment
il fort
au il VI un peu mais c'est bien pour
Marseille quand même c'est un beau
joueur quoi mais mais Marseilles sont au
fond non pas au fond mais ouais mais ob
pour moi c un des meilleurs attaquants
d'Europe bah d'ailleurs après il à
Dortmund il claquait des buts il une
petite pige à Barcelone entretemps et
enfin Arsenal
Barcelone c'est des beau clubs quoi
quand tu joues dans ces clubs là c'est
que tu es pas tu es pas un nulos
quoi il éit vraiment fort et Marseille
pense ça à remonter ou pas ils sont vra
Marseille non mais ils sont une bonne
équipe après je sais pas pourquoi ça
prend pas vraiment plus que ça il y a
peut-être des problèmes extra sportifs
mais tues le effectif il est bien
ouis c'est vrai qu'on est baffé aussi
qui est devenu un peu plus fort après
quand il est parti mais chez nous c'est
qu' a eu sa première sélection à ce
momentl il a fait son doublé pour le
premier match en équipe de France il a
joué à Marseille aussi après donc ouais
il a joué à Lyon il a joué partout
il a fait une bonne carrière
bonjour Il des connaisseurs de foot hein
dans le chat c'est ouais c'est beau
hein et Guarin c'était c'est pas vous si
mais il était pas très connu il av pas
une frappe de loin lui si si j'adorais
frapp mais en fait on l'a pas vraiment
fait jouer souvent
titulaire je sais pas moi j'aurais bien
voulu le voir plus et puis après il est
parti non au Portugal et puis il a
explosé il a joué à Porto l'Inter il a
une belle car enfin mais chez nous il a
rien fait d'extraordinaire mais on
sentait un potentiel une une grinta une
grosse
frappe
il y avait aussi le génie là comment il
s'appelait amuma amuma très bien bon
joueur alors pas car internationale mais
il
était très bon joueur de
ligue très fin techniquement ça il a pas
été éperné par les
blessures AA pu faire plus je sais pas
mais
non je pense tous les SP ont bien aimé
amuma
quoi
un mot ch des 6 pour att un niveau
descend en profondeur 6 c'est un peu
léger je pense profondeur 6 ouais ça va
pas très
loin marlou qui conna tous les joueurs
qui sont passés par sainé et Lyon
quoi erreur de fouja
euh non
non non non non
je sais pas pourquoi mais et param ouais
ouais ouais ça l'air se conclure pour
param qui qui revient bien bien dans la
cour il arrive en en tête
execo il sort quand le DVD sur laquelle
euh alors ça dépend pas de MO il est
tourné hein donc euh c'est chez chess
bas et c'est à eux de l'éditer et de
c'est eux qui ont les clés en main je
leur conseille de le faire le plus tôt
possible parce c'est toujours pareil
pour tous les ouvrages ou vidéos
d'ouverture c'est ça vieillit avec le
temps parce qu'il y a des nouveautés qui
sont joué des il se passe des trucs donc
ce qui est vrai à un moment ça sera
peut-être un peu moins 2 ans après même
si bon on essaie de faire le plus
sérieux possible he mais mais donc
voilà mais ça je sais pas mais j'imagine
courant
2024 quand même ça devit arriver je l'ai
tourné en en
septembre 625 à pas peut craquer hein
bah faut pas se faire mater
quoi mais bon il ramène bien le cavalier
quand même et ouais j'ai faitussi
janovski ouais exactement j'avais fait
ça c'était un peu avant ça je l'ai fait
en décembre l'année dernière euh bah
c'est pour ceux qui cherchent un
répertoire sur D4 et c'est un grand
Midam qui joue bien
euh pourquoi pas enfin je veux dire ce
oui en vu que je l'ai fait j'ai fait
essayer de le faire le plus
consciencieusement possible normalement
ça te fait un répertoire pour tout ce
qui est gambidam
ouais
et ce Cho ils deviennent quoi ils ont eu
s hisoire quoi ils étaient en Ligue 2
l'an dernier il ils ont fait leur saison
pas mal d'ailleurs et euh et je sais pas
problème avec le les dirigeants le le
sponsor
et l'actionnaire qu' on va dire et euh
ils ont été rétrogradés donc là ça va
ils sont que en National ça aura pu être
bien pire mais
euh bon c'est déjà pas terrible mais au
moins le club est pas
mort mais c'était belle équipe non ça
quand ils étaient en Ligue 1 ah oui
socho c'est un beau club c'est un c'est
un des monuments on va dire du foot
français en quelque sorte qui
a qui a eu énormément de saisons dans
l'élite qui est souvent Lig euh et euh
euh qui a formé de nombreux bons joueurs
c'est tu il Astro astrotor Soo le
deuxième club avec le plus de 100 en
Ligue 1 ouais donc c'est un c'est un
historieque quoi c'est ça mais céit pas
genre un déclassement super difficile
quand tu était en Ligue 1 genre la Soo
cétait pas un peu la h la Bonal ouais
euh ouais non mais c'est jamais facile
puis même récemment ils avaient une
belle équipe il enné 2000 avec pederti
fro Wilson Ruma et cetera Isabel voilà
euh ils avaient comment il s'appelle
Mathieu en défense
aussi donc bref ils avaient une bonne
petite équipe c'était bien et
euh alors land je me souviens pas je
sais que land il était à
Nant mais qu' a fin à Basti il me semble
l'endroit il av pedreti ouais mais mais
je sais pas peut-être qu'il a fait un
tour par socho mais je me souviens pas
mais oui oui il for bien socho donc là
bon ouais il ils sont dans le dur mais
écoute s'ils survivent enfin ils ont
survécu mais cette année je sais pas
s'ils vont remonter ou quoi mais que tu
prends le temps de souffler et que tu
reviens ben on sait pas ça remontera
peut-être il se passe quoi sur tour D7
cavalier E6 ouais je pense cavalier F5
ouais bah faut plus bouger ah tuas t
C7 tu es à de Doig hein de d'avoir des
problèmes
rraque sen sort bien de chez parinof
pour l'instant on va
voir ça déjà jou en Ligue des champions
ce chix je crois pas mais tuas jou la
coupe d'
ça il a peu de clubs qui ont jou la
Ligue des Champions ouais mais c'est
ouais bon je sais pas pourquoi leur dit
maises mauvais coup à chaque coup mais
is mais je comprends en fait il va te
cacher le roit par là-bas il va te
mettre une tour en F6 du coup il va être
tout caché puis après il va essayer de
jouer avec le
cheval quand tu mettas des échecs ilve
le roi de bouffer un pion puis il va
revenir enfin c'est moment F2 qui tombe
ouais
mais ça peut ça peut c'est pas
complètement exclu
quoi incroyable quand même all d'avoir
fait autant
d'erreurs et maintenant de
suer
bonne soirée Spike spigle passe un passe
une bonne soirée amuse-toi bien fais-toi
plaisir estce qu'on verit pas une petite
pause ouais finalement ça me va de faire
une pause on revient on voit un peu ce
que ça donne Carau ici allez à tout de
suite les amis à tout
[Musique]
suite
he
he he he he
he he he
he he
[Musique]
he
alors mesdames et
messieurs on est de
retour au mauvais
endroit on dit tout le monde a fait nul
ahah voilà il a fait
nulou bon écoute très bien on pensait
que ça allait encore tourner ça vient de
faire nul on pe scénario où les mon le
roi ESS de prendre H5 après il peut
bouger vers G4 tu sur la seconde rangere
en tout cas s'il y a un camp qui peut
tenter c'est plus noir pas dire que ça
gagne mais en tout cas ok bon ben nul
c'est fait tant mieux tant mieux pour
les resza qui prend pas le bouillon
c'est dommage de Pasir gagner vu la
position qu'il avait il était il était
gagnant et euh donc voilà donc il reste
iarou alors je sais pas si tu veux qu'on
suive un peu ou si on fait jusqu'à la
fin du Z not par que jusqu'au 6e il
reste 33 secondes à chez parinov oui qui
peut craquer je pense que ça peut jouer
vite quoi
h surtout contre un
tel donc fou nul euh pour ceux qui
étaient pas là bah nul de tout le monde
en fait enfin marquan a perdu mais nul
de nul de Baky nul de Maxime nul d'Ali
Reza défaite de marcan je crois si j'ai
pas défi de défaite de Sophie et défaite
de Pauline en tout cas les positions
étaient très
mauvaises donc il y aura ni français ni
française au candidat via le le grand
Suisse voilà et euh pour les candidats
le dernier espoir donc c'est une Calif
àéo de Reza qui bah c'est pas fait mais
justement c'est pour ça qu'on
s'intéresse à à Naka s'il gagne cette
partie qui se qualifie via le grand
Suisse et ben peut-être ça libérera une
place allez l' mais ce sera pas encore
fait mon
Fab et param qui gagne on n dit hein
param qui é gagnant ouais Param
al c'est pas signé mais bon il a son
pioncé et tout mais grosse partie de
param je crois ouais param monstrueux
hein bravo
param énorme joueur param et Naka plus
que 20 secondes hein
pour chez parinov le sait-il ne le
sait-il
pas courresponsable en plus à jouer dur
hein et là tu peux avoir la tremblotte
hein mais euh
j'ai ça fait le scénio d'hier en fait
comme comme by contre car c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont si forts qui a trois retours
ah pas de chance ça c'est une gaffe
monsieur
chearinov bah mais
bon param 27 44 param on le prend pour
un con on sait pas trop pourquoi
d'ailleurs mais juste parce qu'il a fait
un misck une fois contre B en fait non
mais juste
uneou 5 regarde tuas pas l'air d'être
bien du coup depuis on le prend un peu
pour un con mais sinon il est hyper fort
ah oui très beau joueur
bah nous il était au nouvel an avec nous
hein il y a 2 ans ouais bon nouvel an
avec param mais d'ailleurs il est très
drôle très sympa moi j'ai beaucoup aimé
hein c'était beau quand on ma dit que
Ludwig était
1500 do you play chess yes what's your
rating f00
quoi bon ça c'était magnifique il
regardé après
1500 il comprenait pas en fait
par il a complètement éclaté de
r nous mis dans le livreas mis son
anniversaire ou pas pas peutêtre pour la
prochaine édition fa rajouter quand même
si je vouis les candidat on pourra hein
par Lou j'auris rien très talentueux
machin moi j'aime bien il est gentil il
est gentil
par et moi voiture rating
ah je ferme les
trucs ça fait
nul ça va échanger
puis
trop pas qu'il aille te Bou
bon si tuas vraimentvie H3
ouais je crois que tu peux te dire ou
pas le plus important des pions
coucou qui revient qui se demande
qu'est-ce qu'ils font c'est bon quand
même les échecs tu as le temps de faire
toute une journée de faire des vrais
trucs et de faire des vrais trucs
et bah là c'est juste cavalier pr là
c'est termin non cavalier prend pu on
prend tour à 6 roi bouge et on monte non
ah ça a l'air bien gagnant mais
non
mais je sais pas ce que tu en penses
d'un truc bizarre c'est le pion à
[Musique]
7 du coup on faire
suiteok on mon ça ça gagne as
raison facile
oui surtout tu auras direct
tu comment dire genre le S fait ça
admettons
ça là tu un peu bloqué là tu es bloqué
ou donc faut que tu te
rapproche va te
prendre je pas de passer par
là
il plus le
[Musique]
temps truc marrant
5 là pour défendre
le8 mais sinon on pe aussi just on F5
aller prendre g et ça on n arrive pas à
gagner
euh je sais pas
ça doitre
gagnant on a trop un be roi quand même
ouais mais
bon car qui va revenir en tête a
compagnie de param et qui rejoint donc
le quiuor ça fait un un six Tuor com al
en fait tu fait comme
ça B ton tour
F4 fais tour D4 là tu voas les tour A4
donc tu peux pas t 3 ouais mais du coup
tu fais à6
5 je pense qu'il te joue ah oui oui je
suis d'accord
ouais non il a coupé en fait
malheureusement grégoride
he il manque quelques colonnes
quoi
coupé encore un Lyonnais qui coûte cher
for Sainté
ouais mais bon il a quand même joué chez
l'ennemi Fab
ouais malheureusement mais euh pe pas
trop lu vouloir en fait il on l'a vendu
mais on était content de le vendre à
l'époque on était complètement
fauché c un nos seuls jouur B Cabal et
bon vas-y tiens on te vend aprè a fait
une très belle carrière ouais ouis très
fort plus fort que réy Vercoutre ah oui
bah
oui pas
comparable il a jamais vraiment été
titulaire en équipe de France non ou pas
très longtemps bah s'est pris bartez
ouais et après et après il y a pas eu du
Landro qui l'a dépassé non non il était
là mais après ça a été bah le temps de
monanda Loris ou quoi mais il est je
pense qu'il étaé titulaire à l'Euro 2008
mais qui a pas été euh mémorable non on
a perdu au premier tour on c'était fait
défoncé par les Pays-Bas je crois en
[Musique]
poule l'endro pour les P ouais
ouais 2006 j'aurais pu mériter mais euh
bah vu le parcours qu'on a fait tu vois
on peut pas se dire que c une CAN de
mettre BZ
quoi puis puis t'apporte un calme partê
enfin tu es rassuré quoi de la brocage
aussi donc
bon mais sur ce qu'ils avaient fait sur
la saison il ouais cétait le meilleur
gardien à ce moment-là mais
bon
POS des question tellement bizarres sur
Twitter est-ce que Carls n pas
joué du
Qatar pour pouvoir se qualifier àé au
candidatalif par la Coupe du
Monde question bizarre en
fait je sa pas veul trop chercher des
trucs où il a rien
chercher chercher les explications quand
il y en a pas il jouent juste pour
argent enfin mais très souvent dans
beaucoup de de domaines de la vie c'est
l'argent
le la raison en fait pas souvent à
chercher plus loin
quoi ah je pense pour jouer au Qatar
c'était
peut-être pris 200 3000 je ce que c'est
le truc mais oui ça devit être quelque
chose peutêtre 500000 je sais pas ouais
peut-être 200 peut-être 300 peut-être
5000 € on peut pas savoir mais par que
je dire sportivement ça lui apporte rien
pu ça se voit qu'il a pas du tout envie
de jouer donc ouais sa pourquoi il y
allit hein mais tant mieux pour lui mais
c'est pas reproche mais c'est il y a pas
à chercher autre chose
he jouer aux échecs pour l'argent bah
oui enfin quand tu vas jouer en club ou
quoi c'est pas pour le le
plaisir bah non mais peutir du plaisir
ici ou là aussi
[Musique]
mais mais en fait aller au Qatar c'est
pas très plaisant en
fait bah surtout qu'il a plus envie de
jouer aux échec ça se voit je sais pas
comme si tu
vas dans le sud ou dans les îles ou je
sais pas tu vois enfin ou tu pars avec
tes amis à faire un truc
enfin là ça ouaissvieou
éche ah oui tu tu GES de l'argent j en
club enfin après tu en gagne selon ton
niveau et mais en général les joueurs
titrés sont rémunéré pour jouer donc
après ça négocie plus plus plus haut
plus bas plus c plus ça euh et selon ton
classement
et et l'argent qu' a le club et tout ça
tu en a qui peuvent juste dire oh non ça
c'est une équipe de pot joue là enfin
peu importe mais la plupart du temps oui
c'est bien param à gagner param 6 et
demiin ouais méritant méritant param il
travaille beaucoup en ce moment et ça ça
ça paye je crois qu'il est vraiment bien
au classement ho là il monte à
27 bientôt 50 he je dirais il était 27
44 mais je pense avant je crois qu'il y
a pas encore le résultat ah si 27 44 45
en fait
donc ah ouais il est il est il est
égalité top 10 mondial quoi et
honnêtement quand tu vois un
carakin Dominguez et rajabov devant tu
te dis
bon ça peut
passer ça
peut ça peut ça
peut qu'il passe à en fait il aur point
par qu'il a que 22 points de retard sur
s'il continue à jouer comme un
maladea c'est une catar son
Touri
wou et alors qu'il jouit des bonnes
parties tu VO contre mamedov bon cétait
pas idéal mais ça allait contre
jamakanov il a quand même fait une bonne
partie l'adversaire bon il se trouve
qu'il a tout trouvé mais c'était pas mal
abassov c'était bien nan ça allit quand
même et après artemief Sarana svion et
aujourd'hui c'est kata
h Alice allit que en en régressant le de
mal en pie de mal en pie ouais alors que
le début était plutôt
prometteur
g c'est
incroyable il était il était top 6 7
mondial il a perdu turb enous de 2007 il
fait quoi contre un PL
non il a perdu
CUB qu'est-ce qui lui
arrive à vrai
dire plus dansutre
il perd des points à chaque partie qui
joue quoi va mieux arrêter de jouer
quand c'est comme ça ah ouais il peut il
peut se
retrouver il sera peut-être qualifié via
les Grands Prix machin écoute je crois
pas en fait mais il a bien jouer où en
fait en Coupe du Monde il jou quoi c'est
pas B
site bon sa pas tu peux le voir sur
circuit 2023 ouais
ouais
Coupe du Monde il a fait carte finale
non c'était pas mal il perd
Carlsen je sais pas trop ce qu'il a fait
en fait
ou c'est en début de saison les temps à
fermer les
machins c'est fou de passer le Grand
Prix sans rien avoir gagné quand même
je crois pas qu'il va passé enfin mon
avis sa va le griller
quoi sa joue un tournoi pas lui et et sa
doit juste genre finir pas si mal
quoi g tu peux te trouver mieux que 5èe
H pour
ça ça don quand même pas mal de Punto
parce que
c'était c'est une grosse
moyenne mais g c'est la descente aux
enfers c'est assez
étonnant t différence au niveau
pareil on m'a dit qu'en Blitz il était
vraiment pas top c'était vu contre
Maxime donc blit c'est quand même le
talent P
quoi euh on est au 57e
coup
vite mais c'est Naka et carwana quand
même auudessus de la mlée auudessus de
la mélé au de la mêl
ouais non mais d' cas il faut qu'il soit
candidat ça c'est
évident non mais j'ai mal à voir comment
il serait pas en fait non mais il va
être àé l au pire enfin il sera il
mérite ça se voit qu'il est plus
fort et pour les départages alors ceux
qui sont là par qu'en fait je crois
est-ce que param a un meilleur départage
que Naka
non c'est quandme une question
subsidiaire parce que s'il jouent
ensemble peut-être qu'ils vont faire le
truc
non mais je crois qu'il en faut beaucoup
encore pour nak il est 2673 et param é
2646 il faut quand même pas mal
pour monter la moyenne
quoi demain 6 et dem tu vas avir qui tu
vas
avircipen
vidit kwana
carwana Naka et
makulou donc 6 hommes pour de
places
5 hommes pour de places en fait ouais 5
hommes pour deux
places et Naka il a déjà joué
qui supporte de Naka en fait c'est
terrible il a joué vidit il a jouer SP
il va jouer des Hatch il va jouer nak il
va jouer param ou Fabi un jour sa pas et
pour les couleurs il doit avoir les
noirs qui demande les blancs d Hatch
demande les
blancs c'est tout ça peut être des Hatch
Naka euh
vidit en ils veulent tous les noirs en
fait donc un moment mais ça peut être
vidit
[Musique]
param Fabi Jo
oui je crois je crois Fabi je crois
qu'il a joué tout le monde en fait ouais
Fabi a joué si Penko des HAAC non mais
du coup Fabi il peut
jouer param il peut jouer param ou Naka
en fait c'est
tout pe jouer par ça peut être ça al ça
peut être D et sipinko
ou vidit et d ici peno param et les deux
Américains ce qui dérangerait pas
forcément Naka vra dire parce que s'il
fait nul enfin tu vois parce qu'à la
moyenne il est pas enfin au départage il
est pas si mal à vrai dire derère tuas
les blanc tu vois ce que tu as faire
ouais c'est ça en fait si tu fais nul
contre carwana ça te permet de remonter
un peu ta moyenne ça te replacera de
manière très sûre devant des
mecs en fait même même vidit quoi il
sera pas forcément ça va être chaud quoi
mais je pense ça être ça en fait je
pense êre carwana Naka
demain belle affiche et si
pienko face à
paramenko blanc et d Hatch DCH blanc
H et Naka la dernière au blanc
quoi
contre benut-être des qui vont revenir
avec eux sera 7 ou
après puis dans ça il peut y avoir des
décisif ou pas ça se jouera à de toute
façon énorme troupeau C enemi
pour moi ça se joue à
peut se tromper
évidemment j'pre que er leur passe
devant il mérite tellement bon ouais
enfin pas plus que sinon il serait
devant s
méritait bon a va gagner je sais pas si
on attend il peut réfléchir encore ils
sont au 60e
là donc il seendre un quart d'heure donc
soit ça le déprime il l'abandonne soit
il peuticher un quart d'heure et ça joue
encore un peu qu'on a encore une
demi-heure quoi
je pense qu'on jusqu'au bout au bout
bout pour la cas de notre côté aussi
he mais il peut aussi abandonner là
non
tour à 4 on
disait
F5
5 4 je pense que tour
D78 tour
A7 t prend G4 t
H7 et le
tric
trict là 30 secondes avant 140e enfin
160e force de la nature Nakamura quand
mêmee façon tac on peut aussi à priori
faire D5
non
VO la tour A4 ro C5 tour
g476 et fin G4 3
B7 pardon écheque tour B6 on rest
peut-être même tour
à6 ça ça gagne toujours justir quand le
roi
grégoryi tu reviens en cours et tu le
cuueilles là normalement c'est abandon
en fait
hein des parti je sais pas qui ou quoi
enfin pour euh
alors donc carwan de
nulitepenko nul er FF nul Sarana perdu
contre param kzubov svant nul bien
évidemment B qui pr que nul aussi
VO aronia nul sindarov mvel nul keer qui
a battu NiAl Sarine nan vitugof nul et
après bon on est au niveau des points
d'aliza de gens qui sont qui est en
train de gagner contre mamedov attention
pour pour le pour le hlo ça peut avoir
sa part
d'importance te qui s'écroule contre
terahakan jumabayev qui s'écroule le Pr
pranda le maître kazak qui perd contre
douuda là je crois qu'il a un coup dur
le maî kou il s défoncé tout partout
ouais yongi contre Sarich nul il a
retenu les leçons abov qui a battu glura
kuboev qui a battu chankland ner qui a
fait nul contre artémief Korobov qui
gagne contre svanux shirof qui fait
nulle rapide
[Musique]
est que à moin fait mais bon c'est pas
le même niveau de jeu ça joue plus à
2009 là c'est dur c'est dur Fab c'est
très dur no qui est en train de perdre
contre mat
Bartel le mieux pour nos amis
québécois faitorme de grand
d'ailleursfko
contid
côté donc qui a perdu mzine qui a battu
royale
Wagner nul P qui su qui fait
nul que il marque des petits
[Musique]
points défoncer par
kak il
fait che
ok normal et ben voilà
merci à tous merci à
tous et à demain non mais voilà comme
vous disais il y a si joueurs en tête on
s'attend demain les appar fa attendre
qu'il sortte mais ce qu'on vous disait
c'est probablement Naka qui va monter
Fabiano carwana gros gros gros affich on
risque d'avoir des Hatch face àdit et
param contre donc des belles affiches ça
joue la gagne ça joue laif candidat mais
derrière pas oublier que ça peut revenir
tout c'est des nuls ça pas remonter
c'est chaud un joueur comme CER pour
arriver du diable vaaut prês de que faut
pas oublier peut-être il pe en gagner
une le diable va vert qui peut qui peut
être là quoi donc donc voilà on vous en
dira plus quand on aura les appariments
et on vous dit rendez-vous demain alors
demain on revient à l'horaire normal
demain c'est 15h30 après sera 15h HE 15
attention chaque jour ça change il
faudrait pas trop prendre des habitude
quand même merci à